OH GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
WELCOME BACK TO BUDGET SUB THREE
VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE, NOT
EXCITED ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE
PROJECTED FOR THIS YEAR, BUT I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND SOME COMMON
GROUND. WHAT CUTS HURT US THE
LEAST AMOUNT AND WHAT CUTS AND
DELAYS WERE REALLY NOT BRINGING,
UM, YEAR DOWN THE LINE IMPACT ON
OUR MOST VULNERABLE BECAUSE WE
ALL KNOW IN SUB THREE, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LITERALLY ALL
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. HEALTH,
UH, ACCESS EQUITY AND SO FORTH
ON EVERY THINK YOU COULD THINK
ABOUT FROM HOMELESS PREVENTION,
UM, TO JUST BEING A SUCCESSFUL
HUMAN BEING, FROM OUR FIRST
BREATH TO THE LAST BREATH AS WE
ALSO LOOK ABOUT, UH, LOOK INTO
OUR PROTECTING THAT SILVER
TSUNAMI THAT'S COMING IN, WITH
THE OLDER POPULATION FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS AT A RECORD
RATES. YOU SEE, MY COLLEAGUES
HAVEN'T JOINED ME YET. BUT WE
HAVE ONE CENTER THAT WON'T BE
HERE, SENATOR MAN. UM BUT
BESIDES THAT, UM, I WANTED TO
GET STARTED BEFORE SO WE CAN GET
OUT OF HERE TO DECENT TIME. I
HAVE TO DRIVE HOME TODAY. SO
THAT'S A SIX HOUR DRIVE BACK TO
L. A UM, THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE
GONNA CUT OFF CONVERSATIONS FOR
ABOUT MOST VULNERABLE. IT JUST
MEANS THAT II I I'M NOT A GOOD
DRIVER AT NIGHT. SO LET'S THERE
BE SOME DAYLIGHT AS I'M DRIVING
HOME WITH PRECIOUS CARGO. OK, SO
, UH, WE KNOW THAT IN RELATION
TO PUBLIC COMMENTS WE ARE NÓ
LONGER DOING, UM, VIRTUAL PUBLIC
COMMENT, UH, YOU HAVE TO
PHYSICALLY FLY A PLANE DRIVE TO
SACRAMENTO TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THINGS THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTING YOU. UM WE WILL BE
DOING PUBLIC COMMON A LITTLE
DIFFERENT KIND OF SIMILAR,
SOMEWHAT SIMILAR TO WHAT WE WHAT
Y'ALL DID BEFORE THE, UH, THE
PANDEMIC. WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER EACH
DEPARTMENT. UM AND SO THAT
PERHAPS DEPARTMENT HEADS WILL
STILL BE HERE LISTENING TO
STAKEHOLDER. UM INPUT AND SO
FORTH, AND WE CAN HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ON THAT SO AFTER
EACH ISSUE WITHIN EACH
DEPARTMENT, I'LL HAVE PEOPLE
COME UP IN PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
GO FOR ONE MINUTE. I THINK I'VE
RAMBLED ENOUGH. I THOUGHT MAYBE
SOMEONE ELSE WOULD JOIN ME. BUT
WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED. UM IF
YOU DON'T REMEMBER, I LIKE TO
INTERJECT SOME SOME HUMOR INTO
MY SHARE SHIP TO KEEP US ALL
AWAKE. UM, THROUGHOUT THIS, ALL
OK, GIVEN THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
STARTED. WE HAVE, UH, SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS. WE'RE GONNA GO
OVER. TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO DO
THE OVERALL HÌ, HÌ, S¼ AND ALL
THE WONDERFUL DEPARTMENTS UNDER
THAT WE'RE GONNA DO CALIFORNIA
HEALTH FACILITIES FINANCING
AUTHORITY, UM, AND SOME
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY AND OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING.
ANOTHER HEALTH CARE ACCESS. IT'S
M. ACCESS AND HEALTH CARE,
ACCESS AND INFORMATION. AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA. SO LET'S
START OFF WITH, UM, CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
PROVIDING US WITH AN OVERVIEW
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK L, A Ó
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR YOUR
WONDERFUL SUPPORT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. I WILL HAVE YOU. BEGIN
IN PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW. RIGHT?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, UH
BRENDAN MCCARTHY, DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR PROGRAM AND FISCAL
AFFAIRS AT CAL HÌ HÌ S¼. I'LL BE
BRIEF YOU AGENDA DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF LAYING OUT THE
OVERVIEW OF THE AGENCY BUDGET
OVERALL. UM, WE OVERSEE THE 12
DEPARTMENTS AND FIVE OFFICES
WITHIN CAL HÌ HÌ S¼ COORDINATING
ACTIVITIES BETWEEN OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES,
PROVIDING HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES TO THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND AT RISK CALIFORNIANS AND
PUBLIC. SERVICES TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. UM THROUGHOUT OUR
WORK. OUR AGENCY VISION IS TO BE
A PERSON CENTERED, EQUITY
FOCUSED AND DATA DRIVEN, AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
TRY TO EMBED IN ALL THE WORK
THAT WE DO WITH OUR DEPARTMENTS
AND OFFICES. UM SPEAKING ABOUT
THE BUDGET OVERALL BUDGET FOR
AND THESE ARE ALL NUMBERS ARE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROJECTED
BUDGET. YOUR BUDGET? UM I'M SO
SORRY. COULD YOU GIVE ME YOUR
NAME OF COURSE TITLE. BRENDAN
MCCARTHY, DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
PROGRAM AND FISCAL UM, FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR, WE'RE PROJECTING A
TOTAL BUDGET ACROSS THE AGENCY
SO, INCLUDING ALL DEPARTMENTS
AND OFFICES OF $252 BILLION OF
TOTAL FUNDS OF THAT $74 BILLION
AS GENERAL FUND, $38 BILLION
OTHER STATE FUNDS AND THEN $140
BILLION OF FEDERAL FUNDS. OF THE
STATE FUNDS, MOSTLY GENERAL
FUND, BUT NOT EXCLUSIVELY. JUST
OVER HALF OF THAT IS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. MOSTLY ME, 20% OR SO
IS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. 9% IS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. 7% IS 1991 REALIGNMENT
. AND THEN THERE'S ABOUT 12% IN
OTHER AREAS ACROSS THE AGENCY.
WE HAVE JUST OVER 39,000
EMPLOYEES IN OUR DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES. SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
TO Kò HÌ S¼ ITSELF, THE AGENCY.
OUR TOTAL BUDGET FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR IS $947 MILLION. IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THAT OF THAT
$647 MILLION OF IT IS FUNDS IN
THE OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS INTEGRATION THAT IS
THE OFFICE THAT WAS FORMALLY
KNOWN AS THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION. THEY WORK WITH OUR
DEPARTMENTS ON MAJOR PROJECTS,
AND SO THOSE THAT THAT LARGE
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS $647 MILLION
ARE ESSENTIALLY THEM WORKING ON
MAJOR IT PROJECTS SO THE FUNDING
COMES FROM OUR DEPARTMENTS, AND
IT IS A MIX OF GENERAL FUND AND
FEDERAL FUNDS AND OTHER FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE
IT PROJECTS. UM. WE ALSO HAVE A
FAIRLY LARGE INCREASE IN THE
AGENCY BUDGET THIS YEAR OF $255
MILLION IN THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY AND YOUTH RESTORATION,
YOU'LL BE HEARING THAT NEXT THAT
REFLECTS TRANSFER OF GRANT
FUNDING, WHICH IS A TOPIC THAT
YOU WILL BE ADDRESSING IN YOUR
AGENDA, SO IT IS A LARGE
INCREASE IN THE AGENCY'S BUDGET
THIS YEAR AS THOSE GRANTS COME
OVER TO AGENCY UM, THE WHAT WE
CALL THE OFFICE OF THE SECRET
ITSELF HAS A BUDGET OF $37
MILLION AND THAT IS EXCLUDING
THINGS LIKE Ó Y èC R AND Ó Tð
S¼ I UM, IN THE AGENCY. WE HAVE
JUST OVER 550 POSITIONS OF THAT
THE 409 OF THEM ARE IN Ó Tð S¼
I SO THE LION'S SHARE ARE
THEY'RE WORKING ON I Tð PROJECTS
WITH OUR DEPARTMENTS. THERE ARE
88 PEOPLE DIRECTLY UNDER THE
SECRETARY 37 UNDER Ó, Y, èC, R
AND 15 UNDER THE RECENTLY
ESTABLISHED CENTER FOR DATA,
INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION, WHICH
PULLED TOGETHER SOME EXISTING IT
AND OTHER INNOVATION ACTIVITIES
IN THE AGENCY THAT TO HELP
BETTER COORDINATE DATA.
INNOVATION WITHIN AGENCY AND ALL
OUR DEPARTMENTS. AND THEN LASTLY
, WE JUST WE HAVE SEVEN
POSITIONS IN THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL. UH, THAT'S A
VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW. I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
YOU OR THE OTHER MEMBERS HAVE.
SEMINAR QUESTIONS FOR EACH
DEPARTMENT OR EACH SECTION
DEPARTMENT. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADD ANYTHING? AND TELL ME WHO'S
WHO. JOSEPH DALS AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. UH, NOTHING FURTHER
CAN THANK YOU. BRIAN MILLER. L A
Ó, UH, NOTHING TO ADD, BUT
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PHYLLIS'S
DIVE INTO ISSUE TWO. THE OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. Ó Y èC R
OVERVIEW.
WE GOTTA STOP MEETING LIKE THIS.
WE ALWAYS YEAH. NÓ. IT'S GOOD.
IT'S GOOD. UM I ASKED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PRESENTERS COME
UP AND PRESENT AND ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS. AND THE WAITING FOR
HER TO COME UP TO SOME SLIDES TO
SHARE. OK? OK, SO, UM, SHOULD I
GO AHEAD WITH THE SLIDES? GO
AHEAD. OK UM I FIRST UM THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME BE HERE TODAY
. I KNOW THAT WE WERE RECENTLY
HERE AND SO I'M NOT GONNA GO
OVER ANY OF THE INFORMATION
THAT'S CONTAINED IN THE
DOCUMENTS, BUT I DID WANT TO
EMPHASIZE A FORWARD FOCUS. AND
IF I COULD, MADAM CHAIR MAY I
JUST GIVE A BRIEF OPENING
STATEMENT? PLEASE. OK, SO, UM.
THE FURTHER THE YOUTH GET INTO
THE CARCERAL SYSTEM. UH, WE MOVE
WE SEE A SIGNIFICANT
OVERREPRESENTATION OF LATINO
BLACK AND NATIVE YOUTH IN LONG
TERM INCARCERATION, ULTIMATELY
THIS END TO END SYSTEM
TRANSFORMATION. UH, WILL REQUIRE
CHANGES IN CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS
AROUND CULTURE, DISTRIBUTION OF
RESOURCES, ALLOCATION OF
RESPONSIBILITIES AND DEFINITION
OF ROLES. IT IS NOT AN INSTANT
PIVOT, BUT IT IS OUR NORTH STAR,
AND WE MUST BE RELENTLESS. FOCUS
ON IT. AS YOU WILL HEAR TODAY
ABOUT, UH, WHEN WE DISCUSS THE
DATA Ó I èC R REMAINS VIGILANT
THAT THE AVAILABILITY OF S¼ Y Tð
F AT THE LOCAL LEVEL DOES NOT
RESULT IN NET WIDE IN NET
WIDENING EFFECT THAT INCREASES
THE USE OF LONG TERM
INCARCERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE
FOR WHOM ALTERNATIVES ARE
AVAILABLE. AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ADJUDICATED FOR SERIOUS OFFENSES
AND SENT TO S¼ Y Tð S¼, WE MUST
BE ENSURED THAT WE DO NOT JUST
HAVE THE MOST MINIMAL STANDARDS
BUT RATHER CONDITIONS THAT
SUPPORT HEALING ENVIRONMENTS
THAT DO NOT RE TRAUMATIZE
PROGRAMMING THAT ENGAGES THE
MIND AND BODY AND CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS, PROVIDING HOPE
STRONG EDUCATIONAL AND
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT PREPARE
YOU FOR FUTURE SUCCESS AND STEP
DOWN SERVICES TO LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS AS SOON AS
IS, UM AS SOON AS WE CAN, AND
THAT THE YOUTH ARE SUPPORTED IN
THE COMMUNITY AND LIVING, UH,
UH, WRAPPED IN HIGH TOUCH MODELS
IN THE COMING YEAR. THERE ARE OF
OPPORTUNITIES, SOME SYSTEMIC AND
SOME BASED ON PILOTS OF NEW
APPROACHES. SYSTEMICALLY THE
CHILDREN'S YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE IN CAL AIM
WILL BE POTENTIAL RESOURCES BOTH
FOR FRONT AND PREVENTION AND
DIVERSION AND FOR BACK END
HEALING AND REENTRY. Ó Y CR IS
WORKING WITH DHCS TO BE SURE
THERE ARE RULES FOR CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS AND WE ARE DIRECTLY
FUNDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL èC B S¼ TO INCREASE THE
PARTICIPATION OF ENHANCED CARE
MANAGERS. COMMUNITY HEALTH. FROM
A TORRES REPRESENTATIVES AND
COACHES. OUR OMBUDS PROGRAM IS
NOW FULLY STAFFED AND
OPERATIONAL AND AVAILABLE TO
HELP INDIVIDUAL YOUTH ADDRESS
AND HOPEFULLY RESOLVE ANY
VIOLATION OF THEIR RIGHTS WILL
BE WORKING WITH OUR NEWLY
CREATED YOUTH ADVISORY BOARD,
ALONG WITH A REJUVENATED STATE
ADVISORY COUNCIL TO IDENTIFY AND
SUPPORT THE CRITICAL HINGE
POINTS FOR COMMUNITY RESPONSES.
WE ARE PARTNERING WITH A
SECONDARY AND POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION PROVIDERS, BOTH OF THE
STATE AND COUNTY LEVEL TO
STRENGTHEN LINKAGES AND PATHWAYS
FOR USED TO ACCESS HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WE ARE PARTNERING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION ON A PILOT
INITIATIVE IN 10 COUNTIES TO
BRING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
VOCATIONAL SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
TO YOUTH IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM,
BOTH IN THE CARCERAL SETTING AND
AS THEY STEP OUT INTO
COMMUNITIES, BUT WHAT ARE WE
MISSING? MOST IMMEDIATELY DATA
GOOD GRANULAR INFORMATION THAT
SHOWS US WHERE WITHIN EACH
JURISDICTION, THERE IS EXEMPLARY
ENGAGEMENT AS WELL AS WHERE
THERE ARE MISSED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OFF RAMPS FROM SYSTEMS.
CULTURAL CHANGE IS DEPENDENT
UPON SELF-AWARENESS, AND WE'LL
BE WORKING WITH ALL OUR PARTNERS
. LOCAL èC B S¼ SCHOOLS,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, SOCIAL
SERVICES, WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT,
PROBATION AND ADVOCATES TO
ACHIEVE THE GREATEST POSSIBLE
TRANSPARENCY IN THIS PROMOTE A
SEAMLESS SYSTEMS THAT PUTS THE
WELFARE OF ALL YOUTH, INCLUDING
OUR YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AT THE CENTER OF
OUR EFFORTS, I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND GO TO THE DATA NOW. HERE
THIS FIRST SLIDE DEMONSTRATES
THAT THE COMMITMENT OF YOUTH TO
S¼ Y Tð F S¼. WE HAVE THE 2022
AND THE 2023 DATA. AS YOU CAN
SEE, THERE LOOKS TO BE AN
INCREASE OF 80% BETWEEN THOSE
TWO YEARS. I WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT JUDGES WERE NOT ABLE TO
SEND YOUTH TO THE LOCAL, UM TO
Dð JJ ANY LONGER AFTER JULY 2021
. SO THE FIRST YEAR THAT WE SEE
THE 2122 WAS THE FIRST YEAR
JUDGES STARTED SENDING KIDS TO
THE LOCAL S¼ Y Tð F S¼. I ALSO
WANTED TO INDICATE THAT IN
JANUARY OF 2020 THREE, THERE
WERE STILL 410 YOUTH AT Dð, JJ
AND Dð JJ CLOSED FOREVER AND FOR
GOOD ON JUNE 30TH OF 2020 THREE.
I THINK A LIKELY EXPLANATION FOR
THIS INCREASE THAT WE SEE
BETWEEN THE YEARS IS THAT 140
YOUTH FROM Dð JJ WENT INTO THE
LOCAL FACILITIES. SO IF YOU SO
IF YOU DO THE MATH THAT'S REALLY
50 NEW ADMINS BETWEEN 2021 AND
2020. THREE. IF YOU DON'T COUNT
THE Dð JJ KIDS AND I HAVE MORE
DETAILS ON WHAT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THOSE 410 KIDS FROM Dð JJ,
UH, IF YOU WOULD LIKE THAT. I'M
GONNA I'LL TAKE MY QUESTION. SO
OK HERE, UH, THE SECOND SLIDE
TALKED. IT LOOKS, UM AT GENDER
AND AS YOU CAN SEE THAT MOST OF
THE COMMITMENTS ARE MALE. THE
FEMALE AND NON BINARY COUNTS
WERE FOR 2021 22 WERE FEWER THAN
12 TO PROTECT PRIVACY OF THOSE
YOUTH, UH, CAPTURED IN 20 A B
102. WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE EXACT NUMBERS, BUT
THEY'RE LOW. THIS GENDER
BREAKDOWN IS CONSISTENT WITH
POPULATIONS WE SEE THROUGHOUT
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WITH REGARD TO RACE, UH, RACIAL
AND ETHNIC CATEGORIES WITH THE
HIGHEST COUNTS OF YOUTH
COMMITTED TO S¼ Y Tð F. IT IS
HISPANIC AND LATINX FOR BOTH
2122 AND 2220. THREE MISSING
COUNTS, UH, THAT ARE INDICATED
IN HERE ARE LOWER THAN 12. AS
YOU CAN SEE THE OVER
REPRESENTATION OF BLACK AND
BROWN INDIVIDUALS WITHIN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN FISCAL YEAR
2122 LATINOS MADE UP 60% OF THE
POPULATION IN AFRICAN AMERICANS
MADE UP. UH, 30% OF THE
POPULATION. SIMILARLY IN FISCAL
YEAR 2023 22 LATINOS MADE UP A
LITTLE OVER 60% AFRICAN AMERICAN
OR BLACK REPRESENTED 25% OF THE
POPULATION. THEN THERE'S THE AGE
COUNTS. UM IN FISCAL YEAR, 2122
THE AVERAGE AGE OF YOUTH
COMMITTED TO THE S¼ Y Tð F WAS
17.4 YEARS IN FISCAL YEAR 2220
THREE. IT WAS 18.1 AND I'LL GO
AHEAD. UH, AND HOLD ANY
QUESTIONS. UM, YOU CAN SEE THERE
ARE SOME, UH, THE SCOPE IS 14 TO
25 IN THIS CHART. OK NEXT SLIDE.
UM THIS IS, UH, WITH REGARD TO
THE TYPE OF OFFENSE COMMITTED.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF YOUTH
OFFENSES COMMITTED WERE ASSAULT,
ATTEMPTED HOMICIDE COMPLETED
HOMICIDE AND ROBBERY. I THINK
THIS CHART SHOWS A WILLINGNESS
TO KEEP YOUTH WHO HAVE COMMITTED
THE MOST SERIOUS OFFENSES IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND, UH,
REHABILITATED IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES, WHICH IS CONSISTENT
WITH YOUTH DEVELOPMENT. I DO
WANNA HIGHLIGHT THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH WITH SEX OFFENSES AND NOTE
THAT THERE ARE SPECIFIC
TREATMENT NEEDS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAVE OFFENDED SEXUALLY AND
Ó Y èC R IS PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THIS
REGARD, BUT MORE DOES HAVE TO BE
DONE TO ENSURE THAT BEST AND
UNIFORMITY OF TREATMENT IS, UM,
PRESENTED THROUGH AND AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE I
AM ALSO ON THE CALIFORNIA SEX
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT BOARD, AND
WE HAVE SUGGESTED GUIDELINES
THAT CAN BE OBTAINED BY US AND
THEY ARE ALSO ON THE CASE ON
WEBSITE. THIS SLIDE STANDS FOR
THE PROPOSITION THAT THERE WAS
AN INCREASE IN THE USE OF LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS BETWEEN
FISCAL YEAR 2122 AND FISCAL YEAR
2220. THREE AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE FIRST, UM CHART. UH, VERY
FEW, UH, LESS THAN 12 YOUTH
YOUTH WERE MOVED THAT 1ST 2122,
WHICH MAKES SENSE SINCE THAT'S
WHEN YOU FIRST STARTED BEING IN
THE S¼ Y Tð S¼ AND THEN IN 2120
THREE WE HAD 100 YOUTH, UH,
REPORTED THROUGH A B 102 DATA. I
DO WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT Y èC
R HAS IDENTIFIED 90 THREE LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BY THIS
TIME IN OUR OFFICE HAS VISITED,
MANY MET WITH MANY AND HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO FUND MANY WE HAVE
STARTED AN INITIATIVE TO, UH TO
FUND 10 COUNTIES TO DEVELOP LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS. WITH
REGARD TO THE NUMBER OF YOUTH
WHOM, UH, TRANSFER HEARINGS WERE
ORDERED. THIS INDICATES A BUMP
IN, UH UH BETWEEN, UH, FISCAL
YEAR 2122 AND FISCAL YEAR 2220
THREE. UM I DO WANNA NOTE THAT
OF THIS DATA, UH, IN THE FIRST
YEAR, 139. ACTUAL HEARINGS WERE
HELD AND IN 2022, 20, 2300 AND
47. ACTUAL HEARINGS WERE HELD SO
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE ORDERED
THEY WEREN'T ALWAYS HELD.
TRANSFERS TO ADULT. UM JUST
BECAUSE THERE WAS A TRANSFER
HEARING ORDERED, AS I SAID,
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN A
HEARING WAS HELD. SOME OF SOME
OF THE CASES SETTLE. BUT IN
THESE TWO CHARTS, YOU CAN SEE
THAT THERE WAS A DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF YOUTH TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT BETWEEN FISCAL YEAR
2021 AND 22 AND 2022 23. AND
OBVIOUSLY, UM, BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
WHEN THE TIME COMES. UM I DO
WANT TO ADD THAT YOU KNOW. WHAT
DOES THIS DATA TELL US ABOUT HOW
REALIGNMENT IS BEING IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS THE STATE? THAT WAS A
SPECIFIC QUESTION. AND THEN IN
WHAT AREAS DOES THE DATA SHOW
PROGRESS IN MEETING THE GOALS OF
REALIGNMENT AND IN WHAT AREAS
DOES THE DATA INDICATE CAUSES
FOR CONCERN? FIRST AND FOREMOST,
WE CANNOT DRAW MANY CONCLUSIONS
FROM THE LIMITED DATA FROM A ONE
OR TWO ON ITS OWN. OUR TEAM IS
WORKING TO MERGE THIS DATA WITH
OTHER DATA SETS AND EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
INFORMATION IN THE COMING MONTHS
. MUCH OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
DATA LANDSCAPE IS A PUZZLE.
THERE IS NÓ UNIFORM DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEM, THE PROMISE
OF THE DATA BASE REVISION IS
STILL YEARS AWAY AT MY LAST
INFORMATION. IT WAS SIX YEARS
AWAY, SO WE HAVE TO PUT TOGETHER
A PATCHWORK OF DATA TO SEE WHAT
THE PROGRESS IS, AS WELL AS SOME
OF THE, UM JJ DATA IS SOME OF
IT'S REPORTED IN THE FISCAL YEAR
AND SOME OF IT IS REPORTED IN
THE CALENDAR YEAR CALENDAR YEAR.
AS AN EXAMPLE, IN ORDER TO MAKE
A NET WIDENING ANALYSIS. WE NEED
TO REMOVE THE Dð JJ COMMITMENTS,
WHICH WE BELIEVE WERE COUNTED AS
NEW COMMITMENTS IN THE FINAL A B
102 DATA REPORT. WE WILL BE ABLE
TO BRING IN SOME OTHER DATA AND
MERGE IT WITH OTHER DATA POINTS
AND EXPECT THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO TELL YOU ABOUT NET WIDENING.
FOR THE MOMENT. WE ARE JUST
PRESENTING FREQUENCIES. THE DATA
, AS INDICATED, IS NEW AND
DIFFERENT. AND I THINK THAT IT
DOES SHOW SOME PROMISING, UM,
PRACTICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHAT ADDITIONAL DATA WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO Ó Y èC R TO CARRY
OUT ITS MISSION IS ONE OF YOUR
LAST QUESTIONS. THIS DATA IS THE
BEGINNING, AND IT'S RELATIVELY
BASIC. IT'S A GOOD BEGINNING
BECAUSE FRANKLY, BEFORE WE HAD
IT. WE NEVER EVEN KNEW HOW MANY
KIDS WERE IN A, UM WE WERE BEING
COMMITTED TO THE FACILITY. SO AT
LEAST WE HAVE THIS ANNUAL DATA.
HOWEVER TO UNDERSTAND WHICH
YOUTH ARE SENT TO S¼ Y Tð F S¼
AND HOW TO BETTER ASSIST THEM.
WE NEED TO KNOW THE FOLLOWING
HOW MANY YOUTH ARE INVOLVED IN
THE VARIOUS STAGES OF THE SYSTEM
, FOR EXAMPLE AT ARREST
DETENTION, HOW MANY YOUTH ARE
ADJUDICATED? HOW MANY YOUTH HAVE
DISPOSITION HEARINGS? HOW LONG
DO YOU STAY IN SYSTEMS BEFORE
THEIR HEARINGS? WHAT ARE THE KEY
CHARACTERISTICS OF YOUTH
INVOLVED RACE FAMILY INCOME
CHILD WELFARE HISTORY. SPECIAL
ED PRIOR COMMITMENTS,
HOMELESSNESS. PARENTAL
INCARCERATION. HOW DID THE YOUTH
BECOME SYSTEM INVOLVED? DID THE
YOUTH COME TO US FROM ANOTHER
SYSTEM WAS THE FAMILY KNOWN TO
SYSTEMS? HOW DID THE YOUTH MOVE
THROUGH THE SYSTEM LENGTH OF
STAY KINDS OF PROGRAMS OFFERED
IS THE SYSTEM FAIRER RACE EQUITY
MEASURES THAT SHOW WHO IS
BROUGHT INTO CUSTODY AND WHO WAS
CITED AND RELEASED. WHEN DOES
THE Dð DECIDE TO FILE A TRANSFER
MOTION AND FOR WHICH YOUTH WAS A
TRANSFORMATION? NOT FILED? WE
NEED TO KNOW THAT INFORMATION BY
RACE ETH AND GENDER. HOW DID
YOUTH CHANGE IT WHILE IN THE
SYSTEM DID THE YOUTH BENEFIT
FROM OUR PROGRAM, IMPROVED
READING MATH, OTHER EDUCATIONAL
MILESTONES? DID THE YOUTH GET
RECONNECTED TO FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY? DOES THE SYSTEM MEET
THE NEEDS OF YOUTH, THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE COMMUNITY? THE
WHOLE FAMILY AND THE WHOLE CHILD
SERVICES? IS THERE IS THERE
FAMILY ABLE TO SHELTER AND CARE
FOR THEIR CHILD WHEN THE YOUTH
IS RELEASED? WHAT WAS THE
EXPERIENCE OF YOUTH IN THE
SYSTEM? HOW MUCH DOES IT COST?
AND WHAT IS THE LONG TERM
MEASURE OF SUCCESS VERSUS
RECIDIVISM DATA IS THE ONE DATA
POINT THAT EVERY COUNTY COUNTS
AND THAT IS NOT MANDATED TO BE
REPORTED TO Ó YR. BUT IT IS THE
ONE DATA POINT THAT EVERY COUNTY
COUNTS PER THEIR COUNTY PLANS.
19 COUNTIES, UM, DO ANNUAL
REPORTS. SO I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO MERGE
DATA SOURCES TO TELL THE PICTURE
WHEN WE DO OUR FINAL REPORT, BUT
THIS IS THE KIND OF, UM DATA
THAT WE WOULD NEED TO CARRY OUT
OUR THE FULL MISSION AND VISION
OF Ó Y èC R. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. TURN IT OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR ANY
COMMENTS. JOSEPH DAWSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, NOT THE
ADDITIONAL TO ADD, BUT HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. TO PERFECT
. OK SO LET'S UH JUMP INTO SOME
QUESTIONS. UM, I'LL START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
2023 BUDGET ACT. WE INCLUDED
$3.5 MILLION TO REPORT THE S¼ Y
Tð F DATA TO OUR Y èC. R CAN
YOU TALK TO US A LITTLE BIT? HOW
THIS FUNDING WAS DISTRIBUTED TO
COUNTIES AND HOW IT WAS SPENT.
HØI UH, ALISON HEWITT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, AND SO THE FUNDS
WERE ALLOCATED BASED ON WE
UTILIZED A METHODOLOGY THAT HAD
BEEN USED FOR A PRIOR JUVENILE
POT FUNDING THAT WAS AVAILABLE.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY, UM, INCLUDED
IN S¼ BE TWO THREE, SO WE
ALLOCATED FUNDS TO COUNTIES
FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD. UH, JUST
BASED ON A, UH, USE OF CENSUS
DATA TO SAY WHAT A LARGE MEDIUM
AND SMALL COUNTY WAS, AND WE DID
AS WE DO WITH OTHER TYPES OF
GRANTS. IT WAS A DIRECT
ALLOCATION TO COUNTIES AND THE
IDEA UM, CAPACITY BUILDING TO
HELP GIVEN THEIR REPORTING
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT DATA THAN
THEY HAVE BEEN REPORTING
PREVIOUSLY. SO IT WAS, UM, BUT,
UH, IN TERMS OF HOW THE FUNDS
WERE SPENT WERE ONCE WE DO THE
ALLOCATION PROCESS AND S¼ èC Ó
OR THE STATE CONTROLLER'S OFFICE
ISSUES, THE FUNDS WE WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO SAY HOW MUCH COUNTIES
EXPENDED OR HOW THEY EXPENDED IT
. UM UH, BUT WE ISSUED IT KIND
OF WITH THE INTENT AND PURPOSE
OF A CAPACITY BUILDING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND CONNECTED TO
THAT, UM DIRECTOR. UH, I KNOW
THIS IS STATEWIDE DATA, AND I
KNOW WE'RE STILL COMPILING IN
THE COUNTY DATA THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO COME UP IN DECEMBER
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO PERHAPS
COMING BACK. UH, LATER ON
TOWARDS THE END OF SUB THREE TO
TALK ABOUT ALL THAT DATA ANY
PRELIMINARY INFORMATION PER PER
COUNTY YOU CAN SHARE. IS THIS
WHAT YOU WOULD SAY THE MOST
INSIGHT YOU HAVE FOR RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, I WOULDN'T SAY IT'S THE
MOST INSIGHT, BUT I THINK IT'S
THE MOST VETTED AND CLEANED UP.
AND I DON'T WANNA, UM, YOU KNOW,
I I'M I HAVE A LOT OF ON MY MIND
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING, BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE SOME VERY
DETAILED AND VALIDATED
INFORMATION TO YOU, SENATOR.
YES. SO I THINK WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY COME BACK IN A COUPLE
OF MONTHS TOWARDS THE END TO GET
MORE DATA. SO ONE MORE QUESTION
ON THAT. YOU SPOKE ABOUT THAT
POTENTIALLY THE SKEW THAT WE SEE
HERE IN THE FIRST DATA POINT IS
THE 140 Dð JJ KIDS THAT WERE
TRANSFERRED. DID I UNDERSTAND
THAT CORRECTLY, THAT THAT'S WHY
POTENTIALLY, WE COULD SEE THE
SKEW THAT IS ONE EXPLANATION OFF
THE TOP THAT I AM SEEING BECAUSE
WE DO. WE DID WORK, AS YOU KNOW,
WITH THE CONSORTIUM TO BETWEEN
JANUARY AND JUNE, WHEN WE GOT
ALL THOSE YOUTH REALIGNED BACK
TO THEIR COUNTIES. WE WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH PROBATION AND
CONSORTIUM AND Dð JJ. AND WHAT
WE KNOW IS THAT, UM, THERE WAS,
UH, 400 YOUTH THAT HAD TO BE,
UM, RE ALIGNED. BUT LIKE, YOU
KNOW, ABSOLUTELY HAD TO LEAVE.
Dð JJ, UM AND 100 AND TWO OF
THOSE YOUTH WERE DISCHARGED
PRIOR TO CLOSURE. THREE 108 HAD
TO BE RECALLED BY THE COUNTIES
AS A RESULT OF THE Dð JJ CLOSURE
OF THESE 308, WHO HAD TO BE
RECALLED 140 WERE COMMITTED TO
S¼ Y Tð FA 136 TO THEIR OWN
COUNTY AND FOUR TO ANOTHER
COUNTY. UM I HAVE OTHER NUMBERS.
EIGHT WERE COMMITTED TO JUVENILE
HALLS. TWO WERE COMMITTED TO
OTHER COUNTY OPERATED FACILITIES
. 46 WERE COMMITTED TO LESS
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS. FOUR WENT
TO PINE GROVE, TWO WAIVED THEIR
STAY AT Dð. A I THREE WERE
COMMITTED TO A COUNTY JAIL. 77
WENT TO COMMUNITY SUPERVISION OF
THESE 11 WERE REPORTED TO BE IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. 18 WERE
DISMISSED AND DISCHARGED AND
SEVEN AT THE TIME OF THIS
REPORT. STILL PENDING
DISPOSITION IN THE COUNTIES SO
THAT 140 IS ONE EXPLANATION. SO
AS I'M LOOKING AT THE REST OF
THE DATA POINTS ESSENTIALLY, I
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT REMOVING A
ABOUT 100 AND 40 OF EACH DATA.
THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD TODAY OPINE
BECAUSE THAT THAT THAT THOSE
KIDS HAD TO BE COUNTED SOMEWHERE
AND THEY WENT TO S¼ Y Tð S¼
BECAUSE THEY WERE QUALIFIED BY
LAW. THAT'S WHERE THEY NEEDED TO
GO. AND SO THAT WOULD CERTAINLY
UM, BE A VERY GOOD EXPLANATION
FOR WHAT WE SEE BETWEEN THE TWO
YEARS. AND THEN HOW HOW DO THE
COUNTIES REPORT UP? WHO DOES IT
GO TO BE A èC èC, OR IS IT
GOING DIRECTLY TO Ó Y? èC R
WILL THE A B ONE Ó TWO DATA IS
COMING DIRECTLY TO Ó. I èC R
AND I ACTUALLY, UM NEGLECTED TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES OF THE OF THE DATA,
BUT IT DOES. IT DOES COME
DIRECTLY TO Ó Y èC R. AND WE
GOT IT IN TIME IN DECEMBER.
WE'RE JUST COMPILING IT,
ACTUALLY, UM, SO WHAT HAPPENED
WAS, UM. SEA PARK CREATED A
TEMPLATE FOR THE A B 102 DATA
SUBMISSION. THE DATA WAS
SUBMITTED TO US VIA EMAIL. ONCE
THE FORMS WERE RECEIVED, THEY
WERE REVIEWED FOR COMPLETENESS
AND STORED ON A DATA ON OUR DATA
TEAMS. UH SHAREPOINT. IF THERE
WAS MISSING OR INCONSISTENCIES
WE HAD TO REACH BACK OUT TO THE
COUNTIES 16 COUNTIES HAD TO DO
RES SUBMISSIONS OF THOSE 16
COUNTIES, UH, THERE WITH
CORRECTIONS. THREE HAD TO
RESUBMIT THREE SEPARATE TIMES,
AND ONE HAD TO RESUBMIT FOUR
TIMES. Ó Y èC R RECEIVED THE
LAST CORRECTION ON FEBRUARY 24,
WHICH IS WHEN THE A B 102 DATA
COLLECTION WAS FINALLY COMPLETE.
THERE WERE ISSUES WITH THE
CONSISTENCY. THE TRACKING AND
THE REPORTING OF THE DATA ON THE
FORUM. COUNTIES WERE PROVIDED,
UH, DATA 0.1, WHICH COVERS THE
NUMBER OF YOUTH FOR WHOM
TRANSFER HEARINGS TO ADULT
CRIMINAL WAS ORDERED THE AGE AT
THE TIME OF THE HEARING BEING
ORDERED BEGAN AT 16, HOWEVER,
ONE COUNTY ACTUALLY CHANGED
THEIR FORM. AND SO, UM, THAT
AGAIN STARTED TO SKEW THINGS AND
WE HAD TO REACH OUT TO THAT
COUNTY AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
1213 AND 14 YEAR OLDS COULD NOT
BE TRANSFERRED AND 15 YEAR OLDS.
SO THERE WAS SOME. THERE WAS
SOME ISSUES WITH THE FORM AND IN
THE FUTURE ON A GO FORWARD.
WE'RE HOPING THAT Ó Y CR
PUBLISHES THE FORMS, SO IT
MATCHES OUR DATA REQUEST. THERE
WAS EVEN, UM, THE WRONG LABELS.
THEY ASKED ABOUT FITNESS
HEARINGS. THERE ARE NÓ MORE
FITNESS HEARINGS THERE. ALL
TRANSFER HEARINGS. UM WE TRIED
TO NEGOTIATE THAT FOR, YOU KNOW,
IN ORDER TO, UM. TO WARD OFF
THIS CONFUSION, AND WE ACTUALLY
DECIDED NOT TO SEND OUT OUR OWN
TEMPLATE SO THAT THE COUNTIES
WOULD NOT BE FURTHER CONFUSED.
AND SO, BUT I'M HOPING THAT NEXT
YEAR WE'LL HAVE ALIGNMENT ON
THIS. PERFECT THAT WAS GONNA BE
MY FOLLOW UP QUESTION AS TO WHY
èC Ó TO THE TEMPLE AT US, BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE GOING FORWARD
NEXT YEAR. WE'RE GONNA BE MORE
OF THE LEAD AND SENDING THAT OUT
TO ADEQUATELY GET THE DATA
POINTS THAT WE WANT. IT WAS OUR
PREFERENCE ALWAYS TO BE THE
LEAD, AND THAT WAS A DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAD. BUT WE, UM THERE
WAS ALSO A CONCERN ABOUT TIMING
AND, UM, SO IT WAS ALWAYS OUR
INTENT TO BE THE LEAD AND WE
THINK WE SHOULD BE THE LEAD.
PERFECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR WHEN YOU SPOKE ABOUT
THE, UM INDIVIDUALS COMMITTED TO
A SECURE YOUTH TREATMENT
FACILITY FOR SEXUAL OFFENSES.
YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE WAS
MORE TO BE DONE. I THINK IF I
HEARD IT CORRECTLY, AND I'M NOT
SURE EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS, BUT
SINCE THIS IS A BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE HEARING IN HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES, I THOUGHT I
WOULD ASK HIM MAYBE WHAT THAT IS
AND WHETHER IT CARRIES A DOLLAR
FIGURE AND WHETHER YOU KNOW, TO
MAKE SURE THAT SOMEONE IS
CONSIDERED THAT THANK YOU. IS
THAT A FAIR QUESTION? YES. THANK
YOU. SERIES OF THEM, ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SO Kò ON THE
CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER
MANAGEMENT BOARD USED TO, UM
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER Dð JJ, UH
, SEX BEHAVIOR. UH,
INTERVENTIONS. SO WHEN Dð JJ
CLOSED THAT WAS NÓ LONGER. THE
CASE AND THE YOUTH WHO OFFEND
SEXUALLY ARE STILL ON THE PLANET
, AND NOW THEY'RE IN THE
COUNTIES THE Dð JJ SEX OFFENDER
THERAPY TREATMENT IS STATE OF
THE ART BEST PRACTICES. UM, WE
HAVE HIRED FORMER COUNSELOR
THERAPIST DOCTOR HUNTER TO, UM,
ON OUR STAFF TO ACTUALLY WRITE
ALL OF THE TRAINING COMPONENTS
SO THAT COUNTIES CAN BE TRAINED
UP TO USE THE, UM UH, EXACT
PROGRAMMING THAT WAS HELD AT Dð
JJ. AND THOSE ARE THE CASE ON
GUIDELINES FOR JUVENILE
OFFENDERS. SO I THINK IDEALLY,
WE WOULD BRING THE THOSE WHO
TREAT JUVENILE OFFENDERS BACK.
CASE ON. AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS DELIVERING THE BEST
POSSIBLE TREATMENT TO OUR YOUTH
OFFENDERS AND THAT THE
RECIDIVISM RATE FOR YOUTH WHO
OFFEND SEXUALLY REMAINS LESS
THAN 3% I ALSO THINK THAT WOULD
GIVE, UH STRENGTH AND COMFORT TO
THOSE THAT ARE PUBLIC SAFETY
MINDED, AND WE WOULDN'T SEE. FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT SOME OF US FEARED
WAS AN INCREASE IN TRANSFER
MOTIONS FOR JUVENILES WHO OFFEND
SEXUALLY BECAUSE THERE'S NÓ
LONGER A REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENT. SO IF WE KNEW THAT
THE TREATMENT WAS AS GOOD AS Dð
JJ AND WAS CERTIFIED BY, UH AND
YOU KNOW, OVERSEEN BY SOMETHING,
A BOARD LIKE THAT THAT WOULD
SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES, OUR
CHILDREN, EVERYONE BETTER SO I
MEAN, WE HAVE THESE YOUNG FOLKS.
IMPERATIVELY SPEAKING YOUNG
FOLKS SITTING IN SECURE YOUTH
TREATMENT FACILITIES. FOR SEXUAL
OFFENSES. WE NEED SOMEONE TO
WRITE A TRAINING PROGRAM. AND
THEN GET COUNTY PEOPLE TRAINED.
MAYBE I'VE MISSED IT. I DIDN'T
SEE ANY MONEY ATTACHED TO THIS.
MAYBE THERE IS UM. WELL, THE
TRAINING PROGRAM IS DESIGNED. IT
WAS IT'S, UH, IT'S PUBLISHED ON
THE AS I HAD INDICATED ON THE
CASE ON WEBSITE, THEY'RE
JUVENILE OFFENDER TRAINING
GUIDELINES. UM I OH, I SORRY. Ó
Y èC R IS ABLE TO TRAIN AND
THAT WOULD BE AT NÓ COST TO THE
COUNTIES. UM NOW I THINK THE, UM
THE MONEY PART MIGHT BE IN CASE
I'M HAVING TO CERTIFY AND MAYBE
EVEN THEMSELVES TRAIN THE
PROVIDERS. BUT THE COUNTIES ARE
ALREADY CONTRACTING WITH THESE
THERAPISTS. THEY'RE ALREADY
FINDING WAYS TO IN COUNTIES THAT
ARE DOING THIS WELL TO HAVE OUR
YOUTH HAVE REALLY STATE OF THE
ART INTERVENTIONS. THERE ARE
SOME COUNTIES IN ONE VERY LARGE
COUNTY THAT HAS NÓ NÓ PROGRAMS
FOR YOUTH WHO OFFEND SEXUALLY. I
JUST WANT I MEAN THE REASON I'M
ASKING. THE QUESTION IS, I'M
COMING FROM A RELATIVELY
UNINFORMED PERSPECTIVE. SO YOU
KNOW YOU CAN CORRECT ME AT ANY
POINT IN TIME. MY SKIN IS VERY
THICK AFTER 12 YEARS UP HERE.
BUT I'M SORT OF CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS, AND WE HAVE 58 COUNTIES
AND SO WHAT IS THE TIMELINE TO
BRING EVERYBODY ON BOARD? IS
THERE A REQUIREMENT BURIED
SOMEWHERE IN WHATEVER WE'VE DONE
OR THE BUDGET DOCUMENT THAT
REQUIRES EVERYBODY TO BE ON
BOARD WITH COMMON TRAINING AND A
COMMON CURRICULUM? UM. IS THERE
A DEADLINE FOR EVERYBODY TO? UH
I'M A MILITARY GUY, SO I'M USED
TO. YOU KNOW WHAT GETS MEASURED,
GETS DONE SO GOALS, OBJECTIVES
AND A PLAN OF ACTION AND I
REALIZE THAT'S SORT OF A RARE
COMMODITY UP HERE. UM AT LEAST
FOR US, UM, BUT THAT'S WHAT I'M
ASKING ABOUT. AND II. I DIDN'T.
I'M NOT CERTAIN THAT I KNOW. SO
WE ARE NOT A REGULATORY BODY. UM
OUR GOAL WAS TO HAVE EXPERTISE
ON OUR STAFF TO DO THE TRAINING
AND WE'VE DONE THAT. AND I AM
NOT BEING CRITICAL. NÓ NÓ. I'M
JUST LETTING YOU KNOW THAT I
THINK THAT Ó I èC R HAS DONE
WHAT IT CAN TO BE ON THE READY
TO TRAIN COUNTIES. UH, PROVIDERS
, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS,
PRIVATE PROVIDERS, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A IT'S A VARIETY OF WAYS
THAT YOUTH ARE BEING TREATED,
UH, GETTING THE TREATMENT IN THE
FACILITIES, SO IT'S PRIVATE
CONTRACTS. IT'S BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. SO WE'RE ON
THE READY FOR THAT. THERE IS NÓ
TIMELINE BY STATUTE THAT THIS
HAS TO BE DONE OR THAT IT EVEN
HAS TO BE DONE. THAT I'M AWARE
OF. SO THAT'S ON US. I MEAN, WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT SEX OFFENSES UP HERE AND
SEX OFFENDERS, BOTH ON THE FROM
THE PUBLIC SAFETY STANDPOINT AND
FROM DEALING WITH, UM WITH
REHABILITATION. UM. IT WAS SEEN
TO ME THAT THIS IS A PRETTY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. I GUESS YOU
WOULD AGREE. I WOULD AGREE, AND,
UM, ABSOLUTELY HAVE BEEN IN THE
POSITION OF ELEVATING IT FOR THE
WHOLE TIME THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
BECAUSE OF MY PARTICIPATION IN
MEMBERSHIP ON KOM AS WELL. WE
HAVE JUST ELEVATED IT TO THE
PLACE. IT NEEDS TO BE ELEVATED
TO. SO I'M I'M NOT LEADERSHIP.
I'M SURE WILL FIGURE THIS THING
OUT. YES MA'AM, IF I MAY, UM,
JUST FROM THE BUDGETARY PERS. I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IS WHAT
RESOURCES WERE PROVIDED TO
COUNTIES TO HELP THEM SERVE,
PROVIDE SUPERVISION AND SERVICES
FOR JUVENILE YOUTH AND TO
REQUIRE COUNTIES. TO TAKE TO
TAKE CARE OF AND ACCOUNT FOR
YOUTHS WHO ARE IN A SECURE USE
TREATMENT FACILITY FOR SEX
OFFENSES TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET THE APPROPRIATE TRAINING AND
REHABILITATION ATTENTION THAT
THEY NEED WHILE THEY ARE THERE
WHEN THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
THERE. SURE I HEAR YOU, UM HOW?
HOW THE YOUTH, I GUESS ARE WHERE
THE YOUTH ARE PLACED IS UP TO
JUDICIAL DISCRETION IN IN TERMS
OF SEX OFFENDERS SPECIFICALLY
ARE WHAT'S AVAILABLE. THE ONE
THING I WANTED TO POINT OUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS I WANTED TO
POINT OUT FROM A BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE FIRST, IS, UM,
TRAILER BILL. WE UM, WAS
INCLUDED IN THE 2122 BUDGET THAT
EXPANDED THE EXPERTISE OF KOM TO
ADD INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
SPECIFIC EXPERTISE IN IN, UM
YOUTH WHO COMMIT SEX OFFENSES
THAT DID EXPAND THE MEMBERSHIP
OF KOM. UM WE S¼ B. THREE
INCLUDED 9.6 MILLION FOR THE
REGIONAL PROGRAMS AND FACILITIES
GRANTS. A PORTION OF THAT
FUNDING WAS FOR REGIONAL, THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF REGIONAL HUBS
AND PART OF WHAT THE IDEA WAS.
THERE IS THIS THAT COUNTIES
COULD, UM, ESTABLISH REGIONAL
HUBS FOR SPECIALIZED POPULATIONS
THAT HAD SPECIFIC NEEDS, SO I
JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT.
UM UM AND THEN EACH COUNTY IS
GIVEN FUNDS THROUGH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANT,
IN ADDITION TO OTHER FUNDS TO
PROVIDE SPECIFIC SERVICES, SO I
JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT OF COLOR ON THE FUNDING
STREAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
AGAIN. I WASN'T BEING CRITICAL
OF THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS AT
ALL. I WAS JUST SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LOCAL
OPTION. UM ISSUE. AND LOCAL
OPTION, UM, WORKS. I'M A LOCAL
CONTROL PERSON MYSELF. LOCAL
OPTION WORKS SOMETIMES, BUT WHEN
IT'S A PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN, SOMETIMES
LOCAL OPTION DOESN'T WORK QUITE
AS WELL AS IT DOES IN OTHER
ASPECTS. I THANK YOU ALL FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTION. I'VE
DOMINATED THE CHAIR'S HEARING
AND I WILL STOP. IT'S OUR
HEARING, SIR. IT'S OK. OK UM, I
THINK WE'VE NÓ MORE QUESTIONS ON
THIS ISSUE. GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THREE. THE TRANSFER OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE PROGRAMS TO THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I'LL START WITH OUR
JOSEPH DAWSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'LL BE STARTING WITH
OVERVIEW OF MY COLLEAGUE WILL BE
HELPING WITH THE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS, SO THIS REQUEST
SHIFTS THE FEDERAL TITLE TO
GRANT PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION
FUNCTIONS FROM THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS,
OR B, S¼ E èC TO THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
SPECIFICALLY THIS PROPOSAL
TRANSFERS THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE TITLE TO GRANT PROGRAM UNDER
THE FEDERAL JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
DELINQUENCY PREVENTION ACT.
THROUGH GRAND MINISTERING
AUTHORITY INCLUDES THE MOVE OF
RELATED SPENDING AUTHORITY IN
ALL GRAND ADMINISTRATION
FUNCTIONS, INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR
THE STATE ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND DELINQUENCY
PREVENTION AND OTHER COMPLIANCE
MARKETING FUNCTIONS. THIS
REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO EFFECTUATE THE
SHIFT AND PROPOSE CHANGES
ESTABLISHES OIC AS A DESIGNATED
STATE AGENCY TO CARRY OUT GRANT
ADMINISTRATION FUNCTIONS AS WELL
AS REPEALING CODE SECTION. THAT
ARE NOT RELEVANT OR NEEDED.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSED
CHANGES DELAY THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A NEW DISTRIBUTION METHODOLOGY
FOR THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANT FROM
JANUARY 2024 TO JANUARY 2025.
AND I'LL PICK UP FROM THERE. SO
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE SIX PROGRAMS
THAT WERE LISTED IN THE AGENDA.
UM AND THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT ADMINISTRATION
ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS
INTERRELATIONSHIP. SO UM, FOR
THE 2011 REALIGNMENT ALLOCATIONS
, WHICH COVER FIVE OF THE SIX
GRANT PROGRAMS AMOUNTS THE
AMOUNTS THAT ARE INCLUDED ON
PAGE 15 OF YOUR AGENDA. THERE'S
A CHART INCLUDED FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
UM, AND THE AMOUNTS WITHIN THAT
CHART ARE PROJECTED BASED ON
SALES TAX AND LICENSING FEE
REVENUES. GENERALLY THE JUVENILE
GRANTS HAVE A BASE AMOUNT, UM,
SOME OF WHICH ARE SET, SOME OF
WHICH FLUCTUATE FROM YEAR TO
YEAR, AS WELL AS GROWTH
ALLOCATIONS, DEPENDING ON
WHETHER GROWTH MATERIALIZES IN
ANY PARTICULAR YEAR. SO FOR THE
PURPOSES OF MY PRESENTATION, I'M
RELYING ON THE CHART, UH,
PROVIDED IN ON PAGE 15 FOR THE
YOUTH OFFENDER BLOCK GRANT THAT
GRANT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE 2007
JUVENILE REALIGNMENT, WHICH
REALIGNED LOWER LEVEL JUVENILE
OFFENDERS TO COUNTY SUPERVISION.
UM, AND THIS FUNDING IS TO SERVE
THAT REALIGNED POPULATION AND
LOCAL JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH FOR
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT. THIS FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT A COMPREHENSIVE
MULTI-AGENCY JUVENILE JUSTICE
PLAN AND TO FUND PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE PROVEN EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING CRIME AND DELINQUENCY
AMONG AT RISK YOUTH AS WELL AS
JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH. THE
JUVENILE REALIGNMENT GRANT IS,
UH, A LITTLE BIT MORE, UM,
SPECIFIC IN TERMS OF THE
POPULATION IT'S INTENDED TO
SERVE. IT IS INTENDED TO SERVE
LOCAL SUPERVISION OF YOUTH, UH,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN DISCHARGED
FROM THE OF JUVENILE JUSTICE OR
Dð J PRIOR TO Dð J J'S CLOSURE.
UM AND THERE'S ALSO AAA PORTION
OF THAT FUNDING THAT GOES TO
SUPERVISION OF YOUTH WHO MAY
HAVE COMMITTED A PAROLE
VIOLATION AND ARE HOUSED IN
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES
FOLLOWING THEIR RELEASE FROM THE
FORMER DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE, UM IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ACTIVITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE THREE
GRANTS, THE YOUTH OFFENDER BLOCK
GRANT AND THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
CRIME PREVENTION ACT HAVE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS. UM THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE AND
THOSE THOSE, UM, REQUIREMENTS
WERE CONSOLIDATED. IN 2016, SO
THEY'RE ACTUALLY THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS IN STATUTE. UM SO
THE UM COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE A JUVENILE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN TO THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS BY MAY,
1ST OF EACH YEAR FOR THEIR PLANS
FOR THE SUCCEEDING FISCAL YEAR
AND THEN IN OCTOBER 1ST OF EACH
YEAR THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
EXCUSE ME FOR PROVIDING A REPORT
ON HOW FUNDS WERE EXPENDED FROM
THOSE TWO POTS, UM, TO THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS, AND THEN THIS
INFORMATION IS PUBLISHED ON THE
BS. CS WEBSITE. UM JUST VERY
QUICKLY. I'LL TOUCH ON THE
JUVENILE CAMPS AND RANCHES
FUNDING. SO THIS IS SPECIFICALLY
TO SUPPORT SUPERVISION OF YOUTH
WHO ARE ASSIGNED TO CAMPS. UM
WHICH IS A ANOTHER TYPE OF
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITY THAT
OPERATES, I THINK, UH, SENATOR
MANIA. YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU'VE
BEEN TO A FEW, UM, INCLUDING THE
ONE PINE GROVE, UM, WHICH IS
OPERATED BY THE STATE. UM THE,
UH, NUMBER OF CAMPS. UM IS, UH,
IS, UM, A DATA SET THAT'S
COLLECTED BY B S¼ èC èC IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THEIR OTHER
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
RESPONSIBILITIES, AND THE FUNDS
ARE ALLOCATED BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF CAMPS OR NUMBER THE
AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION IN
THOSE CAMPS AS SPECIFIED IN
STATUTE, JUVENILE PROBATION
ACTIVITIES. THESE ARE THIS IS A
MUCH LIKE BROADER POT ALSO
INCLUDED IN 2011, AND THAT IS
REALLY AVAILABLE FOR LIKE A WIDE
VARIETY OF PURPOSES AND TERM.
TERMS OF SERVING YOUTH. IT'S
SOME EXAMPLES INCLUDE
EDUCATIONAL ADVOCACY, MENTAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS AND
COUNSELING, FAMILY MENTORING,
LIFE SKILLS AND COUNSELING,
AMONG OTHERS. AND ON THAT LAST
PART, THOSE FUNDS ARE DIRECTLY
ALLOCATED BY THE STATE
CONTROLLER'S OFFICE BASED ON A
FORMULARY THAT'S SET FORTH IN
STATUTE THAT, UH, JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT B BLOCK
GRANT. EXCUSE ME IS WAS
ESTABLISHED AS A PART OF S¼ B 82
THREE, AND IT'S INTENDED
SPECIFICALLY TO SERVE THE
REALIGNED POPULATION. THE
AMOUNTS ARE SET FORTH IN
STATUTE, AND THIS YEAR WILL
INCORPORATE LIKE A GROWTH
ELEMENT AND THAT'S BASED ON
GROWTH IN UM, THAT APPLIES TO
SOME OF THE OTHER 2011 REAL
IMMIGRANTS, UM, IN TERMS OF
INTERRELATIONSHIP, EACH POT OF
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE FOR ITS
SPECIFIC PURPOSES. OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT COUNTIES
WILL SOMETIMES PULL THE FUNDS
AND USE THEM FLEXIBLY. AS LONG
AS THEY'RE MEETING THE SPECIFIC
UM LEGAL REQUIREMENTS THAT EXIST
WHICH ARE FAIRLY EXTENSIVE, UM,
IN EACH CASE, UM, SO WITH THAT,
AND THAT WAS A VERY LONG
PRESENTATION. IF HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS, I CAN ALSO
QUICKLY MOVE ON TO THE OTHER
POINTS. AGENDA ABOUT, UH, WHAT
KIND OF IS INCLUDED IN THIS P?
èC P AND THEN? UM OK, VERY GOOD
. I'LL UH UH, SPEED UP A LITTLE
BIT. SO UM THIS B èC P. I DON'T
MEAN SPEED UP. OH, NÓ NÓ NÓ.
YEAH I APOLOGIZE. I KNOW IT'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION. THERE ARE
SIX PROGRAMS. UH, AGAIN IF YOU
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS, I'M
AVAILABLE. UM, UH, TO ANSWER. SO
JUST VERY QUICKLY. WE VIEW KIND
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE YOU AS
THE INITIAL KIND OF START OF THE
PROCESS. UM IT DOES INCLUDE THE
FINAL FIGHT THE TITLE TO
REQUIREMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
OUTLAID, UM THERE IS SOME
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ONGOING
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION
RELATED TO THE 2011 OTHER 2011
REALIGNMENT GRANTS. UM AND WE
ARE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
MORE WITH YOU SOON. UH, WHETHER
IT'S AT THE MAY REVISION OR
OTHERWISE, UM, IN TERMS OF THE
RESOURCE NEEDS RELATED TO THE
2011 REALIGNMENT GRANTS. UH THIS
PROPOSAL IS A NET ZERO TRANSFER
BETWEEN THE BOARD OF STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS AND THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, WE ARE TRANSFERRING
THE RESOURCES THAT THE B S¼ èC
WAS USING TO ADMINISTER TITLE I.
I, UM THEY ALSO HAD
RESPONSIBILITY IN RELATION TO
THE 2011 RE ALIGNMENT GRANTS,
AND WE WILL BE, UH, THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE LOOKING
CLOSELY AT Ó Y èC R S¼ ONGOING
NEEDS, WHICH ARE SUBJECT TO
REVIEW THROUGH THE ANNUAL
PROCESS ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS.
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
DELAYS THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT. GRANT FORMULA THAT
THE RATIONALE FOR THE DELAY IS
REALLY JUST MORE TIME IS NEEDED
TO ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
WHICH INCLUDES THE LEGISLATURE,
DELAYED BY A YEAR ALLOWS US TO
PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY TO
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF WHAT WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO THEM, WHICH,
JUST GIVEN THE FISCAL CLIMATE
SEEMS APPROPRIATE, AND WE REALLY
THE ADMINISTRATION REALLY VALUES
THE NECESSARY STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK. Ó IR WILL BE LEADING
THAT STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. UM,
AND WILL BE, UM UM IS IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A PLAN FOR
THAT THAT WE ARE LIKE, YOU KNOW,
HAPPY TO SHARE MORE, UM, WHEN
IT'S AVAILABLE, UM UH IT'S STILL
UNDER DEVELOPMENT. BUT WE I
THINK WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
AROUND WHAT THAT REVISED FORMULA
WILL BE, UM, WITH, YOU KNOW, AN
INTEREST, OBVIOUSLY, AND MAKING
SURE THE FORMULA IS EFFECTIVE
AND, UM, IMPROVING YOU OUTCOMES.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD? ANYTHING
FOR RIGHT NOW, UM, JUST WOULD
AGREE THAT WE'RE WE HAVE A
BLUEPRINT FOR GETTING THAT
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK. THINK
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
IT IS ROBUST AND TRANSPARENT AND
WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH Dð
Ó F. OK? UM E, LEO. ANY COMMENT
ON THIS. OK, LET'S JUMP IN.
LET'S START WITH THE GRANTS
RIGHT NOW. WE JUST TITLE TWO,
WHICH IS LIKE A REALLY SMALL
PORTION OF THE TOTAL.
APPROXIMATELY $1 BILLION. WHEN
YOU ACCUMULATE ALL THESE SIX
GRANTS, RIGHT, UM WHY YOU SAID
THIS IS THE START OF THE
PROCESS. WHY DOES THERE NEED TO
BE A START? AND WHY CAN'T THIS
JUST BE A START FINISH? YEAH,
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND? I THINK
THIS IS, UM THE KIND OF THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHERE THOSE
2011 YOU KNOW, TO THE 2011
REALIGNMENT GRANTS. JUST PERHAPS
MY PRESENTATION TO IMPLIED IT'S
ENORMOUSLY COMPLICATED. THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO PROP THE PROP 30
GUARANTEES, AND SO THERE'S JUST
SOME ADDITIONAL COMPLEXITIES
AROUND THOSE GRANTS THAT REQUIRE
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME AND
ANALYSIS, WHICH IS OCCURRING
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION. UM,
WOULDN'T YOU SAY, THOUGH, THAT
YOU'VE HAD ENOUGH TIME? IT'S
BEEN YEARS. WHY? WHY NOW? RIGHT
BEFORE IT'S SUPPOSED TO, YOU
KNOW, GET UP TO THE STATUE OF
THIS IS A MANDATE. WHY NOW SAY
WE NEED MORE TIME. I THINK AS WE
LOOKED AT THE DETAILS MORE
CLOSELY AS A PART OF THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS, IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT MORE TIME IS WAS
NEEDED AND OUR MANDATE. AND
STATUE OF TRANSFERRING ALL THE
GRANTS OVER. I THINK WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE. UH,
WHEN WE HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF,
UM KIND OF THOSE INTERNAL
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE OCCURRING,
YOU HAVE A BETTER SENSE. WHEN
WOULD THE INTERNAL DISCUSSION
CEASE? SO I THINK WE HAD
COMMITTED TO THE MAY REVISION OR
SOONER. UM, AS I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE INTERESTED
IN BRINGING FORWARD AS SOON AS
WE CAN AS WELL. BUT THE MAYOR
REVISION IS OBVIOUSLY THE NEXT
UP, BUT THE LIKE THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATIVE FORMAL
ADMINISTRATION UPDATE, BUT IF WE
CAN BRING SOME FORWARD SOMETHING
SOONER WE WHAT? I GUESS I'M
WONDERING LIKE AFTER YEARS. YOU
JUST NEED A COUPLE. NOT YOU. THE
ADMINISTRATION NEEDS LIKE THREE
MORE EXTRA MONTHS TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY DIVE INTO WHY WE CAN'T DO
THE COMPLETE SHIFT. IF IT'S THE
NET ZERO MAYBE. Ó Y èC R. YOU
CAN HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE
WHAT ARE THE POTENTIAL
DIFFICULTIES THAT WE DON'T HAVE
IT OR WHAT? DON'T WE HAVE IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO JUST SWEEP
EVERYTHING AND HAVE A B èC P
THAT PROPOSES EVERYTHING. UM
THAT ÁP. I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION. I'M JUST NOT IN A
POSITION TO SHARE MORE AT THIS
TIME. WOULD HAVE BEEN HELPFUL
FOR US TO HAVE SOMEONE HERE IN
THE WELL. THAT WAS IN A POSITION
TO SHARE MORE INFORMATION. I
THINK WHEN I SAY I CAN SHARE
MORE, IT'S BECAUSE THE IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THAT ARE
INTERNAL TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
THE BUDGET DEVELOPMENT KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS GENERALLY ARE
CONFIDENTIAL, SO IT'S NOT THAT
CONVERSATIONS AREN'T HAPPENING.
IT'S JUST THAT I'M NOT IN A P.
WE'RE NOT REALLY IN A POSITION
TO SHARE MORE AT THIS POINT. UH,
YOU KNOW, JUST TO SETTLE, ARE
THERE? DO YOU SEE ANY OBSTACLES?
UH, WITH ICR HAVING THE CAPACITY
TO ONBOARD ALL THESE SIX GRANTS.
I KNOW YOU HAVE J JB J. THAT
ACRONYM WAS JUST A YEAH. YOU
ALREADY HAVE THAT UNDER YOUR
YOUR PURVIEW, DO YOU? IS THERE
ANY EXTRA HELP? CAPACITY
BUILDING. YOU WILL NEED TO
ONBOARD EVERYTHING. UM
GRATEFULLY. WE MET WITH B S¼ èC
èC. AND AT THIS TIME I WOULD
HAVE TO SAY AFTER MEETINGS AND
UNDERSTANDING THE CURRENT, UM,
REQUIREMENTS FOR STAFF. UH,
HOURS. THERE ARE NÓ OBSTACLES TO
ASSUMING MANAGEMENT. BECAUSE IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN, B S¼ èC
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE A SINGLE
POSITION ALLOCATED TO ALL OF
THESE GRANTS. THEY JUST EMBEDDED
IN THEIR EVERYDAY, UM, DUTIES
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO RUN LIKE
THAT. SO MAYBE BY MAY, WE'LL
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE'S A DELAY.
UM. BUT LET'S LET'S SWITCH OVER
ONCE THIS HAPPENS AND WE MEET
OUR MANDATE. HOW DO YOU SEE Ó?
I èC Ó Y èC R CHANGING HOW WE
ADMINISTER THESE GRANTS. I KNOW
WE HEARD FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS, UH, SOME OF THESE
GRANTS ARE ADMINISTERED. YOU
KNOW, WE'RE MEETING SOME OF
THESE GOALS. YOU KNOW, YOU AND
I. YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL. I DON'T
THINK AND YOU KNOW, MOST
COUNTIES ARE MEETING THE GOALS
IN SERVICES FOR OUR YOUTH. SO
WHAT ROLE CAN WE PLAY IN IN? UM
HOW WE CAN CHANGE THE FUNDS BE
ADMINISTERED TO COUNTIES. WELL,
UH, I'M A LAW FOLLOWER. YOU
KNOW, AT THE HEART OF IT. I CAME
FROM THE BENCH, SO I WOULD NOT
DO ANYTHING THAT THE STATUTE
DOESN'T ALLOW OR REQUIRE, OR
THAT ISN'T ALREADY BEING DONE.
BY THE B. SO, UM, WE DON'T
EXPECT TO MAKE WITH MAJOR
CHANGES BECAUSE WE WOULD BE
FOLLOWING THE MANDATES OF THE
LAW TO THE LETTER, I THINK OTHER
THAN WHAT IS STATUTORILY
REQUIRED, WHICH IS CONSULTATION
WITH COUNTIES. UM WE WOULD NOT
BE DOING ANYTHING NEW AND
DIFFERENT. SIZE OF POTENTIAL
METHODOLOGY FOR WELL, THAT'S FOR
THE YEAH, THAT'S FOR THE ONE BUT
OUTSIDE OF THAT, OK, I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. UM. I. I AM
REALLY, YOU KNOW, VERY CURIOUS.
UM YOU KNOW, TO GET THIS FULL
PLAN AS TO WHAT IS HOLDING US
BACK OF WHY TITLE TWO GOT THE
GREEN LIGHT AND NÓ OTHER ONES
GOT THE GREEN LIGHT FOR RIGHT
NOW. WE HEARD THAT Y CR IS READY
TO TAKE ON THIS. UM, AND IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'D BE STATUS QUO
FOR MOST OF THE GRANTS, SO NOT
MUCH WOULD CHANGE IT. I'VE HEARD
BSC DOESN'T HAVE ANY NEW EXTRA
POSITIONS LIKE IT'S RUNNING
SMOOTHLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
BEFORE MAY OR BY MAY TO FIND OUT
WHY THE DEPARTMENT UM IS
HESITANT AND MOVING ALL THESE
GRANTS OVER. OH, I SEE OUR
OMBUDSPERSON. YOU'RE ALL UP AND
RUNNING A FULL STAFFED UP. IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE READY TO GO. UM
NÓ. FURTHER QUESTIONS ARE ON ON
OUR END ON THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ISSUE FOUR.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THE DEFERRAL OF COW HÌ HÌ
S¼ INNOVATION ACCELERATOR.
WELCOME BACK. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AGAIN. BRENDAN MCCARTHY,
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR PROGRAM AND
FISCAL AFFAIRS AT CAL. HÌ HÌ S¼.
UM SO THE AGENDA ASKS US TO
PROVIDE AAA BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE PROJECT, WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
DO. UM THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS HERE WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT SOMETIMES THEIR
INNOVATIONS IN THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM THAT ARE SLOWLY
TRANSLATED INTO THE SAFETY NET
MEANING IN OUR MIND, YOU KNOW
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND CLINICS IN
THE SAFETY NET THAT SERVE LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY THE MEDI POPULATION
. UM AND SO WE WANNA MAKE SURE
WE WANNA ACCELERATE THE
DISSEMINATION OF THOSE KIND OF
INNOVATIONS, PARTICULARLY TO
ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES WE SEE
IN MANY HEALTH CONDITIONS IN OUR
STATE. LIKE AS I SAID, THE POINT
HERE IS NOT TO DO A NEW ORIGINAL
RESEARCH. IT'S TRANSLATIONAL
RESEARCH. WHAT IS OUT THERE THAT
REALLY ISN'T BEING PROVIDED IN
THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET. AND SO
THE PLAN IS TO SET SOME KEY
TARGETS OR AREAS OF FOCUS. FOR
EXAMPLE, WE'VE THOUGHT ABOUT,
UM, LOOKING AT DIABETES RELATED
MORTALITY DISPARITIES IN
MATERNAL AND INFANT HEALTH. UH,
AND THE BURDEN OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AREAS WHERE WE KNOW
THERE ARE LARGE DISPARITIES IN
OUTCOMES AND THEN TRY AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE BEST AVAILABLE
METHODS OF CARE SYSTEMS OF CARE
ARE AVAILABLE IN THE IN THE
HEALTH CARE SAFETY NET. UH, THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET INCLUDES $75
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
EFFORT, UM, THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY 10 BUDGET PROPOSAL
PROPOSES TO DELAY THAT FUNDING
TO BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE AND
BUDGET YEAR PLUS TWO. EXCUSE ME.
DELAY $74 MILLION OF IT TO
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE AND BUDGET
YEAR PLUS TWO. WE HAD BEEN
INTENDING TO USE $1 MILLION IN
THE CURRENT YEAR FOR PLANNING
EFFORTS, AND WE ACTUALLY WERE IN
THE PROCESS OF DOING AN RFP ON
THIS. BUT GIVEN THE CHANGES TO
THE STATE'S FISCAL A. WE
CANCELED THE RFP JUST TO WAIT TO
SEE WHAT THE DECISION IS BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THIS PROGRAM.
IF IT IS INCLUDED IN THE FINAL
BUDGET ACT THIS YEAR, THEN WE
WOULD USE THE BUDGET YEAR FOR
THAT PLANNING EFFORT, WHERE WE
WOULD DIVE DEEPER INTO THE
SPECIFIC KINDS OF TECHNOLOGIES
AND MODELS OF CARE. WE WOULD
LOOK AT FURTHER REFINING WHAT
AREAS LIKE I MENTIONED LIKE
DIABETES PREVENTION AS AN
EXAMPLE THAT WE WOULD BE
FOCUSING ON AND ALSO THINKING
ABOUT GOVERNANCE MODELS AND WAYS
THAT WE MAY BE ABLE TO PARTNER
WITH OUTSIDE ENTITIES LIKE
PHILANTHROPY. OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE ALSO
INTERESTED IN ADDRESSING
DISPARITIES TO LEVERAGE THE
STATE INVESTMENT. UM. LET'S SEE.
SO THAT IS, UH, ESSENTIALLY KIND
OF AN OVERVIEW OF THE PROJECT.
UM THERE ARE SOME OTHER
QUESTIONS. YOU WANT ME TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA, MADAM CHAIR. SO YOU HAD
ASKED, UM WHAT ENTITIES WILL BE
PARTNERS TO RECEIVE FUNDING. OUR
VISION IS THAT THIS IS VERY MUCH
A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE HEALTH
CARE SAFETY NET SO PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS BEING THE
PRIMARY, UM, ENTITIES THAT WE
ARE THINKING OF, BUT PART OF
THAT PLANNING PROCESS WOULD BE
TO LOOK IF THERE ARE OTHER
PARTNERS THAT WOULD RECEIVE
GRANTS EITHER HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS OR MAYBE ENTITIES THAT
CAN HELP IN BRINGING THOSE
INNOVATIONS INTO THE SAFETY NET
SYSTEM SO THAT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING WE WOULD ADDRESS, UM
THROUGH THE PLANNING PROCESS,
AND, UH AS WE DISCUSSED IN THE
PRE HEARING. WE WOULD ENVISION
HAVING SOME KIND OF THIRD PARTY
ENTITY ADMINISTERING THE GRANTS,
BUT THAT ALSO WOULD BE SOMETHING
WE WOULD FLUSH OUT IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS. UH AND THEN
YOU'RE A YOUR AGENDA ASKS FOR
EXAMPLES. SO IT'S A LITTLE
TRICKY BECAUSE WE STILL NEED TO
DO THE PLANNING. BUT YOU KNOW,
SOME EXAMPLES THAT WE HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT. FOR EXAMPLE, ARE
THERE USES OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD BETTER
HELP COORDINATE CARE, FOR
EXAMPLE, DIABETES PREVENTION OR,
UM, UH, WAYS TO LOOK AHEAD AND,
FOR EXAMPLE, IDENTIFY HIGH RISK
PREGNANCIES SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE ALL THE APPROPRIATE CARE IS
AVAILABLE IN A TIMELY WAY TO
IMPROVE MATERNAL AND INFANT
OUTCOMES. SO THOSE ARE THE KIND
KIND OF THINGS IT'S NOT ABOUT.
NEW DRUGS OR NEW DEVICES, BUT
IT'S ABOUT WHAT'S OUT THERE THAT
WE CAN, UM BRING TO BEAR IN THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET NEW MODELS OF
CARE TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES. UM.
ESSENTIALLY THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
OUR THINKING ABOUT WHAT KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES WOULD BE FUNDED WITH
THIS FUNDING. THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS? UH, NÓ FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. RYAN
MILLER. UM JUST AS A BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THIS ITEM, UM,
THIS WAS PROPOSED. INITIALLY
LAST YEAR WE HAD RAISED A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT ABOUT THE
FUNDING AND ULTIMATELY
RECOMMENDED REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL. IT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
THREE PARTY. THE FINAL BUDGET
AGREEMENT IN THE SUMMER, AND THE
ADMINISTRATION, OF COURSE, NOW
PROPOSES FOR A DELAY. WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ANSWERED SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THIS, AND, UM,
CONTINUE TO TRY TO PROVIDE A
SENSE OF WHAT THESE FUNDS WOULD
BE USED FOR. THE PROGRAM REALLY
DOES STILL SEEM TO BE LARGELY
CONCEPTUAL AT THIS POINT, AND
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT THERE ARE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS TO OTHER
PROGRAMS. THE LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO WEIGH THOSE
REDUCTIONS OR OTHER POTENTIAL
REDUCTIONS AGAINST KEEPING
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM. UM SO
I THINK, GIVEN THE LARGELY
CONCEPTUAL NATURE OF THIS
PROPOSAL STILL, IT SEEMS TO US
LIKE A STRONG CANDIDATE TO
CONVERT INTO A REDUCTION. RATHER
THAN A DELAY. IF THE PROGRAM
DOES REMAIN IN THE STATE'S
FISCAL PLAN IN THIS EVENTUAL
BUDGET, WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE SOME OVERSIGHT OVER THE
OVER THE PROGRAM AS IT DEVELOPS,
UH AND WE'D BE AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. UM SO YOU KNOW YOU YOU YOU
YOU MENTIONED, UH, DEPUTY
SECRETARY? YES TITLE. UM, YOU
KNOW, REGARDS TO CLOSING SOME OF
THOSE OR REACHING SOME OF THOSE,
UH, GAPS IN SOCIAL EQUITY, AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU. WHY
I'M BAFFLED IS THAT WITH THAT
BEING THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO WHY WE'RE CUTTING
PROGRAMS FOR COW WORKS AND
FOSTER YOUTH, WHICH WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE ENOUGH DATA ON THAT
REALLY ADDRESSES THE SOCIAL
EQUITY GAPS AND HELPS TO PREVENT
PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH BARRIERS.
THIS IS TOP OF MY LIST. IN IN
HAVING IT JUST CUT. I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD DELAY THIS. I
THINK WE SHOULD IMMEDIATELY CUT
THIS BECAUSE DOWN THE LINE, LIKE
WHEN IT'S I CAN'T AND I DON'T
THINK YOU COULD REALLY GIVE ME A
GOOD REASON AS TO WHY THIS IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN FIRST. WHY
THIS IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN SILS
FOR FOSTER YOUTH. THERE'S NÓ ONE
THAT CAN CAN ARGUE THAT THIS IS
GONNA BE MORE IMPORTANT TO FUND
ENTITIES VERSUS FUNDING OUR
VULNERABLE POPULATION. SO THIS
ONE'S GONNA BE A REALLY
DIFFICULT ONE FOR ME TO AND I
I'LL SEE WHAT WE CAN DO. YOU
KNOW, AFTER SUB THREE STUFF, BUT
UH, THAT'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT THIS
ABOUT THIS TOPIC, GENERAL. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YOU KNOW, I
I'M SORT OF TAKEN BACK TO MY
TIME AND BUDGET SUB FOUR OF I
GUESS, A DECADE OR MORE AGO WHEN
WE WERE DEBATING INITIALLY AT
ITS INFANCY, PRECISION MEDICINE.
SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT
AND WE HAD THE SAME CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHETHER THAT SHOULD BE
FUNDED IN LIGHT OF CONFLICT,
CONFLICTING BUDGET PRIORITIES
AND, UM I TOOK A PARTICULAR
POSITION. THAT PROGRAM OVER TIME
HAS PROVEN TO BE VERY, VERY
VALUABLE AND THE HEALTH CARE
ARENA. BUT GIVEN THE BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAVE THIS
YEAR, AND THE ONES THAT ARE
PROJECTED IN THE THREE YEARS
FOLLOWING, ASSUMING THE
PROJECTIONS ARE ACCURATE, AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THEY'RE NOT. I JUST WONDER
AND AGREE WITH MY CHAIR. IF THIS
MONEY CAN'T BE PUT TO, UM USE
MAINTAINING. HEALTH RELATED
BENEFITS THAT ARE THREATENED AND
UNDER THE PREMISE THAT. SOME
HEALTH CARE TODAY, UM IS BETTER
THAN BETTER HEALTH CARE TOMORROW
OR THE DAY AFTER, OR YEARS
LATER. GIVEN THE CUTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED, OR THE DEFERRALS THAT
ARE PROPOSED, IN ADDITION TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT THE CHAIR HAS
MENTIONED TO VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT. HEALTH CARE,
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRAINING
PROGRAMS WHERE THE PIPELINE IS
LONG. AND IF WE INTERRUPT THE
PIPELINE, WE'RE JUST KICKING THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD TO MAKE IT
WORSE. 345 10 YEARS FROM NOW, SO
I'M NOT GOING TO BELABOR THIS,
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT I DO
AGREE WITH MY CHAIR ON THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET ITEM, AND WE
NEED TO. WE NEED TO THINK VERY
LONG AND HARD ABOUT HOW WE
HANDLE IT. SO NOT REALLY
QUESTIONS. JUST OUR THOUGHTS ON
IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR èC
HÌ HÌ SS, UH, SECTION I NOW
INVITE ANYONE THAT WANTS TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON THE FIRST
FOUR ISSUES THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
YOU WILL HAVE A MINUTE. TO SHARE
WITH US YOUR INSIGHTS AND
THOUGHTS. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING, JOSH GOER ON BEHALF OF
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA, AS YOU KNOW, WITH
THE PASSAGE OF S¼ B 820 THREE
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE
NOW RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FULL
CONTINUUM OF JUVENILE JUSTICE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL, INCLUDING CARE
FOR THE HIGHEST NEED. YOUTH
PREVIOUSLY ADMITTED TO STATE Dð
JJ AS OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA.
PROBATION CHIEFS ARE
COLLABORATING LOCALLY ON THEIR
ANNUAL REALIGNMENT PLANS AND
EXPENDITURE OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE, REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANT
AND COORDINATING WITH THE OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION PURSUANT TO LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET BILL. PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS ARE ALSO COLLECTING
SUBMITTING REALIGNMENT RELATED
DATA TO Ó IRS DISPLAYED IN THE
AGENDA. S¼ B 23 ACTUALLY CALLED
FOR A PLAN TO OVERHAUL THE Dð Ó
J JCPS SYSTEM, BUT IN THE
ABSENCE OF THAT PROJECT THAT
WOULD TAKE SEVERAL YEARS,
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS BEGAN
COLLECTING REALIGNMENT DATA ON
OUR OWN, KNOWING THERE WOULD BE
AN INTEREST AMONG POLICYMAKERS.
WHEN THE NEW DATA SUBMISSION
REQUIREMENTS PASSED. WE ACTUALLY
DIDN'T SEND A TEMPLATE TO
COUNTIES UNTIL THE LAST WEEK OF
OCTOBER BECAUSE COUNTIES ONLY
HAD A COUPLE OF MONTHS TO REPORT
THE DATA AT THAT POINT, JUST
QUICKLY. WE ALSO AGREE WITH THE
GOAL OF AVOIDING THAT WIDENING
AND KNOW IT'S A DELICATE BALANCE
AS WE TRY TO STAND UP QUALITY
JUVENILE PROGRAMS THAT CAN HELP
REDUCE ADULT TRANSFERS RELATIVE
TO THREE ON THE TRANSFER. UH YOU
KNOW, NÓ CONCERNS WITH WHAT'S
OUT THERE. NOW I KNOW THERE WAS
A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS TODAY
ABOUT TRANSFERRING ADDITIONAL
GRANT PROGRAMS. UH ESSENTIALLY,
OUR MAIN FOCUS IS ENSURING IN
ANY TRANSITION OF JUVENILE
GRANTS THAT IT DOESN'T DISRUPT
THE STABILITY, CONSISTENCY AND
CONTINUITY OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT WERE A FOUNDATION
OF EXISTING YES, THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE? OK, MOVING ON. OUR
NEXT DEPARTMENT. YEAH.
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY. WELCOME THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRESENTERS. YOU
CAN PROVIDE ME YOUR NAME AND
THEN OR REVIEW OF IS THAT ALL?
SIT ON. OK THERE YOU GO. YES UM,
CAROLINA BHARA, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH FACILITIES FINANCING
AUTHORITY, ALSO KNOWN AS TFA. SO
YES. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. SO,
UM TO BEGIN. I CAN JUST BEGIN
WITH THE OVERVIEW. IS OK, SO
I'LL BEGIN WITH THE OVERVIEW. SO
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITY
FINANCING AUTHORITY, OR CHAFFER,
WAS ESTABLISHED IN 1979 TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA BY PROVIDING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO NON
PROFIT AND PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. MAINLY THROUGH FINANCING
OF COST EFFECTIVE BONDS, LOANS
AND DIRECT GRANT PROGRAMS. THERE
ARE 21 DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FACILITIES OR HEALTH FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT WE CAN
FINANCE THROUGH OUR ACT, RANGING
FROM SMALL RURAL HEALTH
FACILITIES OR CLINICS TO
MULTI-HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE MAINLY FINANCE
FACILITIES, PROPERTY AND
EQUIPMENT. UM TFA IS GOVERNED BY
NINE MEMBERS OF THE TREASURER.
STATE TREASURE. FIONA MATT IS
THE CHAIR. WE ALSO HAVE THE
STATE CONTROLLER. THE DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE TWO MEMBERS APPOINTED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE,
TWO MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY AND TWO
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR, SUBJECT TO
CONFIRMATION BY THE SENATE. WE
HAVE IN THE MATERIALS BEFORE YOU
NINE ACTIVE FINANCING PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING, UM, TAX EXEMPT BONDS,
LOW COST LOANS AND GRANT
PROGRAMS, TWO OF WHICH I'M GOING
TO BE SPEAKING ABOUT TODAY. SO I
CAN PAUSE THERE BEFORE I GET
INTO THE OTHER TWO ISSUES IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT Tð.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENT ON THIS TAO TAO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LOOKING AT
. RYAN MILLER, ELLIOT. NOTHING
TO HAD AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. JUST DIVE
INTO ISSUE NUMBER 21 OF THE
FIRST GRANT PROGRAMS, SO THE
FIRST ONE IS THE SPECIALTY
DENTAL CLINIC GRANT PROGRAM. SO
THIS PROGRAM IS THE NEWEST
PROGRAM THAT SAFFA HAD RECEIVED
A BUDGET ALLOCATION IN THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2022 FOR $25
MILLION, AND THEN ANOTHER $25
MILLION IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
2020. THREE THIS PROGRAM IS
DEVELOPED PARTICULARLY TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO DENTAL CARE
FOR THE SPECIAL HEALTH CARE
NEEDS POPULATIONS THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT AND EXPANSION OF
SPECIALTY DENTAL CLINICS. UM SO
AS OF AFTER Tð. I RECEIVED THE
FUNDING. WE HIRED A TECHNICAL
ADVISOR, THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. WE WORKED ON A
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS,
ENGAGING THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION OF NURSE
ANESTHETISTS DENTAL HYGIENIST
ASSOCIATION. WE DEVELOPED
GUIDELINES AND WE HELD VIRTUAL
PUBLIC STAKEHOLDER MEETING OVER
WITH OVER 100 STAKEHOLDERS, THE
KIND OF GRASP THE NEED OF THE OF
THE COMMUNITY. AND, UM, WHAT ARE
THE NEEDS OUT THERE SO WE CAN
BUILD THE PROGRAM AS A ROBUST
PROGRAM. WE DEVELOPED GUIDELINES
THAT THE CHARD APPROVED LAST
SUMMER OF 2023. THEN WE ACTUALLY
CONDUCTED SOME SITE VISITS TO
SOME SPECIALTY DENTAL CLINICS.
THE KIND OF SEE THE CARE THAT'S
PROVIDED SO WE CAN BUILD OUR
PROGRAM TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. UM
AND WE HEARD THAT IT CAN TAKE A
YEAR OR TWO TO GET. UM UH, AN
APPOINTMENT FOR THIS TYPE OF
POPULATION BECAUSE OF THEIR
SPECIAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS. AND
SO AFTER THE BOARD APPROVED THE
GUIDELINES IN SUMMER OF 2020
THREE, WE OPENED A FUNDING ROUND
TO ACCEPT APPLICATIONS WITH A
DEADLINE OF APRIL 1 2024. WE
HELD AN APPLICATION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. ARE TO WALK ALL
POTENTIAL APPLICANTS THROUGH OUR
PROCESS SO THAT THEY CAN APPLY
UM GIVEN WITH THE JANUARY BUDGET
RELEASE, IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT
THE FUNDING WOULD BE DELAYED
TILL THE 2526 BUDGET YEAR AND SO
WE DISCUSSED WHAT IS THE BEST
OPTION, GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
ARE ALREADY AND OF OPEN FUNDING
ROUND. WE HAD ALREADY RECEIVED
SIX APPLICATIONS, SO WE
DISCUSSED ABOUT VARIOUS OPTIONS
AND WE DECIDED TO CONTINUE
ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS UNTIL THE
APRIL 1ST DEADLINE. HOWEVER
WE'VE NOTIFIED EVERYONE THAT THE
SCORING AND THE REVIEW AND THE
EVALUATION OF THOSE WILL BE ON
HOLD UNTIL THE FUNDING IS
REPLENISHED. AT THE TIME. WHEN
THE FUNDING IS REPLENISHED, WE
WILL GIVE EVERYBODY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UPDATE THEIR
APPLICATIONS AND UPDATE PROJECTS
BECAUSE A PROJECT COULD CHANGE
IF THEY'RE BUYING REAL ESTATE OR
CONSTRUCTION, UPDATE THEIR COSTS
AND UPDATE THEIR TIMELINES. AND
SO THAT IS KIND OF WHAT WE'VE
DECIDED CURRENTLY CURRENTLY, AS
OF NOW, WE HAVE RECEIVED 10
APPLICATIONS. FOR APPLICATIONS
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. FIVE
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ONE
FROM CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. WAS
KIND OF WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW
READY TO PROCEED WITH WHATEVER
GOES FORWARD. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DIDN'T COMMENT ON THIS
MATTER. UH, NOTHING TO ADD.
HELLO. WE THINK THAT THE
PROPOSED DELAY IS REASONABLE IN
LIGHT OF THE BUDGET CONDITION.
THAT BUT REASONABLE A VIEW FROM
MY KNOWLEDGE. HOW MANY OF THESE
SPECIALIZED CLINICS DO WE HAVE
IN THE STATE? DO WE KNOW? UM I
WOULD HAVE TO GET THAT PROBABLY,
BUT I DON'T KNOW. UM I CAN GET
THAT FOR YOU AFTER THE FACT NÓ.
I ACTUALLY DID A TOUR IN ONE OF
MY CLINICS IN MY DISTRICT AND I
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THIS TOPIC.
UM AND I YOU KNOW YOU SHARED ONE
OR TWO YEARS TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY TALKED TO ME ABOUT.
ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW, IN THE SUB
THREE WE'VE DIVED INTO THE IG Dð
POPULATION. I MEAN, HOW IT
CORRELATES WITH THIS
INTERSECTIONALITY? UM, BUT SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE POTENTIALLY
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU KNOW OUR
BUDGET IS FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS, UH, THAT THERE IS MAYBE A
SMALL WINDOW TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE WITH THESE APPLICATIONS
. THE 10 APPLICATIONS. UH, WE
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING, SO WE
ARE GONNA ACCEPT THEM, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THEM ON HOLD AS
SOON AS THE FUNDING REPLENISHES
WILL BEGIN THE SCORING AND
REVIEW AND THEN MAKE THE AWARDS.
WE CAN'T MAKE A COMMITMENT FOR
FUNDS. WHEN UM, FOR EXAMPLE, IF
WE WERE TO MAKE AN AWARD WITHOUT
THE FUNDS, WE WOULD BE LEGALLY
AN OBLIGATED COMMITTED TO GIVE
THEM THE FUNDS. BUT THEN, IF THE
FUNDS DON'T COME FOR A YEAR,
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO PROCEED
WITH THE THEN THE WHOLE
APPLICATION WILL COMPLETELY
CHANGE. REAL ESTATE MIGHT GO OFF
THE MARKET. CONSTRUCTION COSTS
MAY INCREASE TIMELINES WILL
CHANGE. SO WHAT WE AWARDED WOULD
BE A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT ANIMAL
WHEN IT'S TIME TO FUN. AND HOW
LONG DO WE HAVE THAT PERSON THAT
WE HIRED ON TO HELP WITH THIS
PROGRAM? UM WE WE'VE WE HAVE
THAT HEART THAT PER THAT PERSON
THAT WAS HIRED FOR THIS PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW IS BEING UTILIZED FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS. UM SO WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO KEEP THAT
POSITION. WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF FUNDING FOR SUPPORT. THAT'S
NOT BEING REVERTED. VERY LITTLE.
I THINK 1.25 MILLION AND WHAT'S
THAT GONNA BE USED FOR? IT'S
JUST GONNA BE USED FOR STAFFING
BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO GET, UM
EMAILS AND QUESTIONS LIKE FOUR
OR FIVE EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED
QUESTIONS ON THE PROGRAM AND
THEN APPLICATIONS BEING
SUBMITTED. SO WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE VERY LITTLE WITH WITH
WITH STAFFING. THE GOOD THING IS
WE HADN'T STAFFED UP THE
POSITIONS. UM, BELOW THE MANGER.
WE HAD HIRED AND DEDICATED A
MANAGER FOR THIS PROGRAM, BUT WE
HAD IT FILLED THOSE POSITIONS
UNTIL WE WERE GONNA DO IT, UM,
EARLIER THIS YEAR, BUT THEN WE
HEARD THE NEWS. SO OK, YEAH. CAN
YOU SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE?
ANECDOTALLY JUST THE NEED FOR
THIS. UM YES, DEFINITELY. UM WE
HAD, UM, A STAKEHOLDER MEETING
WE HAD OVER 400 OR 500 EMAILS OR
PEOPLE SIGN UP TO OUR EMAIL LIST
THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN THE
PROGRAM. WE HELD A WEBINAR FOR
100. DIFFERENT, UM PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATIONS, LOCAL MEMBERS
VOICED THEIR UH UM, VOICE THEIR
NEED FOR THE PROGRAM. UM AND
TALKED ABOUT THE UNIQUENESS OF
THIS POPULATION AND HOW LONG IT
TAKES THAT THE THAT THERE'S A
SHORTAGE. OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE
WANTED TO MAKE THAT CLEAR THAT
THEY WANTED THIS PROGRAM TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE TO HELP THE CLIENT. SO
WE'VE BEEN HEARING A LOT. I
MEAN, WE VISITED, UH, SPECIALTY
DENTAL CLINIC IN SACRAMENTO. WE
VISIT ONE IN THE BAY AREA, AND
WE KIND OF SAW HOW SPECIALIZED
HOW MUCH SPECIAL TREATMENT THEY
NEED. I MEAN, THEY NEED TO HAVE
LIKE LOW. UM IF A PERSON HAS
COGNITIVE ISSUES, THEY NEED A
ROOM THAT'S KIND OF SILENT AND
LITTLE NOISE, SPECIALIZED
EQUIPMENT. WE GOT TO SEE ALL OF
THAT. AND SO THAT'S THE GOAL OF
US BEING ABLE TO FUND THROUGH
THE PROGRAM. BUT, YEAH, WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OVER THE YEARS AND
WE GET 4 TO 5 INQUIRIES EVERY
SINGLE WEEK. OK, YEAH. SO THAT
WAS HELPFUL BY THE WAY. SO THE
ONE OR TWO YEARS TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT IS THAT IS THAT SO
BECAUSE OF, UM FACILITIES OR IS
IT PROVIDERS WHAT I WAS TOLD
IT'S BOTH AND PROVIDERS IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THIS, UH,
POPULATION NEED A FACILITY. UM
YEAH. SO DOES THAT WORK, OK? SO
YEAH, THAT THAT IS WHAT WE'VE
HEARD. IT'S BOTH SO THE AND THE
PAYOFF FOR THE SERVICES IS THAT
MEDICAL MEDI, THE PROGRAM THAT
WAS BUILT THROUGH STATUE IS FOR
MEDICAL PATIENTS, AND THAT IS
THE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM. IT'S
FOR THE MEDICAL PATIENT AND ARE
THE MEDICAL DENTAL RATES FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM HIGHER
THAN THEY ARE FOR THE NORMAL
MEDI. THE OTHER PORTION OF THE
ME POPULATION. I. DO NOT KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT. I DON'T
BELIEVE SO. BUT I CAN DEFINITELY
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE I MEAN, I'M TRYING TO
REMEMBER AREN'T AREN'T MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR DENTAL
SERVICES. UM SAID TO BE LOW. I
MEAN, WE'VE HEARD THAT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH FUNDING. SO WHAT WE'VE
HEARD IS THAT PROVIDERS DO NOT
WANT TO ENGAGE FULLY 100% INTO
THIS BUSINESS BECAUSE THE RATES
CANNOT SUSTAIN A FULL 100%
OCCUPIED. A FACILITY IF IT WERE
TO SERVE OR HAVE 10 OPERATORS,
NOT 100. NOT ALL 100% OF THE
FACILITY WOULD BE DEDICATED TO
MEDICAL BECAUSE IT WOULDN'T BE
ENOUGH TO BE PROVIDE ECONOMIES
OF SCALE. THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
HEARD SO AND SO A LOT OF THE
PROVIDERS WILL BE PROVIDING TO
BOTH POPULATIONS, INSURANCE AND
MEDICARE AND WE BUILT THE
PROGRAM TO ACCOMMODATE THAT, SO
WE CAN GET AS MANY PROVIDERS AS
POSSIBLE TO WANNA, UM, PROVIDE
MEDICAL SERVICES. SO WE'RE NOT
SO IF A IF, IF WE FUNDED A
FACILITY, NOT 100% OF IT HAS TO
BE USED FOR THIS POPULATION. IT
WOULD SERVE BOTH POPULATIONS. SO
WHAT FACILITY CAN BE SUSTAINABLE
IN THE FUTURE? I MEAN, DON'T GET
ME WRONG. THIS IS A VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT A PIECE OF THE BUDGET.
WE SPEND A LOT OF OUR TIME AND
ATTENTION AS WE SHOULD, UM, ON
THIS POPULATION BECAUSE THEY
DESERVE EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN
GIVE THEM AND THEN SOME HEALTH
CARE AND OTHERWISE, I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE THIS IS
FOCUSED ON CONSTRUCTION AND MAY
NOT ADDRESS THE OTHER PORTION OF
IT HAVING TO DO WITH, UM
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND I
REALIZE IT'S A DIFFERENT PORTION
OF THE BUDGET. SO WE'LL CONTINUE
TO PUSH FOR THIS. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I HEAR YOU ON THAT
GENERAL. I AGREE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. UH UH, ANY COMMENT ON
THIS? NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD. F
FINANCE. I SKIP TO NOTHING THAT
GREAT OK, NÓ FURTHER QUESTIONS
ON OUR END. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. OK, SO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
IS, UM A PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
DENT THE DEADLINE TO UTILIZE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS THAT WERE
ALLOCATED FOR THE DISTRESSED
HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAM BY CHER
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE, ACCESS AND INFORMATION
FROM JUNE 30 2026 TO THE
DECEMBER 31 2031 DEADLINE OR
SUNSET DATE OF THE PROGRAM IN
STATE. SO IF YOU IF YOU MAY
REMEMBER SO BACK IN MAY OF 2020
THREE, THE DISTRESS HOSPITAL
LOAN PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED TO
URGENCY. LEGISLATION AUTHORIZING
BOTH CHAPA AND HK TO CO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM AND ISSUE
LOANS TO HOSPITALS AND
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL DISTRESS
AND OFFERS 0% LOANS. UM WITH 72
MONTH LOAN TERMS WITH AN 18
MONTH GRACE PERIOD, UH, PAYMENT
DEFERRAL AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
LOAN ISSUE. AND THE GOAL OF THIS
PROGRAM IS TO PREVENT CLOSURE OF
DISTRESSED HOSPITALS AND
FACILITATE THE REOPENING OF
CLOSED HOSPITALS. THE STATUE OR
OR THE PROGRAM WAS FUNDED WITH
7.5 MILLION TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM, AND WE ENTERED INTO, OR
TAFA ENTERED INTO AN INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENT WITH HK SO THAT WE CO
DEVELOP THE APPLICATION PROCESS,
METHODOLOGY AND THE DISTRIBUTION
OF LOANS. AND ALSO DUE TO THE
COMPLEX FINANCIAL SITUATION OF A
LOT OF THE HOSPITALS BEING
INSIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL DISTRESS
AND BEING IN BANKRUPTCY. WE
HIRED OUTSIDE LEGAL COUNSEL TO
ASSIST US WITH THE PREPARATION,
REVIEW AND NEGOTIATION OF ALL
THE LOAN TERMS TO ENSURE WE
SECURE THE SECURITY THAT'S
REQUIRED IN THE STATUTE DUE TO
THE SITUATIONS. UM THE AAA
RECEIVED 30 APPLICATIONS IN THE
FIRST FUNDING ROUND BY THE JULY
31 2020 THREE DEADLINE. HÌ Kò
MAY DETERMINATIONS TO SEVEN
HOSPITALS FOR A TOTAL OF 292.
$1.5 MILLION, ALLOCATING ALL
AVAILABLE FUNDS SINCE THEN, ONE
HOSPITAL FORFEITED ITS FUNDS AND
THEN AS OF NOW, AS OF TODAY,
CHER HAS DISPERSED. $222.4
MILLION TO 13 HOSPITALS. THERE
ARE ONLY THREE HOSPITALS
REMAINING, TWO OF WHICH ARE IN
BANKRUPTCY AND ARE A LITTLE MORE
COMPLEX AND WE CONTINUE
NEGOTIATIONS CONVERSATIONS AND
ENGAGING OUR COUNCIL ON THOSE
SITUATIONS. SO UM CHAVA
BASICALLY IS, UM, CONTRACTUALLY
COMMITTED RIGHT NOW TO AT LEAST
13 EVENTUALLY 16 HOSPITALS FOR
ONGOING WORK TO AT LEAST 2030.
THESE ARE SIX YEAR LOANS.
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLIANCE
DUTIES AFTER LO IS ISSUED.
HOSPITALS MIGHT WANT TO TAKE ON
MORE DEBT. THEY NEED TO GET
CONSENT FROM US. THERE ARE 16
REPORTS THEY HAVE TO SUBMIT
ANNUALLY, WHICH INCLUDE, UM
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS ON
AUDITED QUARTERLY FINANCIALS
BOARD APPROVED BUDGETS AN UP,
UH, PROGRESS UPDATE ON THE
TURNAROUND PLAN THAT EACH
HOSPITAL ENGAGED IN TO IN ORDER
TO TURN AROUND THE HOSPITAL
OPERATIONS TO ENSURE
SUSTAINABILITY. UH, UTILIZATION
STATISTICS FINANCIAL RATIOS.
THIS IS ALL ONGOING WORK THAT
CHA OF STAFF HAS ALREADY
COMMITTED ITSELF TO, FOR AT
LEAST UNTIL 2030. UM AND SO
BASICALLY, THIS PROPOSAL IS JUST
TO EXTEND. IT'S NOT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. IT'S EXTENDING THE
DEADLINE TO UTILIZE THE ALREADY
ALLOCATED FUNDS UNTIL 2031. BANK
QUESTIONS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS Tð Ó R
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, UH, JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT WE, UH,
RECEIVED THE PROPOSED TRADE BILL
LANGUAGE AFTER OUR RELEASE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
. UM SO WE'RE STILL WORKING TO
COMPLETE OUR EVALUATION OF THE
CHANGE AND WILL WORK WITH
CHARING. THANK YOU. LEO NÓ
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. UM, YOU YOU
MENTIONED SEVERAL AUDITS AND
REPORTS OR IS THAT ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS OR IS THAT UNTIL AFTER THE
18 MONTHS THAT THEY PAY AFTER
THE 72 MONTHS AND 18 MONTHS THAT
THEY PAY SO, FOR EXAMPLE, A LOT
OF THE LOANS CLOSED LATE 2020
THREE AND EARLY, 2024 SO SOME,
UM, SO EVERY QUARTER A REPORT IS
DUE AND WE GIVE THEM LIKE 30 OR
45 DAYS AFTER EACH QUARTER, SO
WE ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF REPORTS
DO NOW AND SO THERE'S 16.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR, WE WILL BE
COLLECTING ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
SO 16 TIMES. UH, SIX, I WOULD
SAY, AND THEN WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT THOSE WITH HK.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE WORKING
CONJOINTLY TOGETHER ON THIS
PROGRAM ON ASSESSING THEM AND
THERE'S GONNA ACTUALLY BE
ADDITIONAL WORK ON DETERMINING
THE APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
MODIFICATION BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO
IN THE STATE AS WELL AS
POTENTIALLY LOAN FORGIVENESS.
THAT IS TO COME AFTER THESE GET
DISPERSED. THE TWO THE TWO
AGENCIES WILL WORK TOGETHER ON
DEVELOPING THAT CRITERIA, SO
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK TO COME
OF THE SIX WITH 13 RIGHT NOW.
POTENTIALLY 16 WOULD YOU SAY
THAT WE'VE CAPTURED THE MAJORITY
OF THE HOSPITALS THAT NEEDED
SUPPORT. NOT THE MOST I. I COULD
SAY THE MOST DIRE THE ONES OUT
OF ALL THE HOSPITALS, THE MOST
DIRE AND THE ONES THAT ARE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL DISTRESS.
SO WE DID CAPTURE OF THEM. THERE
WASN'T ONE THAT SOMEHOW DIDN'T
APPLY FOR IT. OR UM, THERE WAS A
LOT THAT APPLIED. I MEAN, WE GOT
30 APPLICATIONS, BUT WITH THE
LIMITED FUNDING, I MEAN, WE
PICKED THE MOST DIRE THAT WERE
IN AND IN THAT REALLY NEEDED THE
FUNDS TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
AND UM, YEAH, MORE TO COME ON
THE REOPENING AND THE BANKRUPTCY
SITUATION. OK? IN GENERAL. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I'M JUST
CURIOUS. I MEAN, I REALIZE MOST
OF THIS WAS UNDER THE GUN OF
LAST YEAR, WHERE HOSPITALS WERE
EITHER ONE CLOSED AND OTHERS
WERE PREPARING TO CLOSE AND
OTHERS WERE PROBABLY GETTING IN
LINE. I'M JUST CURIOUS. UH, WHEN
THE HOSPITAL SUBMITTED THEIR
PLANS OF ACTION AND RECOVERY
PLANS, AND UM AND VARIOUS
REPORTS. DID YOU HAVE THE TIME
PRIOR TO LOAN CLOSING TO CONDUCT
AN ACCOUNTING OF FORENSIC REVIEW
OF THEIR PLANNED PLAN OF ACTION
TO DETERMINE WHETHER IT LOOKED
LIKE IT MIGHT WORK. SO SO WE
PARTNERED WITH HÌ Kò. AND UM,
THERE WAS A METHODOLOGY THAT WAS
DEVELOPED FOUR MAIN CRITERIA
ABOUT LIQUIDITY. HOW LIQUID THE
FACILITY. THE HOSPITAL IS OR
FINANCIAL CAPACITY AND THE
TURNAROUND PLAN. THE TURNAROUND
PLAN WAS KEY. ALL THE TURNAROUND
PLANS. EACH HOSPITAL IS REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT A PLAN HOW IT WOULD
TAKE THE LOAN FROM THE PROGRAM
AND HOW IT WOULD TURN AROUND THE
OPERATIONS TO BECOME SUSTAINABLE
ON ITS OWN. EACH Kò WAS HAD THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THE
ANALYSIS AND THE DETERMINATION
OF THOSE AND THERE WAS A DEEP.
UM A DEEP ANALYSIS OF CASH FLOW
PROJECTIONS AND PLANS OF MAYBE,
UM, JUST OPERATION CHANGES IN
ORDER TO SHOW THAT THEY CAN
POTENTIALLY BECOME SUSTAINABLE
BEFORE THE DECISIONS WERE MADE.
UH, YES. SO ON CHINA, ASKING,
WHO HAS IT? I'M JUST ASKING IF
THERE'S THE METHODOLOGY ON
WEBSITE AS WELL AS EACH KS
WEBSITE ON THE ASSESSMENT WAS
DONE. I ASSUME PART OF IT
ENTAILED IN SOME CASES, IF NOT
MANY OF THOSE CASES, UH, CHANGES
IN THE PAYER MIX. AT THE
HOSPITAL. UH AT A COW VERSUS
COMMERCIAL MEDICARE. I MEAN,
THERE WERE MENTIONS OF THEM.
YEAH, THERE WAS A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT I MEAN, FROM WHAT I'VE
SEEN BECAUSE THERE'S JUST SO
MUCH THERE'S UM HOSPITAL
SUGGESTING CLOSING, UM,
DIVISIONS THAT AREN'T MAYBE
PROFITABLE, REOPENING OTHER
DIVISIONS THAT ARE MORE
PROFITABLE, UM, GETTING LINES OF
CREDIT. UH, THERE WAS JUST A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT, UM UM, UH,
TASKS OR, UM, ITEMS THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO PURSUE IT. IT WAS
ALL OVER. WELL FOR EXAMPLE,
CLOSING LINES OF BUSINESS THAT
ARE NOT PROFITABLE. WE HAVE SOME
ROLE IN THAT. I MEAN, NOT THE
LEGISLATURE, NECESSARILY. BUT
GOVERNMENT DOES WAS THERE FOLLOW
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THOSE
ACTIONS WERE THAT WE FACILITATE
THOSE ACTIONS. IF YOU ALL
DETERMINED IT WAS APPROPRIATE,
FOR EXAMPLE, TO CLOSE A I HATE
TO SAY IT, BUT A MATERNITY, UH,
LINE OF SERVICE. SO EACH
HOSPITAL WILL BE GIVING A
QUARTERLY UPDATE ON WHATEVER
THEY SAID THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO DO IN THE TURNAROUND PLAN, SO
IF THEY HAD SAID THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO CLOSE THE CLINIC OR
OPEN A CLINIC, THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO GIVE US QUARTERLY
UPDATES THAT COMES TO US AND TO
HÌ Kò, AND WE'LL BE LOOKING INTO
THEIR PROGRESS EVENTUALLY, ONCE
WE DEVELOP THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR MODIFICATION AND
FORGIVENESS, WE WILL DEFINITELY
DIVE INTO HOW WELL HOW WELL THEY
WERE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
TURNAROUND AND JUST ONE FINAL
QUESTION. GIVEN THE FACT THAT I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO UNDERTAKE THIS IN A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR, BUT WAS THE
COST OF SEISMIC UPGRADE INCLUDED
IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE
HOSPITAL'S CONTINUED VIABILITY.
UH NOT IN THE INITIAL NOT IN THE
INITIAL DECISION OF WELL, NOT
THAT I BELIEVE SO I WOULD HAVE
TO CONFIRM WITH HK BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE IT WAS IN THE INITIAL
DECISION. UM SO, UM, IT WAS MORE
HOW TO GIVE WHICH HOSPITALS
NEEDED THE FUNDING TO KEEP THEIR
DOORS OPEN AND PREVENT FROM
CLOSURE. SO WE'LL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT LATER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR RESPONSE. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NÓ FURTHER QUESTIONS.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN.
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT FOR,
UH, ISSUES ONE THROUGH THREE. WE
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE. AND WHAT AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JESSICA MORAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
HERE TO GIVE COMMENTS ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO ON THE SPECIAL NEED
DENTAL CLINIC GRANTS. UH, JUST
WANTED TO AGAIN URGE YOU, UH,
THE LEGISLATURE TO NOT DELAY
THOSE GRANTS. I WANT TO ALSO
ADDRESS SOME COMMENTS THAT WERE
ASKED THE COMMITTEE, UM, SO AS
FAR AS HOW MANY SITES ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE STATE. IT'S
REALLY HARD TO QUANTIFY. WE DO
KNOW THAT MOST PEOPLE GO TO U S¼
F OR U Ó P IN THE BAY AREA IF
THEY'RE IN L A TYPICALLY U S¼
èC U èC L, A THE DENTAL
SCHOOL. ARE WHO REALLY HAVE THE
MOST CAPACITY TO TREAT THESE
PATIENTS? I KNOW YOU KNOW. U èC
L A HAS SIX CHAIRS SO THEY CAN
ONLY SEE SIX PATIENTS AT A TIME
AND THIS POPULATION BECAUSE THEY
DO NEED SPECIAL MODIFICATIONS OR
EXTRA TIME FOR DESENSITIZATION
AND TO GET THEM USED TO BEING IN
THE CHAIR. THEIR EQUIPMENTS DO
TAKE LONGER. SO THAT IS PART OF
THE REASON WHY WAITLISTS ARE SO
BACKED UP. IN ADDITION TO COVID,
AND THIS LACK OF CAPACITY, SO,
UH, THE REASON THIS GRANT IS
FOCUSED ON CONSTRUCTION IS WE'RE
TRYING TO REALLY INCREASE
CAPACITY THROUGHOUT THE STATES
THAT WAY. PATIENTS DON'T HAVE TO
TRAVEL TO THE BAY AREA OR TO L,
A GREAT. SORRY. UM, SO AGAIN,
JUST REALLY. THESE ADAPTER
FACILITIES WERE REALLY MAKE AN
IMPACT FOR THIS POPULATION. THIS
IS A LONG STANDING ISSUE, AND WE
THINK CHA FOR DEVELOPING THIS
GRANT IN SUCH A THOUGHTFUL WAY
TO REDUCE YOUR GEOGRAPHIC
INCREASED YOUR GEAR DIVERSITY.
SORRY, NOT REDUCE IT. UM, SO
YEAH, AGAIN, URGE YOU NOT TO
DELAY AND THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS ISSUE.
THANKS. THANKS. DANIEL SAVINO
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES. THE REGIONAL CENTERS
ARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO ISSUE
TWO OF THE PROPOSED DELAY OF
FUNDING FOR THESE CLINICS. IT
REALLY IS AN ACCESS AND CAPACITY
ISSUE. FAMILIES HAVE TO DRIVE
HOURS TO GET AN APPOINTMENT TO
GET TO AN APPOINTMENT ONCE THEY
CAN GET IT. A ROOMMATE OF MINE
ONCE HAD A VERY BAD TOOTHACHE.
IT WAS UTTERLY DEBILITATING FOR
HIM AND HIS SOUL CHALLENGE WAS
POVERTY. WAS NOT DISTANCE. IT
WAS NOT COMMUNICATIONS. IT WAS
NOT DISABILITY AND LIVING WITH
THAT, FOR A PERIOD OF TIME WAS
UTTERLY DIS UTTERLY DEBILITATING
FOR HIM. IMAGINE WHEN YOU THROW
IN SPECIAL NEEDS, OTHER
CHALLENGES THE LIVES OF OUR
FAMILIES AND THE COMMUNITY THAT
WE SERVE. THIS IS REALLY A
CRITICAL ISSUE. WE HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL REJECT THIS.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK. CPE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT ON THE DELAY OF
THE SPECIALTY GRANT PROGRAM. THE
DELAY WILL PREVENT MANY
COMMUNITIES FROM ACCESSING
PREVENTATIVE AND EARLY
INTERVENTION CARE AND DISRUPT
TIMELY ACCESS, PARTICULARLY FOR
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED PARTS OF
THE STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HØI. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
MATT ROMAN WITH, UH, WITH NAPS.
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING PACIFIC
DENTAL SERVICES, AGAIN, ECHOING
THE CONCERNS FROM èC Dð ON THE
DELAY OF THE SPECIALTY DENTAL
CLINIC FUNDING. THIS IS ALREADY
A LARGELY DISENFRANCHISED. THIS
IS GOING TO CONTINUE
DISENFRANCHISING I REALLY
LARGELY, UH, MARGINALIZED
POPULATION IN THE STATE. WE UH
WE JUST WANT TO SEE THAT THIS
FUNDING IS HELD AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REJECT IT. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE STEPHANIE ROBERSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
DENTAL SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS,
ECHOING COMMENTS FROM THE èC Dð
, A AND PACIFIC DENTAL SERVICES
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM MY
PARTNERS. YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
STAFF AT JAFFA THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PROGRAM. IT'S A
STAFFED UP PROGRAM, AND, UM,
THEY'RE ALREADY ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS RIGHT NOW. AND SO,
WITH THAT, WE REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED DELAY OF
THESE DENTAL CLINIC PROGRAMS AND
AGAIN THE DEFERRAL OF THIS
PROGRAM, UM, WOULD FURTHER
EXACERBATE TO CARE FOR AN
ALREADY EXISTING VULNERABLE
POPULATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT? BEFORE YOU LEAVE
. I JUST WAS THINKING ABOUT
SOMETHING. UM, AND MAYBE THIS IS
FOR Dð F AND L Ó IS THERE. IS
THERE SOMETHING? UM YOU KNOW, I,
I BE MINDFUL I GET IT. YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE TO CUT SOME DELAY
SOMEWHERE WHERE SOME FUNDING
COULD BE ALLOCATED WHERE WE CAN
START SOME PLANNING OF THESE SO
THAT WHEN POTENTIALLY WE COME
BACK TO, UM UH. MOVING THE
PROGRAM FORWARD THAT SOME
PLANNING OF THE APPLICANTS IS
READY TO GO AND WE DON'T DELAY
IT COMPLETELY. THE CHALLENGE IS
IF WE WERE TO LEGALLY I MEAN TO
GRANT AN AWARD JUST FOR
PLANNING. I MEAN, OUR AWARDS ARE
NOT FOR PLANNING. INITIALLY IT'S
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE. IT'S FOR
BUILDINGS, EQUIPMENT, AND, UM,
BASICALLY GETTING THE FACILITY
UP AND RUNNING. SO WE DON'T I
DON'T THINK THE STATUTE OPENS IT
UP TO PLANNING GRANTS. BUT A LOT
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED. THEY ALREADY HAVE
THEIR PLANS TOGETHER, SO WE HAVE
TO LEGALLY COMMIT OURSELVES TO
FUNDING THE FULL GRANT. SO I
DON'T KNOW. WE WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF GRANTS OVER THE YEARS AND, UM
II. I GUESS YOU KIND OF HAVE TO
FIND THE FULL PROJECT PER PERSON
PER APPLICANT. IT'S HARD TO JUST
GIVE MONEY JUST FOR PLANNING
WHEN THESE PROJECTS SHOULD BE
SHOVELED READY WHEN THEY APPLY,
OR AS SHOVELED, READY AS
POSSIBLE WHEN THEY APPLY TO BE
COMPETITIVE, SO OK, THAT MIGHT
BE AND JUST TO ADD TO THAT, YOU
KNOW IS DETERMINED, UH, FROM OUR
SIDE THAT BEST SOLUTION FOR
CONSIDERING ALL THE ALL THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE UP FOR
SOLUTIONS THAT THE FULL DELAY
WAS MOST APPROPRIATE FOR THE
GOVERNORS BUDGET. YEAH I. I
THINK WE WOULD ALSO ADD. UM UH,
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A CASE WHERE
IT APPEARS THAT THERE'S ALREADY
BEEN A LOT OF GROUNDWORK. LAID
TO HAVE THIS PROGRAM READY.
THEY'VE ALREADY ACCEPTED
APPLICATIONS. YOU KNOW, THERE'S
KIND OF A VARYING DEGREES OF
THESE DELAYED PROGRAMS IN TERMS
OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH THEY ARE
OFF THE GROUND AT. I MEAN, I
THINK YOU KNOW, I THINK WE WOULD
POINT TO THE ITEM IN THE HÌ HÌ
S¼ SECTION OF THE AGENDA THAT
WAS ALREADY HEARD IS ONE THAT
WAS REALLY NOT IN THAT POSITION.
RIGHT? SO THE WILL WANNA WEIGH
THESE CHOICES AND TRADE OFFS.
UM, OF COURSE. AT THE END OF THE
DAY, UM THE BUDGET CONDITION
APPEARS TO BE WORSENING BEYOND
THAT, UH, THAT'S SHOWN IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND SO, UM,
YEAH, UM YY YOU KNOW THERE?
THERE ARE A LOT OF TOUGH, TOUGH
CHOICES THAT ÁP APPARENTLY WILL
HAVE TO BE MADE, I GUESS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WELL I'LL JUST SAY
THIS. I MEAN, I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE A LIST.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO MAKE A
LIST OF ALL THESE THAT ARE
PROPOSED TO BE REVERSIONS AND
ALL THESE THAT ARE PROPOSED TO
BE A DEFERRALS, PARTICULARLY IN
THE HEALTH CARE ARENA, AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO SOME
TRIAGING. AND I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT. WE HAVE TO. WE HAVE TO
CLOSE THE GAP, BUT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE IN
CLOSING THE GAP. WHO ARE WE
GOING TO? HURT THE MOST GIVEN
THAT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO HAVE
PAIN AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE SOME TOUGH DECISIONS, AND
THIS MAY BE ONE OF THOSE THAT
NEEDS TO BE, UM LEFT ON THE
TABLE INSTEAD OF BEING SWEPT
OFF. WE ALSO NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT OUR MEDI REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING THIS
SERVICE. BUT TO THOSE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS, AND, UM, IT MAY
NEED WE MAY NEED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO INCENTIVIZE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE DENTAL
SKILLS TO WORK IN THIS AREA. SO
THAT'S MY COMMENT. MADAM CHAIR.
MAYBE M èC Ó. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT APARTMENT. LIKE TO WELCOME
UP EMSA. HM?
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN START
WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY. ABSOLUTELY. AND YES,
AND YOUR NAME TOO. PLEASE. IS IT
RIGHT NOW? OK I'M CRAIG JOHNSON
ADMINISTRATION AND HUMAN
RESOURCE DIVISION CHIEF FOR THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY, WHICH I WILL REFER TO
AS IM S¼, A GOING FORWARD AND AS
REQUESTED, I'LL PROVIDE YOU THE
OVERVIEW OF OUR DEPARTMENT. OUR
PROPOSALS SO EMSA WAS. FORMALLY
ESTABLISHED BY THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES SYSTEM AND PRE
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY CARE
PERSONNEL ACT. S¼ B 125 IN 1980
AS THE STATE LEAD AGENCY AND
CENTRALIZED RESOURCE TO OVERSEE
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTER MEDICAL
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA, WAS
CREATED IN 1981 BY THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE DIVISION 2.5
WITH THE INTENT OF CREATING A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM WITH MS
RESPONSIBLE FOR CO ORDINATION
AND INTEGRATION OF ALL STATE
ACTIVITIES CONCERNING EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES TO ENSURE THE
PROVISION OF EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CARE. IZA IS CHARGED WITH
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP AND THE
INNOVATION AND ADMINISTRATION OF
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHICH INCLUDES SETTING STANDARDS
FOR THE TRAINING AND SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR VARIOUS LEVELS OF
EM S¼ PERSONNEL. IS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROMOTING
DISASTER MEDICAL PREPAREDNESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, AND WHEN
REQUIRED, COORDINATING AND
SUPPORTING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL RESPONSE TO
MAJOR DISASTERS. EMSA WORKS
CLOSELY WITH MANY LOCAL, STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES, PRIVATE
ENTERPRISES AND THOSE IN
DISASTER. MEDICAL SERVICES ROSE
TO PROMOTE QUALITY EM S¼
SERVICES STATEWIDE. THE
AUTHORITIES PROGRAM FUNCTIONS
ARE ORGANIZED INTO THREE
DIVISIONS. EM S¼ PERSONNEL
STANDARDS DIVISION. ASSISTANCE
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AND DISASTER MEDICAL
SERVICES DIVISION. I'LL LEAVE IT
THERE FOR OUR OVERVIEW. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN OUR
REVIEW. CHRISTINE Tð DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTHING TO FURTHER
THEIR DAD. THANK YOU. WILL WE?
WELCOME BACK? UH, GOOD TO BE
BACK. UM SO WILL OWENS
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE, UH,
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD ON THE
OVERVIEW, BUT AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. YOU MIGHT BE THE ONLY
NAME I'VE MEMORIZED. YEAH. UM.
CO. COULD I JUST GET AN UPDATE
LAST YEAR? WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
TRANSITION OF, UH, THE I BELIEVE
IT WAS THE POST. AND THE ADVANCE
DIRECTIVE AND JUST LIKE THE SOME
OF THE BARRIERS IN IN
TRANSFERRING ALL THAT
INFORMATION, JUST WANNA GET A
QUICK UPDATE ON THAT SITUATION
THERE. OK? UH, GOOD MORNING,
ELIZABETH BASSETT, THE DIRECTOR
FOR THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY. SO UM, I
BELIEVE LAST YEAR, UH, RECALLING
CORRECTLY, WE HAD TRAILER B
LANGUAGE PUT FORWARD TO REMOVE
THE ADVANCED HEALTH CARE
DIRECTIVE OUT OF THE POST
ELECTRONIC REGISTRY, THE
ELECTRONIC REGISTRY FOR THE
PHYSICIAN ORDER FOR LIFE
SUSTAINING TREATMENT, SO AS A
PART OF THAT WE ARE STILL
STANDING UP THE PULSE REGISTRY.
UM ELECTRONIC REGISTRY STATEWIDE
, AND WE ARE ADDING, UM AS THIS
IS, THE ADVANCED HEALTHCARE
DIRECTIVE IS MANAGED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. WE
ARE ADD. A CHECK BOX TO THE
BOTTOM OF OUR EPOS FORM. SO THAT
, UM IF A PATIENT HAS AN
ADVANCED HEALTH CARE DIRECTIVE
ON, UM WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE THAT THAT IS THEN
INFORMED WITH THE PHYSICIAN, OR
WHOEVER COULD PULL UP THAT POST
FORM, AND THEY CAN SEE THAT THEY
COULD ALSO REACH OUT TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. IS
THAT HELPFUL? YEAH AND THEN I
KNOW WE ALSO CHANGE SOME OF THE
BACKGROUND FROM ONE OF THE
POSITIONS THAT YOU NEEDED TO
HIRE. SHOOT. IT WAS THE CHIEF
MEDICAL CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER
BECAUSE WE WERE HAVING SOME
DIFFICULTIES BRINGING IN
SOMEBODY SO WE REALIGN THAT WERE
WE ABLE TO BRING IN THAT PERSON?
SO UM, THE CHANGE WAS WE HAD PUT
FORWARD TO CHANGE. THE DIRECTOR
OF I S¼ A HAD ALWAYS THE
REQUIREMENT WAS ALWAYS THERE TO
BE A PHYSICIAN SPECIALIZING IN
EMERGENCY MEDICINE. AND THEN WE
BIFURCATED THAT. WHERE THE
DIRECTOR THAT WAS NÓ LONGER A
REQUIREMENT, BUT WE DID ADD A
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER. WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR.
OFFICE TO TRY TO BRING SOMEBODY
IN THAT IN THAT ROLE, BUT WE DO
HAVE AN ACTING CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER WHO IS SERVING US NOW
AND DOING A FANTASTIC JOB. GREAT
THANK YOU. OK UH, LET'S MOVE ON
ANY QUESTIONS J ON THE OF YOU
GREAT. LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TWO MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR OF
THE CRITICAL BIOMEDICAL
EQUIPMENT. WAITING FOR IT TO
COME BACK ON. THERE IT IS. SO
EMSA REQUEST TO ME IN GENERAL
FUND IN 2425 AND ONGOING TO
MAINTAIN CRITICAL BIOMEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND MEDICAL SUPPLIES
ACQUIRED DURING THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC AND PROVIDE LIFE SAVING
RESUSCITATIVE AND MEDICAL
SERVICES TO RELIEVE SUFFERING
FOR DISASTER VICTIMS DURING
PANDEMICS OR OTHER CATASTROPHIC
EMERGENCIES. THE 2021 22 BUDGET
ACT INCLUDED 2 MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO MAINTAIN APPROXIMATELY
4000 PIECES OF EQUIPMENT.
FUNDING FOR THE MAINTENANCE
CONTRACT EXPIRES AT THE END OF
20 THREE 24. THESE FUNDS ARE
USED TO CONTRACT WITH BIOMEDICAL
EQUIPMENT MAINTENANCE COMPANY
VIA THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES EQUIPMENT MAINTENANCE
MANAGEMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
DURING THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC. IM
S¼, A HAD NEARLY THREE 1000
PIECES OF BIOMEDICAL EQUIPMENT
DEPLOYED THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
UH UH AND COUNTRY. THE REQUEST
OUTLINED IN THIS PROPOSAL WILL
KEEP APPROXIMATELY 4000. OUR
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT PIECES YOU
READY TO DEPLOY FOR FUTURE LARGE
INCIDENTS. DISASTERS AND
PANDEMICS IF APPROVED. A
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICE
DIVISION WILL BE ABLE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY SUPPORT AND
IMPROVE DISASTER, MEDICAL
PREPAREDNESS, MITIGATION
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY FOR MAJOR
DISASTERS. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANY COMMENTS. THEY'RE COMING.
THANK YOU. WELL, UH, YES. SO UM,
THE SAME. WE HAVE THE SAME
COMMENTS FOR ALL OF THE
PROPOSALS, SO I'LL JUST SAY NOW
AND ES SO AS NOT TO REPEAT
MYSELF, BUT I GENERALLY WE HAVE
NÓ CONCERNS WITH ANY OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT BEING SAID, GIVEN
THE BUDGET SITUATION, THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO WEIGH
ANY NEW GENERAL FUND. UH,
SPENDING, UH, PROPOSED IN THE
BUDGET, GIVEN THE BUDGET
SITUATION NOW AND MOVING FORWARD
, UH, THAT BEING SAID NÓ
CONCERNS NECESSARILY WITH THESE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS. TURN HER
OFF. WE KNOW THIS TAKES ME BACK
ABOUT A DECADE. I HATE TO KEEP
SAYING THAT, BUT IT
UNFORTUNATELY IS TRUE IN SUB
FOUR IN THIS STATE, WE AT ONE
POINT IN TIME MAINTAINED. I
CAN'T REMEMBER. EXACTLY AND BY
THE WAY, THIS ISN'T YOUR AREA
RESPONSIBILITY BUT 3 TO 4 MOBILE
FIELD HOSPITALS, MUCH LIKE THE
MILITARY USED TO DOES STILL, UM,
AND THEY WERE STAGED IN VARIOUS
LOCATIONS IN THE STATE TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR NATURAL DISASTERS
AND OTHER HEALTH CARE
EMERGENCIES. UM, UNFORTUNATELY,
UM, FOR BUDGET IN A PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION. UH, THE
ADMINISTRATION DECIDED NOT TO
MAINTAIN UPDATE THE MOBILE FIELD
HOSPITALS BECAUSE NOT ONLY DOES
THE EQUIPMENT REQUIRE REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE, UM PHARMACEUTICALS
NEED TO BE REVIEWED AND REPLACED
AND EQUIPMENT, SURGICAL
EQUIPMENT AND THE LIKE. THE
HOSPITALS WERE ALLOWED TO
DETERIORATE OR EVENTUALLY
REMOVED FROM VARIOUS LOCATIONS
IN THE STATE WAREHOUSED IN A
WAREHOUSE SOMEWHERE HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA, AND ALLOWED TO
FURTHER DETERIORATE TO THE POINT
WHERE ASSUME THEY JUST TOSSED
HIM IN A TRASH BIN OR DISPOSED
OF THE HAZARDOUS MATERIAL AND
THEY'RE COMPLETELY UNUSABLE TO
THE EXTENT THEY EXIST TODAY AS
WE DEAL WITH SEISMIC ISSUES WITH
HOSPITALS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
AND CLOSURES OF HOSPITALS. UM OR
RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
. THOSE COULD HAVE BEEN
MAINTAINED AND KEPT IN STRATEGIC
LOCATIONS AROUND THE STATE AND
AVAILABLE TO DEPLOY. I THOUGHT
IT WAS A MISTAKE, THEN I THINK
IT WAS A MISTAKE. NOW I CONTINUE
TO BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
SORT OF RESOURCE. SO HAVING SAID
ALL THAT I COMMEND THIS REQUEST,
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO FIND $2 MILLION TO
ALLOW YOU TO MAINTAIN REPAIR THE
EQUIPMENT WE HAVE TODAY SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO REPURCHASE IT.
REACQUIRE IT THE NEXT TIME WE
HAVE ONE OF THESE STATEWIDE
EMERGENCIES. THAT'S MY COMMENT,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
GENERAL. YES UM, AGREE WITH
THAT. I THINK IT'S HELPFUL TO
FOR US TO BE PREPARED RIGHT AND
NOT BE A KIND OF SITUATION THAT
WE WERE A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
MY ONLY THING IS IT'S GOING TO
BE FOR BOTH ISSUES IS I WOULD
ASK THAT THE DEPARTMENT COME
BACK AGAIN NEXT YEAR AND THAT WE
THINK ABOUT APPROVING ONLY BY
THE YEAR GIVEN THE BUDGET AND
WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE I'M A LITTLE
HESITANT IN, UM AND IN SETTING
ASIDE FOR THE NEXT TWO X YEARS,
SO THAT WOULD BE MY ONLY THING
FOR THE FOR THIS. UH UH, THIS
ISSUE AND SAME COMMENTS FOR THE
NEXT ISSUE, BUT GO AHEAD WITH
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. UM SO ISSUE
PROPOSAL NUMBER TWO, I ASSUME.
SORRY ABOUT THAT. SO MS A
REQUEST 4.2 MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN 2024 AND 25 AND 4.4 MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND 2526. THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WERE
PROVIDED FOR THE CONTINUAL
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES INFORMATION SYSTEM,
KNOWN AS KEMPS. ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL CONTAIN TO ALLOW
IA TO MONITOR AND IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES SYSTEM TO MEET THE
PATIENT AND CLINICAL CARE NEEDS
OF 39 MILLION RESIDENTS AND 268
MILLION VISITORS PER YEAR. KEMPS
IS A SECURE, CENTRALIZED DATA
SYSTEM FOR COLLECTING DATA ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES REQUESTS PATIENTS
TREATED AT HOSPITALS AND EM S¼
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS. KIMS
USES THE UNIVERSAL STANDARD FOR
COLLECTING PATIENT CARE
INFORMATION FROM AN EMERGENCY
911 CALL FOR ASSISTANCE CALLED
THE NATIONAL EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES INFORMATION SYSTEM, OR
NIMS. KIMS PROVIDES THE ONLY
STATEWIDE MEANS OF MONITORING
THE OVERALL HEALTH OF THE EM S¼
SYSTEM AND THE CARE THAT EM S¼
AGENCIES PROVIDE TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND VISITORS IN A DAM
IDENTIFYING STRAINS AND THREATS
TO THE SYSTEM FROM LOCAL OR
STATEWIDE EVENTS. THROUGHOUT THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC CHEMISTS HAS
PROVEN AN ESSENTIAL SOURCE OF
CRITICAL INFORMATION. FOR
EVALUATING PATIENT CARE.
CONTINUED OPERATION OF KEMPS IS
CRITICAL TO MAINTAIN AN
EFFECTIVE AND STATEWIDE EM S¼
SYSTEM, AS WELL AS MEET THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR LENS.
US, UH, TO REQUIRE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE HEALTH DATA IN A FORMAT
THAT COMPLIES WITH KEMPS AND
NIMS STANDARDS, AND THAT'S
ACCORDING TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE OF 17 97.27. ANY
FURTHER COMMENT. NÓ FURTHER
COMMENT. THANK YOU. UM, WHAT
KIND OF DATA POINTS? ARE WE
COLLECTING? THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
FEEL LIKE YOU KNEW THAT WAS
COMING. YES. AND WE LOVE THIS
QUESTION. SO HERE'S A GREAT UH,
MAYBE JUST TWO QUICK, GREAT
EXAMPLES OF HOW WE USE THIS
DATA. ONE IS YOU CAN SEE. UM
WHEN, UH, EM S¼ PROVIDER ARRIVES
ON SCENE THEY FILL OUT AND THE
ELECTRONIC PATIENT CARE RECORD
WHAT THE PRIMARY IMPRESSION WAS
WE DO █7 MILLION PLUS TRANSPORTS
A YEAR, SO WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
FROM THE DATA THAT 740 PATIENTS
A DAY IT IS DOCUMENTED THAT
THEIR PRIMARY IMPRESSION IS
BEHAVIORAL, HEALTH OR
PSYCHIATRIC NEED. AND SO AS WE
HAVE THESE GREAT CONVERSATIONS
AROUND +988 OR OR, YOU KNOW,
POLICY AND LEGISLATION, THIS
REALLY HELPS INFORM, UM, THAT
AND THEN ANOTHER JUST A DISASTER
EXAMPLE, BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL DURING
THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC, AS YOU
ALL WOULD BE AWARE WE DEPLOYED
AM PATIENT OFFLOAD TEAMS TO THE
HOSPITALS TO SUPPORT THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE, USING THE KEMPS DATA
AROUND AMBULANCE, PATIENT,
OFFLOAD TIME AND THE DATA THAT
WAS, UH UH, INPUTTED INTO THOSE
EP èC R S¼ AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE
, YOU KNOW, 7 MILLION TRANSPORTS
A YEAR ACROSS 58 COUNTIES, YOU
REALLY ARE ABLE TO, UM
UNDERSTAND QUALITY ASSURANCE
THAT EBBS AND FLOWS WITHIN THE
SYSTEM AND HAVE SOME HOPEFULLY
REALLY GOOD POLICIES. AT LAST
YEAR. SOME OF YOU REMEMBER
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ AND I CAN'T
REMEMBER IF IT WAS THAT SIGNED
OR NOT TO COLLECT DATA AROUND
THE WAIT TIME. PATIENT OFF WILL
BE COLLECTING THAT INFORMATION.
COME UP TO HIM, SIR. A B 40. IS
THAT WHAT THE CHARGE OF EMSA
HAVE? WE STARTED COLLECTING THAT
INFORMATION. UH, WE HAVE NOT
STARTED COLLECTING THAT IN. WELL
WE COLLECT AMBULANCE PATIENT
OFFLOAD TIME. THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WAS AROUND
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES BETWEEN A
NURSE AND AN EM. S¼ PROVIDERS
WAS VERY TECHNICAL. UM THAT HAS
NOT STARTED YET. THOSE
ELECTRONIC CINEMAS HAVE NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED TODAY. UM, BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH. AND DID YOU SAY THAT
70% OF THE TYPES OF CAUSE OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH? SORRY 740
PATIENT TOUCHES A DAY ACROSS THE
STATE. THE PRIMARY IMPRESSION IS
LISTED AS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. SO
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE. THERE'S
HUNDREDS OF DATA FIELDS AND AN
ELECTRONIC PATIENT CARE RECORD.
BUT THAT'S JUST AAA REAL LIFE
EXAMPLE OF, YOU KNOW, JUST
POLICY CONVERSATIONS WE'RE
HAVING TODAY AND HOW THAT DATA
CAN BE USED AND WHY THIS SYSTEM
IS SO IMPORTANT. FOR ME. I
NEEDED INFORMATION ON SOMETHING
RELATED TO THIS I COULD REACH
OUT TO AND SAY, HEY, DO WE HAVE
A DATA POINT ON THIS? YOU SHARE
THAT. OH, GOOD TO KNOW. ARE WE
ABLE TO TELL? ARE YOU ABLE TO
TELL US WHAT? FOR EXAMPLE, IN
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AREA? UH,
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE TOTAL
CALLS AT 700. SOMETHING
REPRESENTS. OH I MEAN, A RAW
DATE OF 700 DOESN'T GIVE ME SO I
DON'T. I CAN'T DO THE MATH ON MY
HEAD. BUT IT'S 740 A DAY TIMES
365 DAYS AND WE KNOW WE DO 7
MILLION TRANSPORTS A YEAR SO I
CAN'T RUN THAT PERCENTAGE OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD. BUT YES, IF
WE COULD ABSOLUTELY FOLLOW. SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A TOTAL DAILY
FIGURE. AND THEN WE KNOW 700 OF
THE TOTAL DAILY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND SOMEBODY COULD DO THE
MATH AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
PERCENTAGE FOR THOSE. THAT'S AN
AVERAGE RIGHT. A POINT IN TIME
AVERAGE ACROSS, YOU KNOW IF YOU
WERE TO RUN IT ACROSS THREE 165
DAYS, VERSUS MAYBE THE FOUR
QUARTER OF THE YEAR AROUND THE
HOLIDAY SEASON. THAT DATA MIGHT
LOOK DIFFERENT, SO RIGHT LIKE,
UM AND IT'S NOT GEOGRAPHICALLY
WE CAN RIGHT WE DEFINITELY SO
ONE OTHER QUESTION AND IT HAS TO
IT RELATES TO THE WALL TIME IN
THE HOSPITALS. WHEN WILL YOU
START BEING ABLE TO CAPTURE THE
ELECTRONIC SIGN OFF BETWEEN THE
PARAMEDIC AND THE NURSE IN THE
HOSPITAL? I THINK IF WE COULD
FOLLOW UP ON THAT, I THINK, UM,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE OUR, UH, STATE
DATABASE BUT THE REQUIREMENT FOR
AN ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE. YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD WITH STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THEIR LOCAL EP èC R PLATFORMS
AND HOW THEY WOULD IMPLEMENT IT.
SO I COULDN'T GIVE YOU AN ANSWER
ON THAT TODAY, BUT WE COULD
ABSOLUTELY FOLLOW NÓ. SO IT HAS
TO END YOUR SYSTEM HAS TO
INTERFACE WITH 58 COUNTIES AND
THOSE SYSTEM HAS HAVE TO
INTEGRATE WITH 1000 PLUS
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU. ONE LAST
THING IS THERE ANYTHING ON THERE
THAT ARE TOP OF HEAD? OTHER
INTERESTING DATA POINTS JUST TO
SHARE WITH US. AH NOT TOP OF
MIND. BUT I WOULD. UH WELCOME.
UH, WE HAVE AN ANNUAL KIMS
REPORT THAT WE WOULD LOVE. YOU
KNOW, WE'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE. OK
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. GREAT SO MS A
REQUESTS GENERAL FUND OF 3
MILLION IN 2425 THREE 0.1
MILLION AND 2526 AND THREE POINT
2,000,026 27. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL BE USED FOR THE
CONTINUED STORAGE AND SECURITY
OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL RESPONSE
EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES. SO
DURING THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC, I
S¼ A SINGLE WAREHOUSE, WHICH
CONTAINED APPROXIMATELY 25,000
SQUARE FEET OF STORAGE WAS
WOEFULLY INSUFFICIENT TO HOUSE
THE NEEDED EQUIPMENT AND
SUPPLIES TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT. DURING THE COVID-19
RESPONSE EFFORTS AS WELL AS ANY
OTHER FUTURE RESPONSES. SO TO
MEET THE IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
SPACE, I MS A LEAST THREE
ADDITIONAL WAREHOUSES TO SUPPORT
THE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS,
INCLUDING THE IN PROCESSING AND
STORAGE OF NEARLY 31,000
VENTILATORS, PLUS INFUSION PUMPS
AND OXYGEN CONCENTRATORS AND
OTHER ASSOCIATED UM EQUIPMENT
AND DEVICES TO SCALE BACK
WAREHOUSE STORAGE CAPACITY IN
PROPORTION TO DECLINING
EMERGENCY MEDICAL RESPONSE
NEEDS. AFTER THE INITIAL
COVID-19 PANDEMIC SURGE, THE
THREE ADDITIONAL WAREHOUSES WERE
CONSOLIDATED IN 21 AND 22 INTO
ONE WAREHOUSE WITH 255,000
SQUARE FEET, WHICH INCLUDES
13,000 SQUARE FEET OF OFFICE
SPACE. NOW EMSA REQUIRES 255,000
SQUARE FEET OF WAREHOUSE SPACE
AS WELL AS SECURITY SERVICES IN
JANITORIAL SERVICES, UH, TO
ADDRESS CURRENT WAREHOUSE,
OPERATIONAL NEEDS AND TO
ADEQUATELY STORE AND MANAGE EXI
EXISTING INVENTORIES OF MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT, MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND
OTHER MEDICAL RESPONSE ASSETS.
FOREIGN FINANCE AND ADDITIONAL
COMMENT. NÓ FURTHER COMMENTS. NÓ
FURTHER COMMENTS ON MY END,
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
AND BEFORE YOU LEAVE, WE'RE
GONNA OPEN IT TO PUBLIC. COM
COMMENT IF ANYONE HAS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT, AND UNDER MSA, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE EACH. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
NICK CLAY. I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, ALSO
KNOWN AS M, S¼, A èC. WE
REPRESENT ALL 34 LOCAL EM S¼
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
REPRESENTING ALL 58 COUNTIES. WE
ARE HERE TODAY TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF OUR CLOSE PARTNER
EMSA AND THEIR BUDGET ITEM AND
WE SUPPORT THEIR BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. JOHN POLAND. I'M
THE REGIONAL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SIERRA SACRAMENTO VALLEY
EM S¼ AGENCY WERE ONE OF THE SIX
REGIONAL EM S¼ AGENCIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ACTUALLY
COVER UM 10 COUNTIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I'M NOT GONNA READ
THEM ALL BECAUSE I ONLY HAVE A
MINUTE. UM, BUT, UM, AGAIN AS A
PARTNER OF MSO. WE SUPPORT THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND AGAIN WE
ARE JUST AS INTERESTED IN THE EM
S¼ DATA, WHICH HAS IMPROVED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND WE LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THAT IMPROVE AS
WELL. THANK YOU. HELLO HELLO. MY
NAME IS JEFF FERRIS. I AM THE EM
S¼, ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE COUNTY
OF KERN. AND I AM THE PRESIDENT
ELECT FOR M S¼ A AND I WANT TO
ECHO MY COLLEAGUES IN OUR
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET FOR EMSA.
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM
ON A DAILY BASIS AND IT'S VITAL
THAT THEY, UH, SYSTEM REMAIN
FUNCTIONAL FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COPY AND
PASTE. I HEAR YOU. THANK YOU.
SEE NÓ FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DEPARTMENT FOR
COMING TODAY. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO HÌ Kò DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE, ACCESS AND INFORMATION. I
WILL COME UP THE ADMINISTRATION.
LEO AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FOR ISSUES UNDER THIS DEPARTMENT
. WE'RE GOING TO START WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF HK.
OKAY? GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. UM ELIZABETH LANDSBURG,
THE DIRECTOR OF HÌ Kò. NICE TO
SEE YOU. UM I'LL BE PROVIDING A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF HÌ Kò OUR
BUDGET AND THEN I'M JOINED BY
TWO OF OUR DEPUTY DIRECTORS TO
HELP WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
OTHER ITEMS AS WELL. UM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE,
ACCESS AND INFORMATION WAS
RECAST FROM ASH IN THE 2021
BUDGET IN LIGHT OF OUR EXPANDED
PORTFOLIO. OUR MISSION IS TO
EXPAND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
QUALITY, AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS THROUGH
FACILITIES, ACTIONABLE
INFORMATION AND THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE THAT EACH COMMUNITY
NEEDS. WE HAVE FIVE PROGRAM
AREAS THAT I'LL TALK ABOUT
FACILITIES FINANCING, WORKFORCE
DATA AND AFFORDABILITY. OUR
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET IS 1.2
BILLION, AND OUR PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR 2024 25 IS 523. I SAID YES.
523 MILLION. UH, MANY OF THE
FUNDS WE RECEIVED PREVIOUSLY HAD
MULTIYEAR AUTHORITY. SOME OF THE
FUNDS FROM PRIOR YEARS ARE STILL
AVAILABLE AND WILL GO THROUGH
THAT, UM, WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
OUR WORKFORCE DEPUTY, UM TO TALK
ABOUT THE DELAYS. THE PROPOSED
DELAYS. THE PROPOSED BUDGET DOES
REFLECT DELAYS IN OUR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'LL TALK ABOUT.
WE ARE REQUESTING POSITION
AUTHORITY FOR 19 POSITIONS IN
THIS BUDGET, WHICH WOULD BRING
US TO 748 POSITIONS FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR. SO I'LL JUST GO
THROUGH BRIEFLY. OUR FIVE
PROGRAM AREAS. UM ON THE
BUILDING SIDE. WE ARE THE
BUILDING DEPARTMENT FOR
HOSPITALS AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES, MONITORING THE
CONSTRUCTION, RENOVATION AND
SEISMIC SAFETY OF THESE
FACILITIES. OUR PRIMARY GOAL IS
TO PROMOTE PATIENT SAFETY BY
ENSURING THAT EACH FACILITY
REMAINS FUNCTIONAL IN THE EVENT
OF A NATURAL DISASTER, INCLUDING
MAJOR EARTHQUAKES. ON THE
FINANCING SIDE. WE HAVE OUR COW
MORTGAGE PROGRAM, WHICH
PROVIDES, UH, LOAN INSURANCE TO
NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
FACILITIES FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND EXPANSION OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO ADMINISTERED WITH THE
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAM
, AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS YOU WERE HAVING
WITH CHA, UM, ABOUT THE
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAM
IF THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. OUR
FINANCE TEAM ALSO RUNS THE SMALL
AND RURAL HOSPITAL RELIEF
PROGRAM, WHICH PROVIDES GRANTS
TO RURAL AND CRITICAL ACCESS
HOSPITALS FOR SEISMIC SAFETY
COMPLIANCE PROJECTS. UM ON THE
DATA SIDE, WHERE A LEADER IN
COLLECTING HEALTH CARE DATA AND
DISSEMINATING IT, SO WE HAVE FOR
DECADES BEEN COLLECTING HOSPITAL
FINANCIAL DATA SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY FINANCIAL DATA,
PRESCRIPTION DRUG TRANSPARENCY,
DATA AND PATIENT OUTCOME. DATA
WE HAVE OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS
BEEN STANDING UP. CALIFORNIA'S
ALL PAIR CLAIMS DATABASE, THE
HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS DATA
PROGRAM AND WE ARE ABOUT TO
SUBMIT TO YOU A REPORT SHOWING
THE SUCCESS OF THAT PROGRAM, SO
WE WERE REQUIRED TO BE
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLIANT AND DID
START PUBLISHING. SO WE
LITERALLY HAVE ACCESS TO
BILLIONS OF CLAIMS THAT HAVE
BEEN PAID BY HEALTH PLANS TO
PROVIDERS AND HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA, SO IT'S A VERY RICH
DATA SET. SO WE HAVE STARTED TO
PUBLISH. WE HAVE A SNAPSHOT THAT
WE'VE PUBLISHED, UM AS WELL AS
SOME DEMOGRAPHIC AND GEOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
HEALTH CARE. UM AND WE'LL BE OUR
OUR PRIORITIES FOR THIS YEAR
WILL BE AROUND PRESCRIPTION DRUG
COSTS, HOSPITAL COSTS AS WELL AS
SOCIAL DRIVERS OF HEALTH, SO
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING
THAT INFORMATION ON THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE PROGRAM SIDE. UM HÌ
K'S WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS ALL HAVE THREE GOALS.
THE FIRST IS TO INCREASE THE
RACIAL AND LINGUISTIC DIVERSITY
OF THE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
THE SECOND IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DEVELOPING HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE THAT SERVES MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS. AND THEN THE
THIRD IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
HELPING DEVELOP A WORKFORCE THAT
WILL SERVE ME MEMBERS. WE FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON PRIMARY CARE,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND ORAL
HEALTH AND ITS WE'VE APPRECIATED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
THE CHAIR ABOUT SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS. WE'LL GET INTO MORE
DETAIL BOTH ABOUT SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS. UM, AND SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE PROPOSED DELAYS. BUT
AS YOU KNOW, WE ARE BOTH. UH WE
HAVE PIPELINE PROGRAMS TO BRING
MORE FOLKS AND A MORE DIVERSE,
UH, CANDIDATE POOL INTO BECOME
HEALTH CARE. WORKERS WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE INDIVIDUALS
THROUGH STIPEND PROGRAMS,
SCHOLARSHIP AND LOAN REPAYMENT,
AND THEN WE'RE SUPPORTING THE
TRAINING AND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. HK'S LAST PROGRAM AREA
IS AFFORDABILITY AND WE HAVE
THREE MAIN COMPONENTS THERE. THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY THE KOR X PROGRAM
TO ADDRESS PHARMACY COSTS AND
OUR HOSPITAL FARE BILLING
PROGRAM, SO I KNOW, UM THE NEXT
ITEM IS TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF
OKA SO I'LL HOLD OFF ON THAT AND
THEN, UM, IN RESPONSE TO
INCREASING PRESCRIPTION DRUG
PRICES, THE STATE HAS SET UP
THIS CALOR X PROGRAM, WHICH VÆ
PAGANI WILL GIVE AN UPDATE ABOUT
IN AN UPCOMING AGENDA ITEM. IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR, HK TOOK
OVER ENFORCEMENT OF THE OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITAL FAIR
BILLING ACT, WHICH IMPOSES
PARAMETERS ON WHAT HOSPITALS CAN
CHARGE UNINSURED AND
UNDERINSURED PATIENTS. SO HÌ NOW
HAS CONSUMER COMPLAINT PROCESS
WHERE WE CAN ACCEPT CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS ABOUT HOSPITAL BILLS
AND REVIEW THOSE TO SEE IF
HOSPITALS HAVE FOLLOWED THEIR
OWN DISCOUNT IN CHARITY CARE
POLICIES, AND WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THE POLICIES COMPLY WITH
THE LAW. SO THAT'S A NEW PROGRAM
AREA FOR US. UM I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE ON. TO THE OVERVIEW OF
OCHRE OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE OK? IN TERMS OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE 2022 23
BUDGET TO ADDRESS THE CRUSHING
COSTS CONSUMERS FACE IN PAYING
FOR HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS AND
SERVICES. UM EVERY YEAR, THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION DOES A SURVEY IN
EVERY YEAR. THERE'S FINDINGS
THAT MORE THAN HALF OF OUR
CALIFORNIA NEIGHBORS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS GO WITHOUT NEEDED HEALTH
CARE SERVICES DUE TO DUE TO COST
AND FACE WORSE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AS A RESULT, WE KNOW THAT'S
WORSE FOR BLACK CALIFORNIANS FOR
LATINX CALIFORNIANS AND FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN RESPONSE
TO THAT AFFORDABILITY BURDEN,
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
PARTNERED TO CREATE THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY OR
OCA. UM OK. HAS THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS, SLOWING HEALTH CARE
SPENDING GROWTH. PROMOTING A
HIGH VALUE SYSTEM. AND ASSESSING
MARKET CONSOLIDATION. SO WE HAVE
HAD OUR FIRST FULL YEAR OF
ENGAGEMENT WITH HEALTH CARE,
STAKEHOLDERS, SIBLING STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE PUBLIC. AND
SO I'M REALLY PLEASED TO GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE. UM WE, THE HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY BOARD, WHICH
IS MAKING SOME OF THE KEY
DECISIONS AS PART OF THIS EFFORT
, WAS APPOINTED AND BEGAN
MEETING LAST MARCH. SO WE MEET
MONTHLY. WE JUST HAD A MEETING
YESTERDAY. UM AND I CAN SAY WE
HAVE VERY ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO COME TO OUR Ó A BOARD
MEETINGS, UM, AND ARE
PARTICIPATING. IN ONE OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS IS TO ESTABLISH A
SPENDING GROWTH TARGET AND OCA
AND THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. UH, BOARD ARE
WORKING TOWARD A JUNE 1ST
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT TO SET
THAT SPENDING GROWTH TARGET THAT
ESTABLISHES AN ACCEPTABLE ANNUAL
RATE OF GROWTH FOR PER CAPITA
HEALTH CARE SPENDING SO UNDER
THE STATUTE, THE STEPS ARE THAT
THE OFFICE HAS TO PROPOSE A
SPENDING GROWTH TARGET, AND IN
JANUARY, OUR OFFICE RECOMMENDED
TO THE BOARD A 3% STATEWIDE.
TARGET FOR FIVE YEARS FROM 2025
TO 2029, AND THAT IS BASED ON
THE 20 YEAR AVERAGE ANNUAL
CHANGE IN MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME. UM, FOR THE LAST 20
YEARS, SO WE REALLY VIEW OUR
MISSION TO MAKE SURE THAT HEALTH
CARE IS AFFORDABLE FOR
CONSUMERS. SO IT MADE SENSE FOR
US AND FOR THE BOARD. TO LOOK TO
THAT HISTORICAL MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME GROWTH, SO WE BELIEVE
IT'S IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
BOARD'S PREFERENCE FOR USING A
CONSUMER CENTRIC ECONOMIC
INDICATOR. UH, WE THINK TYING
THE TARGET TO HISTORICAL MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME GROWTH REALLY
SIGNALS THAT HEALTH CARE
SPENDING SHOULD NOT GROW FASTER
THAN THE INCOME OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE LAST 20 YEARS IS THAT
WAGES HAVE BARELY KEPT PACE WITH
INFLATION AND HEALTH CARE COSTS
HAVE BEEN RAISED, HAVE BEEN
RISING AT TWICE THAT AMOUNT.
THIS RECOMMENDATION PLACES
CALIFORNIA ON THE PATH OF A MORE
SUSTAINABLE, AFFORDABLE AND
EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM,
SLOWING THE TRAJECTORY OF HEALTH
CARE, SPENDING GROWTH AND
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS, SO THE BOARD HAS
UNTIL JANUARY. 1ST PARDON ME
JUNE 1ST TO ADOPT THAT FIRST
SPENDING GROWTH TARGET SO THEY
WILL DO SO IN ONE OF THEIR NEXT
THREE MEETINGS. AND ONE OF THE
KEY, UM, TOOLS OF THE OFFICE IS
TRANSPARENCY, SO WE ARE
COLLECTING A NEW DATA SET OF
TOTAL HEALTH CARE SPENDING. UM
IN THE STATE. WE'VE NOT HAD THAT
THAT, UM ACCESS TO THAT DATA, SO
WE'RE IN THE FINAL STAGES OF
DRAFTING REGULATIONS.
ESTABLISHING REQUIREMENTS, UM,
FOR HEALTH PLANS TO SUBMIT TOTAL
HEALTH CARE, UM, DATA TO US TO
FACILITATE THE DATA COLLECTION
NECESSARY TO MEASURE TOTAL
HEALTH CARE EXPENDITURES WITH
THAT? WILL BE PUBLISHING A
BASELINE HEALTH CARE SPENDING
REPORT IN 2025. UM ANOTHER KEY
PIECE OF OUR WORK AT OCA IS
HEALTH IS REALLY TRYING TO DRIVE
TO A HIGH VALUE SYSTEM. THIS IS
NOT ABOUT A RACE TO THE BOTTOM,
BUT WE REALLY WANT, UM, A HIGH
VALUE SYSTEM THAT'S MORE
EQUITABLE AND A QUALITY SYSTEM
SO ENSURES TO ENSURE A BALANCED
APPROACH TO SLOW SPENDING GROWTH
. WE ARE PROMOTING HIGH VALUE
SYSTEM PERFORMANCE THROUGH
CREATING ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
MODEL STANDARDS. UM, SO THAT
WE'RE HOPEFULLY PAYING FOR VALUE
INSTEAD OF JUST FOR CARE. UM,
WE'RE SETTING PRIMARY INVESTMENT
BENCHMARKS. WE THE RESEARCH IS
CLEAR THAT IF YOU SPEND MORE ON
PRIMARY AND PREVENTIVE CARE, YOU
ACTUALLY CAN BOTH IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND BRING COSTS DOWN.
SIMILARLY WE WILL BE SETTING
BENCHMARKS FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SPENDING AND MEASURING QUALITY
AND EQUITY MEASURES AT THE SAME
TIME THAT WE'RE MEASURING COSTS.
UM AND WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON
DEVELOPING A WORKFORCE
STABILITY, UM, STANDARD. LAST
BECAUSE HEALTH CARE
CONSOLIDATION IS A MAJOR DRIVER
OF HEALTH CARE, UH, COST. THE
THIRD MAIN AREA THAT OCA HAS
AUTHORITY OVER IS HEALTH CARE
MARKET OVERSIGHT. SO WE HAVE
ISSUED REGULATIONS TO HAVE NEW
REQUIREMENTS IF THERE IS A
PROPOSED MERGER ACQUISITION,
DEALING, UH SIGNIFICANT MERGER
ACQUISITIONS IN THE HEALTHCARE
SPACE IN CALIFORNIA, THERE IS
NOW A REQUIREMENT TO FILE A
NOTICE WITH US IF WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THAT, UM,
TRANSACTION COULD RESULT IN
NEGATIVE IMPACT TO ON ACCESS OR
AFFORDABILITY. WE CAN DO A FULL
COST OF MARKET IMPACT REVIEW.
OUR TEAM STOOD UP A PORTAL TO
ACCEPT THOSE NOTICES AND AS OF
JANUARY, 1ST HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
OCA WITH 90 DAYS ADVANCE NOTICE
OF A PROPOSED TRANSACTION. UH,
WE HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED OUR
FIRST TRANSACTION. BUT WE ARE WE
ARE READY. WE ARE READY AND WE
ARE WAITING. AND WE ARE, UM,
COLLABORATING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. IF WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT A TRANSACTION WILL
CERTAINLY BE, UH, WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
SIBLING. UH, DEPARTMENTS AND ON
THAT. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. AND YOU
SAID YOUR COLLEAGUE IS GONNA GO
INTO èC RX, RIGHT? UM, THEN,
UH, MY FIRST QUESTION TO YOU IS
REGARDING THE DATA POINT. WE'RE
GONNA GET, UM, SHOWING THE
SPENDING COST. IS THAT GONNA
BRING IT DOWN THROUGH TYPES OF
INSURANCE? MEDICAL PROVINCE? OK
GREAT. YEAH, SO WE'LL BE
REPORTING SEPARATELY ON
COMMERCIAL COVERAGE MEDI AND
MEDICARE. AND DOING AN ANALYSIS
OF COST. UH, DRIVERS. THANK YOU,
GENERAL. ANY QUESTIONS? OK WE'LL
GO ON TO, UM UM, THAT THIRD
QUESTION. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. UM I'M
VISHAL PAGANI, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AT HÌ Kò. I FIRST
START WITH PROVIDING AN UPDATE
ON THE CALOR X BIOSIMILAR
INSULIN INITIATIVE. AS MANY OF
YOU ARE AWARE, UM IN FEBRUARY,
2020 THREE, HÌ Kò INITIATED A
CONTRACT WITH CIVIC RX, A
NONPROFIT DRUG COMPANY FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF BIOSIMILARS OF
THE THREE MOST POPULAR VERSIONS
OF INSULIN, INSULIN, ASPART,
LIRO AND GLARGINE. UM SECA IS
ADVANCING ON ITS DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS AND MAINTAINS CLOSE
COMMUNICATION WITH THE F Dð, A
THEY DO NOT AT THIS TIME, HAVE A
SPECIFIC TIME FRAME FOR
APPROVAL. IN UH, HIS ROLE AS A
CæA FOUNDATION BOARD MEMBER, DR
MARK GALLEY, HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH AND HELP DRIVE OUR
CIVIC PARTNERS TO MAKE CAL RX
INSULIN AVAILABLE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. SECA IS ALSO ENHANCING
ITS UH, PETERSBURG, VIRGINIA
TEAM WITH ADDITIONAL NEW MEMBERS
DEDICATED EXCLUSIVELY TO
INSULIN. REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET DEFERRAL OF
THE 50 MILLION FOR THE
MANUFACTURING FACILITY. WE NOTE
THAT THIS COMPONENT OF THE
INITIATIVE ENTAILS COMPLEX
PLANNING WITH ACTIVE
COLLABORATION AMONG HÌ, Kò CIVIC
AND GOBI. UM IT IS ANTICIPATED
TO EXTEND BEYOND THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR DUE TO ITS
MULTIFACETED NATURE THAT
INCLUDES SITE SELECTION,
ASSESSING WATER AND ENERGY NEEDS
AND ENSURING ACCESS TO SKILLED
LABOR. THE PROJECT WILL BE
NECESSARY WHEN CIVICA NEEDS TO
EXTEND BEYOND ITS INITIAL
OVERSEAS SUPPLIER FOR ACTIVE
DRUG SUBSTANCE, AT WHICH TIME
THE CALIFORNIA BASED
MANUFACTURING FACILITY WOULD BE
THE DOMESTIC SOURCE FOR ACTIVE
DRUG SUBSTANCE. UM, CCA IS ALSO
MAKING GOOD PROGRESS ON UH,
COMMERCIALIZATION. THIS THIS IS
ABOUT GETTING THE PRODUCT IN THE
MARKET. AND GETTING IT COVERED
CIVIC IS HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH
HEALTH PLANS AND PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGERS IN CALIFORNIA
TO ACHIEVE, UH, PREFERRED
FORMULARY STATUS, UM, TO GET THE
INSULIN COVERED ON THE HEALTH
PLAN DRUG FORMULARIES FOR THE
CIVIC AND CAL RX BRANDED
PRODUCTS ONCE THEY'RE APPROVED
BY THE F Dð, A AND. I'LL NOW
MOVE ON TO PROVIDING AN UPDATE
ON THE NALOXONE. ACCESS
INITIATIVE. REGARDING OUR WORK
TO BRING A LOW COST OVER THE
COUNTER VERSION OF NALOXONE. WE
HAVE BEEN HAVING POSITIVE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH
MULTIPLE VENDORS. WE ARE
CONFIDENT WE'LL WE WILL BE ABLE
TO PROCURE AN OVER THE COUNTER.
VERSION OF NALOXONE AT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED PRICE THAN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST PRICE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES NALOXONE DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM. OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT IN PLACE
BY SUMMER IN A RX BRANDED
NALOXONE PRODUCT AVAILABLE FOR
PURCHASE BY THE END OF THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND THAT WRAPS UP
MY CALL X, UM, UPDATE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD. HELLO. JASON
KANTARO CIO, UM, NOTHING MORE TO
ADD ON THIS ITEM, BUT AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. PERFECT I JUST
WANT TO CONFIRM SO THE THERE'S
NÓ SPECIFIC TIME FRAME FOR THE F
Dð A APPROVAL FOR, UM, THE
INSULIN PORTION. IS THAT WHAT
YOU MENTIONED? YES, OK. AND THEN
FOR, UM NALOXONE WE BY THE END
OF THE YEAR, CONSUMERS WILL BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE THE CHEAPER
VERSION. UH, YES. BY THE END OF,
UH, WE HOPE TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT BY SUMMER AND THEN
BUT, YEAH, BY THE END OF THE
YEAR, UM NOT JUST CONSUMERS, BUT
ALSO, UM, ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SERVE HARM REDUCTION AGENCIES.
WHAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET THE
CALIFORNIA UM, THE PRICE THAT WE
NEGOTIATE. AND WHAT'S THAT GONNA
LOOK LIKE? IN TERMS OF HOW AN
ORGANIZATION OR AN INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMER BE ABLE TO PURCHASE
THEM. SO THERE'S UM A FEW USE
CASES. THERE'S ONE IS THE STATE
PURCHASING, WHICH IS THE  N Dð P
PROGRAM THAT Dð HÌ èC S¼
ADMINISTERS. SO UM, UH, SOME
LOWER PRICES THAT WE NEGOTIATE
WITH A PARTNER COULD YOU KNOW
THEY THEY WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE AT THAT LOWER PRICE,
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO EXTEND, UM
THE PRICING THAT WE NEGOTIATE TO
OTHER ENTITIES. I MAY NOT
QUALIFY, UM, TO GET FREE
NALOXONE THROUGH THE  N Dð P. UM
SO THESE THESE COULD BE COUNTIES
, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OR JUST
OTHER OTHER TYPE OF NONPROFITS
THAT MAY NOT BE ELIGIBLE, SO WE
WANT TO EXTEND THE SAME TERMS
AND CONDITIONS OF PRICING TO
THEM, UM, FOR THE SELECTED
PARTNER AND THEN FOR CONSUMERS
THAT ARE MORE DIRECT, LIKE
INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY BE
PURCHASING FOR A FAMILY MEMBER
THAT'S EXPERIENCING OPIOID USE
DISORDER, UM, THAT THAT WE'RE
ALSO WORKING ON HOW HOW DO WE
MAKE THAT AVAILABLE SO THAT THEY
COULD PURCHASE SMALLER? IT IS.
WOULD THIS BRING IN ADDITIONAL
REVENUES? ON TOP OF, UH WE ARE
WE BREAKING EVEN. JUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UM CAN
YOU CLARIFY YOUR QUESTION? SO IF
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA BE SELLING
THESE THESE THIS ITEM, UM IS IT
AFTER CREATING IT, THE
INVESTMENT WE PUT INTO THIS AND
AFTER AND THEN SELLING IT, ARE
WE BREAKING EVEN? OR IS THAT
GONNA BRING ADDITIONAL REVENUES
TO THE STATE? LET US GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT TO GET SOME MORE
DETAIL ON THAT, AND WE CAN
CONNECT WITH YOUR STAFF. UM TOP
OF MY HEAD. I CAN'T GIVE CLEAR.
UH, GOOD ANSWER ON THAT. BUT LET
US LOOK INTO THAT MATTER, AND
WE'LL GIVE YOU A BETTER
RESPONSE. OK ANY JUST A JUST A
QUICK QUESTION. UH, MADAM CHAIR
WITH RESPECT TO THE INSULIN
PROJECT. I REALIZE WE CAN'T
CONTROL THE LENGTH OF TIME THAT
IT TAKES F Dð A TO ISSUE AN
APPROVAL. BUT SINCE THIS IS
OTHERWISE A BUSINESS ACTIVITY.
DO WE HAVE ANY PROJECTION AS TO
MAYBE YOU MENTIONED THIS AS TO
HOW LONG IT WILL TAKE TO ROLL IT
OUT. AND ONCE F Dð A APPROVAL
HAS BEEN GRANTED. YEAH, ONCE, UM
F Dð A APPROVES IT. CIVICA
INTENDS TO HAVE, UM BATCHES OF
PRODUCTS. UM. HØI IN PRODUCTION
THAT THEY COULD IMMEDIATELY
BEGIN DISTRIBUTING. UM SO I
MEAN, IS THAT A YEAR IS THAT 18
MONTHS FOLLOWING F Dð A APPROVAL
? IT SHOULD BE. UM I CAN'T GIVE
A SPECIFICS ON WHEN F Dð A
APPROVAL WILL OCCUR. UM, THEY
WON'T BE THIS YEAR. BUT UM,
COMPANY MUST HAVE AN IDEA. ONCE
THEY GET F Dð A APPROVAL. IT'S
GOING TO TAKE US 12 YEARS TO
MOVE THIS OR 812 YEARS. 12
MONTHS TO MOVE THIS OR 18
MONTHS? YEAH ONCE IT GETS
APPROVED BY THE F Dð A IT WOULD
BE WITHIN MONTHS THAT THEY COULD
BEGIN DISTRIBUTING. WOULDN'T BE
ANOTHER YEAR THAT NEEDS TO GO
ON. PERFECT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. UM, WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A QUICK FIVE MINUTE
RECESS FOR, UH, FOR FIVE MINUTES
AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
67 3. WE'LL RESUME. WE'RE MOVING
NOW ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
PLEASE PROCEED. I'LL BE COVERING
ISSUE TWO. UM WHICH IS THE CALOR
X TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT. B èC P.
HER BACKGROUND. UH, LAST MAY, HK
SUBMITTED A B èC P FOR THE Kò
RX NALOXONE ACCESS INITIATIVE,
WHICH INCLUDED FUNDING TO
SUPPORT A PARTNERSHIP TO BRING A
LOW COST OVER THE COUNTER
VERSION OF A NALOXONE NASAL
PRODUCT. AS WELL AS FUNDING FOR
THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE INCREASING WORKLOAD
OF ADMINISTERING THE CALOR X
PROGRAM. THE FUNDING FOR THESE
THREE POSITIONS WAS APPROVED
THROUGH THE MAY REVISION. P èC
P. THE REQUEST FOR A POSITION
AUTHORITY WAS DESCRIBED IN THE
NARRATIVE BUT DID NOT MAKE IT TO
THE SUMMARY OF THE MAY 23. THE
MAY REVISION. P èC P DUE TO AN
OVERSIGHT. THIS PROPOSAL
REQUESTS TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
ENABLE HÌ Q TO TRUE UP ITS
POSITION AUTHORITY WITH THE
ASSOCIATED WORKLOAD OF PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION. UM THAT WRAPS UP
MY OVERVIEW. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. UH ALBERT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THIS B èC P HAS
NÓ FISCAL TIED TO IT AND IS
UTILIZING EXISTING RESOURCES.
HELLO. YEAH, JUST TO EMPHASIZE
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID
. THIS IS A TECHNICAL CORRECTION
. LAST YEAR'S BUDGET, UH,
PROVIDED FUNDING FOR THE
POSITIONS BUT DIDN'T PROVIDE
AUTHORITY TO INCREASE THE
POSITIONS. AND SO THIS PROVIDES
THAT AUTHORITY SO IT FOR THAT
REASON WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS
WITH IT. UM ELIO. ACTUALLY I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU. LET'S
START THERE. UM, I THINK IT WAS
JUST YESTERDAY. YOU CAME OUT
WITH YOUR HÌ Kò OVERVIEW. THAT'S
CORRECT. UM, IN IN IN THERE. IT
TALKED ABOUT JUST THE GROWTH OF
HÌ Kò. UM, YOU SHARED 700. 4018
EMPLOYEES, POTENTIALLY, UM AND
THE WORKLOAD, POTENTIALLY
DECREASING. A LOT OF PROGRAMS
ARE, UM THEY WERE DONE IN A LOT
OF OTHER PROGRAMS ARE BEING
PROPOSED FOR DELAY FOR IT TO BE
DELAYED. COULD WE TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE JUST THE
YEAH. AND NOW THAT THAT IS, UM,
ON YOUR AGENDA FOR ISSUE THREE,
SO WE'D BE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
AN HOUR WE COULD WE COULD TALK
ABOUT THEN THEN. OK, GREAT.
YEAH, WE'LL WE'LL GET TO THAT
APP. ANY QUESTIONS FOR RIGHT
NOW, GENERAL? OK, WE WANT TO
ISSUE THREE THEN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND GOOD AFTERNOON, LIBBY
ABBOTT, DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. THE ALIGNMENT OF
HEALTH WORKFORCE, DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND STAFFING RESOURCES
PROPOSAL IS REQUESTING POSITION
AUTHORITY FOR 16 POSITIONS FOR
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR FISCAL YEAR 2024
25. AND ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT
MULTIPLE NEW AND EXPANDING
HEALTH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES. THESE
16 POSITIONS WOULD BE SUPPORTED
BY PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. THE B èC
P IS A TRUE UP FOR WORKLOAD, AND
WE ARE USING IT TO REPLACE
CONTRACT AND BLANKET STAFF IN
TRANSITION THEM TO PERMANENT
STATE STAFF IN ORDER TO CATCH UP
WITH AND SUSTAIN WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN FUNDING TO HÌ Kò FOR
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. LAST YEAR'S
AND CURRENT YEARS. DELAYS SPREAD
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD OUT OVER
TIME, BUT DO NOT REDUCE OUR
TOTAL WORKLOAD. THE FUNDS IN
QUESTION HAVE MULTIYEAR SPENDING
AUTHORITY AND MANY OF OUR 56
PROGRAMS THAT WE NOW HAVE IN
FLIGHT AT HÌ Kò ARE IMPLEMENTED
AND NEED TO BE MONITORED OVER
SEVERAL YEAR PERIODS WITH
ASSOCIATED WORKLOAD FOR THAT
MONITORING, SO WE ANTICIPATE A
SUSTAINED WORKLOAD FOR AT LEAST
SEVERAL YEARS. THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. FINANCE. AND ALBERT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NOTHING FURTHER THAT THANK YOU.
JASON, GO AHEAD. SO UM, JUST FOR
REFERENCE ON PAGE 37. YOU CAN
YOU CAN AGAIN SEE THAT THE
PROPOSALS FOR 16 POSITIONS BUT
NÓ ASSOCIATED FISCAL EFFECT OF
THAT, AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
MANAGE THESE INCREASED POSITIONS
WITHIN ITS EXISTING RESOURCES.
THAT'S VERY UNDERSTANDABLE,
GIVEN THE BUDGET PROBLEM, AND
BECAUSE OF THIS, THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF DOES NOT CONTRIBUTE
DIRECTLY TO THE BUDGET PROBLEM.
THAT SAID, AND WE WILL DISCUSS
THIS MORE ALSO IN THE NEXT ISSUE
, TOO, BUT THE STATE'S BUDGET
SITUATION IS DETERIORATING AND
THE LEGISLATURE LIKELY WILL FACE
PRESSURE TO IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
SOLUTIONS BEYOND THOSE
IDENTIFIED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL SOLUTIONS
WITHIN HKS BUDGET THAT WOULD
HAVE POTENTIAL WORKLOAD
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE FOR THE UM,
DEPARTMENT. FOR THAT REASON WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REVISIT THIS PROPOSAL IN MAY,
WHEN IT HAS A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OF THE
REVISED SORT OF BUDGET SITUATION
AND ALSO A SENSE OF WHAT ACTIONS
ARE TAKEN, AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT ADDITIONAL ACTIONS ARE
TAKEN TO PULL BACK FUNDING FOR
HÌ Kò WORKFORCE INITIATIVES THAT
IT THAT IT, UH ADJUST TO HÌ Kò
STAFFING ACCORDINGLY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, UM. SO LAST
YEAR, THE BUDGET WAS A LITTLE
TINY, TINY BIT BETTER, AND IT
WAS PROPOSED FOR DELAY AND I
KNOW WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT AN
ISSUE FOUR BUT JUST GETTING A
LITTLE AHEAD OF OURSELVES HERE,
BUT AND IT WAS PROPOSED FOR
DELAY. AND THEN THIS YEAR BUDGET
IS WORSE, AND IT WAS AGAIN
PROPOSED FOR DELAY. I HAVE LIKE
LITTLE HOPE THAT NEXT YEAR IT
WON'T BE THAT IT WILL. IN FACT,
IT'LL BE PROPOSED FOR DELAYED
AGAIN. UM SO I'M WONDERING YOU.
YOU SHARED, UM, THAT YOU KNOW,
THIS WILL BE ONGOING WORK. YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE IF WE
CONTINUE DELAYING TO MAYBE I
DON'T KNOW. CUTTING HOW YOU
FORESEE THAT ONGOING WORK
LOOKING. YEAH, ABSOLUTELY. SO
THE IMPACTS OF THE DELAYS
CERTAINLY PUSH OUT THE LAUNCH OF
NEW PROGRAMS OR NEW CYCLES, BUT
WE'VE RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS. AND WHAT I ALLUDED TO
BRIEFLY IN IN MY EARLIER COMMENT
WAS THAT WHEN WE IMPLEMENT A
PROGRAM IT'S OFTEN IMPLEMENTED
OVER A TWO YEAR CYCLE, SO
PROGRAMS THAT WE STARTED WITH
THE 2022 BUDGET ACT IN 20, THREE
24 OUR ARE GONNA HAVE SEVERAL
YEARS SORT OF WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED FOR EVALUATION OF
THOSE FUNDS. HAVE THEY BEEN
EFFECTIVE GRANT MONITORING TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE IN COMPLIANCE
ASSOCIATED SORT OF FINANCIAL
MONITORING FUNCTIONS AS WELL.
CAN YOU TALK TO US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE NON THE WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS ARE WERE PROPOSED FOR
DELAY. THE ONES ARE STILL GOING
THE ONES THAT WE ALREADY SENT
SOME MONEY ON ABSOLUTELY. UM AND
I THINK THAT'S SKIPPING AHEAD TO
THE LATER QUESTION. BUT I'M
HAPPY TO JUMP TO THAT. WE SO
2022 BUDGET ACT. LET'S CONNECT
THAT TO ISSUE THREE. THE
POSITIONS THESE 16, I FORGOT. 16
POSITIONS. UM ARE WE ATTRIBUTING
THESE POSITIONS TO THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN ONGOING
AS MAINTAINING THEM? OR ARE YOU
ATTRIBUTING THESE TO SO THESE
POSITIONS ARE ACTUALLY STAFF
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE EITHER
CONTRACT STAFF OR TEMPORARY
STAFF. SO IT'S FOR OUR CURRENT
WORKLOAD. UM, AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DO IS TRANSITION
THEM TO PERMANENT STATE STAFF
WITH THIS B èC P. SO THOSE ARE
PROGRAM OR SORRY STAFF THAT
SUPPORT OUR ONGOING PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING THOSE THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED OVER ARE THEY PART
TIME RIGHT NOW? ARE THERE FULL
TIME WITHOUT BEING FULL TIME
CONTRACT OR IN THE BLANKET? OK
UM, BECAUSE THEY'RE CONTRACTED.
ARE WE PAYING AT A HIGHER PRICE
FOR CONTRACT? WOULD IT BE A
DIFFERENT NOW GOING THE STATE. I
THINK I WOULD WANT TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT ONE. OK, JUST BE
TO NOT MISSPEAK ON ANY SPECIFIC
NUMBERS, OK? AND SHOULD WE SAY.
WELL, WHEN DOES THE CONTRACT
END? WE HAVE CONTRACT AUTHORITY
THROUGH. I BELIEVE MIDDLE TO END
OF 2025. IT'S A SORT OF A ROUGH
ESTIMATE, GIVEN WE ANTICIPATE
SOME SAVINGS. UM OUR HOPE IS TO
BRING ON STAFF SO THAT WE CAN
TRANSITION OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE. WE'VE BEEN RELYING ON
THESE CONTRACTORS FOR THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF, AND WE WANT TO
HAVE AN OVERLAP PERIOD SO WE CAN
TRANSITION SO THESE POSITIONS
THE FUNDING WON'T TAKE INTO
EFFECT UNTIL THE NEXT BUDGET
CYCLE. IF THESE POSITIONS ARE
FUNDED UNTIL NEXT FISCAL YEAR
WELL AND TO CLARIFY THIS IS JUST
POSITION AUTHORITY. WE ALREADY
HAVE THE FUNDING FOR THAT. WHAT
I'M SAYING MEANING? YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING'S ON THE TABLE. I
MEAN, IF FOSTER KIDS ARE ON THE
TABLE, EVERYTHING'S ON THE TABLE
RIGHT, MEANING THAT FUNDING THAT
WAS ALLOCATED IN SOME WORLD
COULD WE ESSENTIALLY PULL IT
BACK FOR THAT YEAR BECAUSE WE
DON'T NEED IT FOR THE NEXT YEAR
SINCE THOSE POSITIONS ALREADY
FUNDED FOR ONE MORE YEAR? RIGHT?
DID I DESCRIBE THAT? YEAH I MEAN
, I THINK PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CONVEY IS THE PROGRAMS
ARE IN FLIGHT. RIGHT SO IT'S
TRUE THAT THERE'S PROPOSALS TO
DELAY SOCIAL WORK AND TO DELAY
NURSING AND TO DELAY SOME OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, BUT WE ARE
STILL DOING WORK IN ALL OF THOSE
AREAS. AND SO WE DO NEED STAFF
TO CONTINUE TO DO THOSE WORK BUT
THEIR STAFF AND FUNDED BY THE
CONTRACTS UNTIL MID 2025 CORRECT
SO THE MONEY THAT'S. SITTING IN
èC WILL BE SITTING IN HK UNTIL
MID 2025. WE HAVE. THERE ARE
DIFFERENT POTS OF MONEY, AND WE
TYPICALLY WILL GET FIVE YEAR
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. SO RIGHT.
WE HAD CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE DOLLARS THAT
CAME IN TWO YEARS AGO, WE HAD
WORKFORCE FOR THE CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL DOLLARS THAT CAME IN LAST
YEAR, EACH OF WHICH HAS FIVE
YEAR EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. OK?
YEAH, MAYBE JUST TO ADD TO THAT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS INDICATING IS THAT
THEY ARE IMPLEMENTING
INITIATIVES THAT WERE FUNDED IN
PREVIOUS BUDGETS. THOSE FUNDS
CAME WITH MULTI YEAR EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY, SO THEY ANTICIPATE
SOME OF THOSE ACTIVITIES TO
INCLUDE TO, UH YOU KNOW, PERSIST
IN THE FUTURE. THE QUESTION
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURES. THESE
ARE THESE ARE PROPOSED SORT OF
PERMANENT STAFFING POSITIONS,
AND, UH, JUST THE BUDGET
SITUATION IS UNCERTAIN AND THE
SORT OF FUTURE OF SOME OF THESE
FUND FUNDING ALLOCATIONS FOR
WORKFORCE ARE UNCERTAIN. AND SO
THAT'S WHY IT WILL BE THE LEG.
LEGISLATURE LIKELY WILL WANT TO
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS IT'S AS
IT'S, UM, SORT OF REVIEWING THE
NEED FOR THESE POSITIONS ON A
PERMANENT BASIS. THINNER. JUST.
QUESTION OF INTEREST, YOU KNOW,
READING ABOUT THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE
FUNDING, ALMOST $1 BILLION AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR WHAT YOU
DO. I THINK IT'S BADLY NEEDED.
I'M JUST WONDERING IF WE IF
THERE'S A REPORT OF RESULTS. IN
OTHER WORDS, STUDENTS ENROLLED
AND UM. YOU KNOW HOW I'M A DATED
GUY? SO I FORGIVE ME FOR ASKING
THE QUESTION. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. YEAH, ABSOLUTELY. AND
I AND I'VE TOUCHED ON THAT AN
ISSUE FOR SO READY TO GO TO THAT
ONE. I CAN CERTAINLY WAIT. I
ALTHOUGH I'VE BEEN ACCUSED OF
NOT HAVING ANY I DO HAVE SOME
PATIENTS, SO I'LL WAIT FOR ISSUE
FOR IT. IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
OUR QUESTIONS ARE AN ISSUE FOR
US, SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE INTO
ISSUE FOUR. I CAN PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A DELAY OF 140.1
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THE
NURSING AND SOCIAL WORK
INITIATIVE. MOVING THESE FUNDS
TO 2025 26. THE BUDGET ALSO
DELAYS 100 AND 89.4 MILLION
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND DUE
TO LOWER THAN PROJECTED REVENUES
FOR VARIOUS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVES. THE BUDGET OVERALL
MAINTAINS 974.4 MILLION OVER A
MULTIYEAR PERIOD. THE BUDGET.
ALSO REV REVERTS 14 MILLION FOR
A STATE HOSPITAL LOAN REPAYMENT
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT
PROGRAM. AND THESE ARE FUNDS
THAT HAVE NOT GONE OUT AND THERE
WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO PULL THE
FUNDS AS A SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET SHORTFALL. I WOULD
ALSO FLAG THAT THROUGH PROP 98
FUNDING. THERE IS A
COMPLEMENTARY NURSING PROGRAM
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THAT ALLOCATES █60
MILLION PER YEAR OR A TOTAL OF
300 MILLION OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS, STARTING IN 2024 25.
YEAH. SO UM, THERE ARE A LOT OF,
UH, WORKFORCE INITIATIVES AT HÌ
Kò AND THERE. THERE ARE SEVERAL
INITIATIVES AFFECTED BY THIS
PROPOSAL. IF YOU IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE 40, YOU'LL SEE A TABLE KIND
OF TOWARDS THE BOTTOM THERE AND
IT EXTENDS THROUGH PAGE 41. AND
THAT SHOWS ALL THE AFFECTED
INITIATIVES UNDER THIS PROPOSAL,
AND IT ALSO SHOWS THE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUND AND ALSO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND THAT'S
EITHER BEING DELAYED OR REDUCED.
SO YOU KNOW, GENERALLY, OUR
COMMENTS HERE ARE GOING TO BE
SIMILAR TO COMMENTS YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT OTHER BUDGET SOLUTIONS. WE
GENERALLY FIND THE YOU KNOW
PROPOSALS ADDRESSING ONE TIME
SPENDING TO BE REASONABLE, YOU
KNOW, TURNING TO ONE TIME
SPENDING FIRST, UM, YOU KNOW,
AVOIDS HAVING TO TURN TURN TO ON
A CORE ONGOING PROGRAMS AND ALSO
MAKES AVAILABLE OTHER ONE TIME
RELATED SOLUTIONS IN THE
AVAILABLE IN THE FUTURE, SUCH AS
DRAWING DOWN RESERVES. THAT SAID
THERE ARE TWO KEY POINTS. I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE HERE FOR THIS
PROPOSAL FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION. THE FIRST IS
THAT, UM AS HAS BEEN REFERENCED
EARLIER. THE STATE'S BUDGET
SITUATION IS DETERIORATING, THE
LEGISLATURE WILL LIKELY HAVE TO
FIND ADDITIONAL SOLUTIONS IN
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT THAT
RAISES TWO KEY DECISION POINTS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. WITH REGARD TO THIS
PROPOSAL, IT IT COULD MEAN YOU
KNOW, YOU KNOW, PULLING BACK
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
HÌ Kò WORKFORCE INITIATIVES THAT
ARE THAT ARE REMAIN UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, OR
ALTERNATIVELY, IF THESE
INITIATIVES ARE OF HIGH PRIORITY
TO THE LEGISLATURE, THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD WANT TO FIND
NOT ONLY AMOUNT OF FUNDING
ELSEWHERE IN THE BUDGET TO
ADDRESS BUT EVEN MORE THAN THAT,
GIVEN GIVEN THE INCREASING
BUDGET PROBLEM. THE SECOND POINT
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS THAT UM
MUCH OF THESE SOLUTIONS FOCUS ON
DELAYS RATHER THAN REDUCTIONS IS
IMPLICIT ASSUMPTION. THERE IS
THAT IMPLEMENTATION FOR THESE
INITIATIVES WILL RESUME IN IN
THE FOLLOWING YEAR. AND AS WAS
SORT OF REFERENCED EARLIER. UM
BOTH OUR OFFICE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION PROJECT THERE TO
BE DEFICITS IN THE OUT YEARS
RUNNING AROUND $30 BILLION EACH
YEAR, AND SO GIVEN THAT GIVEN
THOSE DEFICITS THAT THAT
ASSUMPTION THAT, UM SO SOME
WOULD CONTINUE WITH KIND OF THE
FOLLOWING YEAR MIGHT NOT BE
REALISTIC. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. UM SO LET'S I MEAN,
WE'RE ALSO HERE. WE'RE NOT HERE
JUST TO SAY WE WANNA FUND
EVERYTHING. LET'S ALSO FIND
OTHER WAYS. RIGHT WE CAN BE
CREATIVE. AND I AGREE WITH YOU,
JASON. MAYBE UM, EVEN THOUGH
IT'S DIFFICULT, UM 11 TIME
FUNDING, WE CAN DELAY OR OR OR
CUT. SO TO THAT POINT, MY FIRST
QUESTION IS RELATED. HOW WE CAME
TO SOME WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
MOVING FORWARD AND OTHERS NOT SO
I SAW THAT 7 MILLION FOR COUNTY
BASED PSYCHIATRIC LOAN REPAYMENT
AND THEN A MATCHING 7 MILLION
FROM THE M HÌ S¼ FUND IS BEING
PROPOSED FOR DELAYS OR CUT. HOW
DO WE GET TO THAT BEING CHOSEN
AS THE ONE BECAUSE THAT'S
ALREADY PEOPLE INSIDE RIGHT? SO
INSTEAD OF FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT
BRING MORE PEOPLE TO THE
WORKFORCE UH, JUST TO CLARIFY.
YOU REFER YOU'RE REFERRING TO
THE LOCAL BUREAU HEALTH
PSYCHIATRY PROGRAM? I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE Tð I. I THINK I
COPIED THIS FOR BÀN, BUT IT WAS
JUST COUNTY BASED PSYCHIATRIC
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM. 7
MILLION GENERAL FUND OR AND THEN
7 MILLION FROM AM HÌ S¼  N. M HÌ
S¼ FUND, SO THERE'S OUR
APOLOGIES. THERE'S TWO KIND OF
LIKE NAMES PROGRAMS, SO THERE'S
THE ONE THAT IS BEING REVERTED
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IS THE STATE HOSPITAL SPECIFICS?
THAT'S THE ONE. OK, SO THE STATE
HOSPITAL SPECIFICALLY JUST
KIDDING. THAT'S NOT THE ONE.
IT'S COUNTY BASED. ONE FALSE
ALARM. SO THE OTHER ONE, THE
LOCAL BEAVER HALL SEPARATE FROM
STATE HOSPITAL. SO UM, THE
FUNDING THAT IS BEING DELAYED,
UM, THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THE
█14 MILLION. SO THERE ARE 7
MILLION GENERAL FUND 7 MILLION
HEALTH SERVICES FUND. THAT 7
MILLION IS KIND OF LUMPED IN
WITH THE GENERAL 100 AND 89.4
MILLION THAT WE NOTED, WAS BEING
DELAYED DUE TO AVAILABILITY OF
RESOURCES AT THE TIME OF OUR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ANALYSIS, THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND HAD
LOWER UM, REVENUE PROJECTIONS
THAN WE INITIALLY ANTICIPATED.
SO BASED ON THAT THE DECISION
WAS MADE TO DELAY SEVERAL FOR
HEALTH INITIATIVES, INCLUDING
THIS ONE WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT.
SO THE 7 MILLION, UM, IS A
COMPONENT OF THE 189.4 MILLION.
YES SO TO YOUR POINT, THERE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS, ONE FOR STATE
HOSPITALS AND ONE FOR COUNTIES.
SO THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO
REDUCE SPENDING ON THE ONE FOR
STATE HOSPITALS, BUT IS NOT
PROPOSING ANY CHANGES TO THE ONE
FOR COUNTIES AND THAT THAT IS
THE ONE YOU AND THAT'S THE ONE
MORE TO YOUR POINT. UM IS YOU
KNOW THERE THERE ARE, UM THERE'S
ONE TIME SPENDING IN THE IN THE
DEPARTMENT. UM, SOME OF IT'S
BEEN CARRIED OVER INTO THE
CURRENT YEAR AND HASN'T BEEN
ENCUMBERED YET. SO IN ADDITION
TO LOOKING TO, UM FUNDS THAT ARE
THAT ARE SCHEDULED TO BE
APPROPRIATED IN THE BUDGET YEAR,
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO LOOK
TO PULL BACK. YOU KNOW, SPENDING
THAT'S BEEN CARRIED OVER INTO
THE CURRENT YEAR AND HASN'T YET
BEEN ENCUMBERED THE TRICK. THERE
IS THAT, AS AS TIME GOES ON IN
THE CURRENT YEAR, MORE FUNDS
WILL BE ENCUMBERED. AND SO
THAT'S A BIT OF A MOVING TARGET.
BUT THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER AREA
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO TURN TO
AND MORE TO THE POINT ALSO THAT
THAT SPECIFIC LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR COUNTIES THE ONE
THAT ISN'T BEING AFFECTED BY A
BUDGET SOLUTION, IF OUR
UNDERSTANDING THOSE FUNDS
HAVEN'T BEEN ENCUMBERED YET, SO
THAT WOULD BE AN EXAMPLE. OF A
PROGRAM THAT COULD BE REDUCED IF
THAT WAS OF INTEREST TO THE
LEGISLATURE, AND THAT'S WHY I
NOTED THAT DOWN AND LET'S TIE IN
WITH THIS OTHER QUESTION OF I
FEEL LIKE THIS WAS A TOPIC THAT
CAME UP LAST YEAR, HÌ Kò IS UP
TO THE CHOPPING BLOCK OF FUNDING
TO BE CALLED BACK AS WE HAVEN'T
DISTRIBUTED THE FUNDS WHAT
LESSONS LEARNED? LEARNED HAVE WE
TAKEN BACK AND SAYING HEY FOR
THE UPCOMING YEARS, LET'S
DISTRIBUTE THE MONEY THAT WE
HAVE TO XYZ SO THAT WE'RE NOT AN
OPTION, UH, TO HAVE MONEY BE
CLAWED BACK. LIKE WHAT? WHAT IS
OUR PROCESS IN GETTING THIS
FUNDING OUT AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
. SO WE'RE NOT AN OPTION FOR
CLAWBACKS. YEAH. I MEAN, I WILL
JUST SAY UM, I. I THINK WE'RE
ACTUALLY A MODEL IN TRYING TO
GET FUNDS OUT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. SO WE, YOU KNOW, THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE IS ONE
EXAMPLE. WE HAD THREE 100 PLUS
MILLION FOR THE WELLNESS
COACHES. WE HAD 300 MILLION PLUS
FOR THESE EIGHT DIFFERENT WORK
STREAMS, A NUMBER OF WHICH WERE
NEW FOR US. WE'D NEVER DONE WORK
ON SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH,
SO WE WE'VE GOTTEN VERY
MEANINGFUL DOLLARS OUT VERY
QUICKLY NOW ON LAST YEAR'S
PROPOSAL WHEN THEIR PROPOSED
DELAYS WE DON'T WE HAVE TO HOLD
ON IMPLEMENTATION, BUT GENERALLY
, YOU KNOW, I'M VERY PROUD OF
THE TEAM'S WORK IN GETTING
DOLLARS OUT QUICKLY. WHAT IMPACT
DO WE SEE WITH BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO PAUSE EACH TIME LIKE YOU JUST
MENTIONED RIGHT? SO WE PAUSED
LAST YEAR, AND WE WE'RE PAUSING
AGAINST THE AGAIN THIS YEAR, SO
IT'S APPROXIMATELY CLOSE TO TWO
YEARS OF PAUSING. AND HOW IS
THAT IMPACT IMPACTING THE
APPLICANTS COMING IN, UH, FOR
THESE PROGRAMS OR WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THEM. ARE WE STILL
HAVING SOME APPLICATIONS COME IN
AND OUR MESSAGE. WE HAVE A LOT
OF APPLICATIONS COMING IN, AND
THE TEAM IS DOING A LOT OF
OUTREACH. BUT YES, MADAM CHAIR.
I CERTAINLY TAKE THE POINT THAT
IF THERE'S A PROPOSED DELAY, YOU
KNOW IT WASN'T UNTIL THE BUDGET
SAID WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
THAT WE THEN KIND OF RESTART THE
PROCESS, BUT, UH, YOU KNOW, UH,
MS ABIN SPEAK TO IT. THE TEAM IS
ALWAYS DOING A LOT OF. I THINK
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO
IS AND I'LL LET LIBBY TALK ABOUT
IT, SO TAKE A STRATEGIC APPROACH
AND HAVE PRIORITY SO THAT WE
WE'RE READY TO GO WITH PROGRAMS
WHEN WE HAVE THE FUNDING. YEAH,
SO THERE'S TWO THINGS I CAN
SPEAK TO THERE ON THE STRATEGIC
PLANNING SIDE. WE'RE SORT OF
TAKING ADVANTAGE, I SUPPOSE OF A
LITTLE BIT OF SLOW DOWN WITH THE
DEFERRALS TO GO THROUGH A
STRATEGIC PLANNING PROCESS FOR
BOTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
AND NURSING WORKFORCE, SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH SUPPLY AND
DEMAND MODELING AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE, FOR
EXAMPLE, NEED TO LOOK LIKE IN 10
YEARS. WHAT WILL THE COMPOSITION
OF THAT WORKFORCE BE IN TERMS OF
PROVIDER TYPE RACE, ETHNICITY
AND LANGUAGE? HOW WILL THEY BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHERE THEY NEEDED WORKING
BACKWARDS FROM UNDERSTAND WHERE
OUR GREATEST GAPS IN TERMS OF
TRAINING. WHERE DO WE NEED TO
SUPPORT RETENTION? UM WE ARE
UNDERTAKING THAT PROCESS NOW,
WITH RESULTS EXPECTED BY THE END
OF THE YEAR, SO THAT AS OUR
BUDGET SITUATION CHANGES AND
THERE'S ADDITIONS OR DEFERRALS,
WE HAVE A CRYSTAL CLEAR PICTURE
OF OUR PRIORITIES. AND WE CAN
ALWAYS ANCHOR BACK TO THAT TO
DETERMINE SORT OF WHERE BEST TO
SPEND OUR FUNDS. THE SECOND
PIECE OF WHAT I THINK YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT IS SORT OF LIKE HOW
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THE START?
STOP NATURE AND MAKE SURE THAT
OUR PROGRAMS ARE CONTINUING. WE
USE LOT OF THESE FUNDS TO FUND
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALREADY
EXISTING. AND SO WE CHANNEL THE
FUNDING TO LET'S SAY THE
EXISTING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM WHERE THE
EXISTING LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
AND SO THAT ALLOWS US WHEN THERE
IS A DEFERRAL OF FUNDS OR A
DELAY OF FUNDS TO CON
POTENTIALLY CONTINUE A CYCLE FOR
THAT PROGRAM WITH FUNDING FROM
OTHER SOURCES. SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
WE ARE USING èC YB HÌ CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE FUNDING TO FUND
CYCLES FOR SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THESE
DEFERRALS. SO WE'RE LOOKING HEAD
NEXT YEAR TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN DO THAT. WE MAY HAVE TO
ADJUST SOME OF OUR AWARD AMOUNTS
DOWN AND WE WILL. THE TOTAL
FUNDING, OF COURSE, WILL BE
SMALLER, SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO
MAKE A SMALLER AWARD. BUT THAT'S
HOW WE TRY TO SORT OF KEEP OUR
PROGRAMMING CONTINUING IN A
FLUCTUATING ENVIRONMENT. UM THAT
WAS GONNA BE ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
. BUT LET'S PUT A PIN INTO èC
YB HÌ. I UH, FOR A MOMENT THERE,
UM II. I WANNA KNOW ALSO
REGARDING, UM, THE PROPOSED M
èC Ó WORKFORCE PROGRAM. UM UH,
THAT I THINK IT'S APPROXIMATELY
$75 MILLION. THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF INFORMATION UNDER HÌ Kò OF
WHAT? THAT PROGRAM. WHAT THAT
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT UNDER M èC
Ó IS GONNA LOOK LIKE YOU SHOULD
A LITTLE BIT WHAT MORE YOU CAN
SHARE ON THIS. ARE YOU REFERRING
TO THE LM èC, THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT COLLABORATIVE, BUT
IT'S WORK FOR ONE OF THE SEAS.
BUT YEAH, IT'S FOR WORKFORCE.
RIGHT CORRECT. CORRECT SO, UM, I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT. I THINK IT WAS A
STAKEHOLDER REQUEST OR PROPOSAL
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENTING. BUT, YES, IT IS TO
REALLY LOOKING AT COLLABORATION
BETWEEN SOME OF THE LABOR GROUPS
, UM, TO DEVELOP WORKFORCE, I
THINK FOCUSED ON ALLIED HEALTH
AND WE DO. ALLIED HEALTH IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF OUR AREAS OF
FOCUS. UM, AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING THAT
PROGRAM. FORWARD DO YOU HAVE ANY
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL OR, YOU
KNOW, JUST A LITTLE. THIS IS NEW
FOR US, BUT I'LL JUST ADD A
LITTLE BIT, WHICH IS TO SAY, UM
THE GOAL OF THE INITIATIVE WOULD
BE TO STRENGTHEN AND SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT AND RETENTION OF THE
MEDICAL WORKFORCE THROUGH LABOR
MANAGEMENT. COOPER OPERATION
COMMITTEES, WE WILL ESTABLISH
PROGRAM CRITERIA AND ISSUE
GRANTS, STARTING IN 2025 TO
STRENGTHEN AND SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT AND RETENTION OF THE
MEDICAL WORKFORCE THROUGH LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATIONS, WHICH
CAN DEVELOP AND DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND THE GRANTS. GO TO
THESE COMMITTEES. COMMENTS ON
THIS. YEAH. THIS IS NEW
INFORMATION AND ALSO THE TRAILER
LEGISLATION TO OUR KNOWLEDGE
HASN'T BEEN RELEASED YET. SO
WE'RE STILL WAITING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION BEFORE WE CAN ASSESS
THIS. WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD ACTION ON
THIS UNTIL THAT THAT MORE
INFORMATION IS SORT OF PROVIDED
BUT ALSO EMPHASIZE THAT THE M
èC Ó TAX YOU KNOW IS A IS
ANOTHER SOURCE OF FUNDING. SO IS
THE LEGISLATURE IS WEIGHING ITS
OPTIONS. THAT'S THAT'S ANOTHER,
UH, POTENTIAL PLACE TO TURN TO.
THERE'S LOTS OF CONSIDERATIONS
INVOLVED THERE. THE THERE'S A
THE PROPOSAL INVOLVES MANY OTHER
AREAS OF SPENDING, SO THAT WAS
ALL ALL HAVE TO BE WEIGHED, BUT
THAT JUST WANTED TO EMPHASIZE
THAT POINT. THANK YOU, GENERAL.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
START WITH THIS. I, UM I
UNDERSTAND THE BUDGET ISSUES. UM
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
SEVERE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
OUT YEARS ARE NOT MUCH BETTER
UNDER THE PROJECTIONS, AND IF
THOSE PROJECTIONS ARE ACCURATE,
I DON'T KNOW WHEN WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO A FLIP THE START SWITCH
ON THESE PROGRAMS AGAIN AND
THAT'S CONCERNING TO ME. YOU ALL
KNOW WE HAVE A $6.4 BILLION
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
BOND AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT MEASURE THAT'S BEFORE THE
VOTERS TO OUTSIDE THE PURVIEW OF
THIS. CERTAINLY FOR MY STAFF.
UH, BUT IF THAT HAPPENS TO BE
APPROVED, WE ALSO HAVE POLICY
ISSUES THAT ARE FLOATING AROUND
THE BUILDING HERE ESSENTIAL
POLICY ISSUES, FRANKLY HAVING TO
DO WITH FENTANYL AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT, WHICH, IF
APPROVED. BOTH OF WHICH BOTH THE
BOND ONCE THOSE ARE ISSUED, AND
THE FACILITIES THAT ULTIMATELY
WILL BE CONSTRUCTED AND THE
POLICY PROGRAMS, UH, NEED A
WORKFORCE AND YOU'RE IN THE
BUSINESS, SO I'M I'M NOT. I'M
LECTURING TO THE CHOIR, I GUESS,
BUT UM WE CAN'T FLIP A SWITCH
AND EXPECT THE REQUISITE NUMBER
OF PRACTITIONERS TO POP OUT THE
END OF THE PIPE. I THINK I ASKED
SOMEONE WHAT THE RATIO OF KIDS
TO CHILD PSYCHIATRIST WAS IN IN
INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, AND
I THOUGHT I READ SOMEWHERE. IT
WAS LIKE A HANDFUL TO 600,000
KIDS. YOU PROBABLY KNOW THE
STATISTIC BECAUSE YOU MAINTAIN
THOSE STATISTICS. BUT WHATEVER
IT IS, IT'S UN. IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE, AND IT'S ALMOST
OUTRAGEOUS. AND SO I'M I DON'T
HAVE A QUESTION. I GUESS I HAVE
A COMMENT. I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT PERHAPS
PICKING AND CHOOSING AMONG THESE
INITIATIVES, HOW TO CONTINUE
FUNDING, UH, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS,
GIVEN THE FACT THAT IN MANY
CASES IT TAKES FOUR OR FIVE
YEARS TO GET SOMEONE WITH AN
APPROPRIATE DEGREE, AND THEN IN
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS, IT TAKES
TWO OR 3000 HOURS OF WORK AFTER
THAT, TO SECURE THE NECESSARY
LICENSURE TO MOVE FORWARD TO
BEGIN TO PROVIDE, UM
UNSUPERVISED. CARE AND TREATMENT
OF THOSE WHO NEED IT. UH, I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THIS. I
THINK ONCE THE COMMENT I MADE
EARLIER WAS, I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE A BIG LONG LIST.
OF THESE PROGRAMS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TRIAGE BECAUSE
ONE THING IS FOR SURE. WHILE WE
DON'T DO IT IN ANY OTHER AREA IN
THIS STATE OR VERY MANY OF THEM.
OUR POLICIES ON THE LEFT AND THE
RIGHT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
COORDINATE AND WORK TOGETHER. NÓ
SENSE IN FLOATING BONDS NÓ SENSE
IN ADOPTING FENTANYL TREATMENT,
UH, POLICIES IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND THEN NOT PROVIDING FOR
FUNDING FOR THE WORKFORCE
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
INITIATIVES. NOT SURE. ISSUE AND
NOT YOUR JOB. I JUST IT'S OUR
JOB TO FIGURE IT OUT. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT.
MADAM CHAIR. IF I MAY, SENATOR,
YOU KNOW, I. I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE. AND I JUST WANT TO SAY I
MEAN THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
VERY AWARE OF THE WORKFORCE
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING AND
TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO ADDRESS IT, AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT TAKES TIME TO DEVELOP
WORKFORCES AND I THINK PART OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
DEVELOP NEW WORKFORCE
PROFESSIONS. UM, TO REALLY LOOK
AT THAT LADDER AND SUPPORT
PEOPLE TO GET THROUGH IT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO HAVE THE NUMBER OF
CHILD PSYCHIATRISTS WE NEED.
WE'RE REALLY PROUD THAT WE'RE
FUNDING. UM, PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH
NURSE PRACTITIONERS, AND THEN
WE'VE DEVELOPED THIS NEW
WELLNESS COACH MODEL TO SERVE,
UM YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN SCHOOLS
AND IN IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE SOLUTIONS AND THERE ARE
HARD CHOICES AND BELIEVING I'M
NOT BEING CRITICAL. I THINK OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS STEPPED
UP MORE THAN PROBABLY ANY OTHER
AND PERHAPS IN MODERN HISTORY.
UH, AFTER, UH, RONALD REAGAN, UH
, TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES. I
MEAN, I DIDN'T MENTION THIS. I
KNOW MY CHAIR IS INTERESTED IN
FOSTER KIDS. AND THAT RIVERSIDE
COUNTY TRIES TO RECRUIT 10 TO 15
SOCIAL SERVICE WORKERS TO DEAL
WITH THE EVENTS OF THE RECENT
PAST, AND YOU'RE ALL VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THOSE DOWN THERE
IN INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
YOU TRY TO RECRUIT RECRUIT 10 TO
14 OF THESE AND YOU GET THREE.
AND YET WE READ ABOUT IT ON A
ONE THE CONSEQUENCES OF NOT
HAVING APPROPRIATELY TRAINED AND
SKILLED WORKERS. IN THESE VERY,
VERY CRITICAL, VERY SENSITIVE
ISSUE, DEALING WITH OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION, SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
FIX THIS. NÓ ABSOLUTELY. UM AND
I WANTED TO ECHO SOME OTHER
THINGS. UM YOU KNOW, WE L A
TIMES A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, HAD
INFORMATION ON CARE CORP AND HOW
IT'S YOU KNOW, ROLLING IN L, A
COUNTY AND ALWAYS LIKE L, A
COUNTY A LITTLE SLOWER TO GET
THINGS UP AND RUNNING. UM
BECAUSE WE'RE SO BIG, BUT THE
LACK OF LCSW OR OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH THERAPISTS WHO ARE
APPROVING THESE APPLICATIONS IS
REALLY IMPACTING THE PROCESS. UM
SO I JUST YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHERE
MY QUESTION WAS LIKE, HOW DO WE
PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH ONES WHEN
WE HAVE SOME OF THE DOLLARS THAT
WE SUPPORT. IS IT THE ONE
RETENTION OR IS IT CREATING A
NEW WORKFORCE? AND I CAN IMAGINE
YOU YOU KNOW YOU HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS ALL THE TIME. I'M
JUST SO MANY BIG PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW, AND I JUST
THINK ABOUT CARE AND CAL A AS
ONE OF THE BIG ONES AND THEN
WITH PROP ONE. I KNOW WE'RE
TAKING AWAY A LOT OF MONEY FROM
SERVICES. GREAT FOR HOUSING, BUT
THE SERVICES PART IS GONNA HURT
A LITTLE BIT. SO HOW CAN WE
MAINTAIN THESE PROGRAMS? WE CAN
BUILD EVERYTHING, BUT IT'S NOT
LIKE THE MOVIE IS JUST BECAUSE
YOU BUILD IT. THEY WON'T COME.
YOU NEED THE PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY
WORK THEM. THEY CAN COME. SO YOU
KNOW, THIS IS GONNA BE TOP OF
MIND FOR A LOT OF US AS WE
CONTINUE AND SEE. THIS 75
MILLION FOR SALE TAX. IS IT
REALLY GONNA HELP CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE PEOPLE TO
COME IN? UM WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
, IS IT A POLITICAL PLANE OR IS
ARE WE REALLY UTILIZING THIS M
èC Ó MONEY TO INVEST AND FOR
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS, 10 YEARS
THAT I'M HERE WE CAN SAY HEY,
THE INVESTMENT OF 75 MILLION
REALLY WORKED. WE HAVE X AMOUNT
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTHCARE
WORKERS SO FORTH. UM AND THEN
QUICKLY BEFORE WE MOVE ON èC YB
HÌ I DID I DO THE ACRONYM, RIGHT
BOY? UM, TWO THINGS ONE I'D LIKE
FOR YOU, LIBBY. IF YOU COULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE. YOU SAID
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT BECAUSE I
BROUGHT THIS UP. I THINK IN THE
FIRST OVERALL BUDGET HEARING, WE
HAVE SOME MONEY. CAN WE USE SOME
OF THAT FUNDS TO COVER SOME OF
THE DELAYS OR CUTS AND TWO MAYBE
Dð Ó FL A Ó? HOW MUCH MONEY DO
WE HAVE LEFT? AND èC YB HÌ. I
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION, AND I
DON'T HAVE THE PRECISE NUMBER
FOR YOU. BUT I CAN CONFIRM THAT
WE'RE USING èC YB HÌ I FUNDS TO
FUND SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED SO FAR, EXAMPLE,
UM, SOCIAL WORK, EDUCATION
CAPACITY EXPANSION. THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE THAT AWARDS
FUNDING TO TRAINING INSTITUTIONS
TO SUPPORT EXISTING OR EXPANDING
SLOTS FOR SOCIAL WORK EDUCATION.
HOW TO CREATE MORE SOCIAL
WORKERS AS YOU'VE JUST
DESCRIBED. THERE IS A GREAT NEED
FOR, UM, WITH THESE DEFERRALS WE
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN? LIKE? WHAT
DOES WHAT IS THAT PROGRAM MEAN?
SO WE'LL GIVE FUNDING TO AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION THAT
RUNS A SOCIAL WORK PROGRAM.
LET'S SAY FOR MASTERS MASTERS IN
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAM TO ADD SLOTS
TO THEIR PROGRAM SO THAT THEY
CAN TRAIN MORE SOCIAL WORKERS,
SO JUST LIKE THE PROPOSED TO LAY
OF THE SOCIAL WORK SLOTS, RIGHT
IT, COULD IT RIP IT, UM AUDIENCE
AGREES IT REPLACES THAT. SO IT
THERE'S ONE PROGRAM AND THIS IS
SORT OF WHAT WE WERE REFERRING
TO. EARLIER WE USE DIFFERENT
POTS OF FUNDING TO FUND THAT
PROGRAM. BUT WE'VE BEEN RUNNING
THAT PROGRAM FOR A COUPLE OF
CYCLES. THAT PROGRAM IS IMPACTED
BY THE DEFERRALS UNDER THE
SOCIAL WORK INITIATIVE, AND WE
WILL BE USING èC YB HÌ I
FUNDING TO CONTINUE NEXT YEAR'S
CYCLE. OK, SO THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF PROGRAMS AND I CAN GET BACK
TO YOU WITH THE SPECIFICS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE IT ALL
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD HELPFUL.
WE'RE USING èC YB HÌ FUNDING TO
KIND OF KEEP THINGS MOVING
FORWARD. IN THAT TIME WAS THAT
ENOUGH TIME TO SEE HOW MUCH
MONEY WE HAVE LEFT? UH JOSEPH Dð
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UH WHAT
OUR APOLOGIES. WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE NUMBERS REALLY AVAILABLE
ON US, BUT WE CAN DEFINITELY,
UM, CIRCLE BACK AND GIVE YOU
THOSE NUMBERS. I'D BE REALLY
INTERESTED IN THAT. WHEN YOU'RE
FINISHED, I JUST WANNA FOLLOW UP
ON YOU KNOW ONE OF THE ISSUES AS
I UNDERSTAND IT IN THE SOCIAL
WORK HERE, MM S¼. IT'S NOT ONLY
THE SLOTS IN THE SCHOOLS, BUT
THE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AND WHAT
THEY WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD BY
THOSE WHO RUN THESE SCHOOLS, AT
LEAST, DEPENDING I GUESS ON
WHERE YOU ARE IN THE STATE IS
THAT THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS BECAUSE
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
AGREE TO MENTOR THOSE FOR THE
REQUISITE NUMBER OF UNBELIEVABLY
LONG HOURS THAT THE. THE SOCIAL
WORK GRADUATES HAVE TO, UH, HAVE
TO COMPLETE IN ORDER TO OBTAIN
LICENSURE. UM, I ASSUME THERE'S
NÓ PROGRAM TO ASSIST IN PAYING.
IS THERE A PROGRAM TO ASSIST IN
PAYING THESE MENTORS OR WHATEVER
WE CALL THEM PROCTORS SUPERVISOR
SUPERVISOR. GREAT QUESTION, SO
THAT IS SOMETHING WE WERE HOPING
TO STAND UP WITH THE 70.1
MILLION THAT'S DELAYED UNDER
SOCIAL WORK. WE HAD A PROGRAM IN
MIND, UM FOR SOCIAL WORK,
CLINICAL SUPERVISION. WE WILL BE
ABLE TO STAND THAT UP WHEN THE
FUNDS ARE RESTORED. WELL, WE
BETTER PUT THAT ON OUR LIST TO
TRIAGE BECAUSE I MEAN, THAT'S A
REAL PROBLEM. NOW LET ALONE WHEN
WE START EXPANDING THESE
PROGRAMS, SO I ALSO WANTED
SENATOR ROTH. WE DID RE
INSTITUTE. THE SOCIAL WORK, UM,
STIPENDS AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED
TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE THESE THREE 1000 HOURS,
YOU KNOW, PRE WITHOUT A STIPEND.
FOLKS ARE WORKING, UM WITHOUT
PAY, WHICH IS ANOTHER BARRIER,
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO HAVE A JOB
SO VERY HAPPY TO HAVE THAT BEEN
ABLE TO REINSTITUTE THE STIPEND
PROGRAM. ROSS EYE ON THAT TOO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. JASON AND JOANNA. ADD
SOMETHING TO THAT. YOU KNOW, I,
UM WE'LL GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I. I HAVE SOME DATA
ON THE èC YB HÌ I, BUT I MIGHT
MIGHT BE BETTER TO, UM, ANSWER
THAT WITHOUT DOING THE MENTAL
MATH ON THE SPOT TOTALLY WORKS.
UM I THINK WE'VE COVERED
EVERYTHING. AND I WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'VE ADDRESSED YOUR, UH,
DATA QUESTIONS. SENATOR ROTH AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY WE YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE STOOD UP A WORKFORCE
RESEARCH DATA CENTER. WE'RE
GETTING TERRIFIC DATA FROM ALL
THE LICENSING BOARDS AND WE OWE
THE LEGISLATURE A REPORT THAT
WE'LL BE GETTING TO IN THE NEXT
MONTH. UM, SHOWING THE DATA, BUT
IT ETHNICITY DATA HAS GEOGRAPHIC
MALDISTRIBUTION. UM SO NÓ. I
DON'T KNOW THAT. THAT THAT THAT,
UH, RATIO THAT YOU WERE ASKING
BEFORE, BUT WE HAVE SOME OF THAT
DATA THAT CAN HELP ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS. WELL, I JUST WANT TO
BE VERY, VERY CLEAR IN SAYING I
THANK YOU BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT ANY TIME WE HAVE AN ISSUE,
AND I'M GUILTY OF THIS, TOO. WE
TURN TO KI AND JUST ASK YOU TO
FIX IT FOR US. SO THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU DO. THANK YOU, OLIVIA.
I WAS GONNA ASK. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY. I THINK
IT WAS LAST WEEK. THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MENTAL HEALTH. THE
LONG TITLE HAD A HEARING. UH ON,
UM, WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
YOU WHERE THE GAPS ARE ON
DEMOGRAPHICS RACE AND THEY SPOKE
ON THAT, AS YOU MENTIONED. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD A CHANCE,
BUT IT WAS REALLY GOOD. AND YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE SAME AS ALWAYS,
RIGHT. NOT ENOUGH BILINGUAL,
LATIN AND SO FORTH. AND
LANDSBERG AND I WERE ON THE
PANEL. OH, GREAT. I WAS I WAS
WATCHING THE Tð VÆ. I COULDN'T
GO THERE. SO I MEAN, I MISSED
Y'ALL PART. ALL RIGHT. WE
LEVERAGE SOME OF THE AMAZING
DATA THAT THE DIRECTOR LANDSBERG
JUST USED TO DESCRIBE WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND CHALLENGES WITH
CONCORDANCE AND WHERE WE'RE
HEADING. THANK YOU. OK, SO WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THIS UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON HK ANYONE HAS A
PUBLIC COMMENT ON SECTIONS ONE
THROUGH FOUR. WE ARE HOLDING
EACH. UM WE'RE HOLDING ISSUES TO
THREE AND FOUR OPEN BUT WELCOME
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT TO ONE
MINUTE, PLEASE. HØI DIANA
DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA ON ISSUE ONE HEALTH
ACCESS STRONGLY ADVOCATED FOR
THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AND
HAS REMAINED VERY ACTIVE IN
IMPLEMENTATION TO ENSURE THE
OFFICE LIVES UP TO ITS VISION TO
TRULY BRING COSTS DOWN AND
IMPORTANTLY, INCREASE ACCESS TO
CARE. THE AFFORDABILITY TARGETS
ARE A CORNERSTONE TO THE OFFICE
AND HEALTH ACCESS SUPPORT
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED 3% TARGET
AND THE PROPOSED METHODOLOGY,
TYING THEM TO HOUSEHOLD INCOMES,
SO AT LEAST HEALTH COSTS DON'T
FURTHER GROW MORE UNAFFORDABLE
FOR CALIFORNIAN FAMILIES. NEXT
ISSUE. CALOR X AGAIN. HEALTH IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS PROGRAM,
INCLUDING THE ADDITION OF
NALOXONE, AND WE APPRECIATE THE
UPDATES TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THE PROGRAM COME TO
FRUITION, UM AND FURTHER EXPAND
AS AN INNOVATIVE WAY TO KEEP
COSTS DOWN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, ANDREA RIVERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK. èC P
APPRECIATES THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT BY THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE THAT VITAL HEALTH SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS REMAIN IN PLACE
DESPITE THE CURRENT FISCAL
UNCERTAINTY THAT SAID, WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER PROMOTORA AND
HEALTH REPRESENTATIVE WORKFORCE
DOLLARS REMAIN INTACT. UH
HOWEVER, WE WOULD URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO USE PREVIOUSLY
ALLOCATED UNUSED, UNSPENT
DOLLARS UNDER HÌ Kò THAT ARE
CONNECTED TO THE MEDICAL
BENEFIT. TO INCREASE RATE
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS, PROMOTORS AND
HEALTH REPRESENTATIVES. èC HÌ W
PR S¼ ARE MOSTLY WOMEN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT
DELIVER CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
SERVICES. AND MUCH OF CALAIS
RELIES ON CW'S CW PR S¼ TO CARRY
OUT THE EVOLUTION OF OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. UH,
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
YOU ON THIS ISSUE AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT, UM YOU
SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT. ABOUT OUR WORK ON
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS? YEAH,
AND THE MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENTS
AND YOU AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE WAS A ROLE THERE. YEAH WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY. SO UH, MEDI CAL
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
GETTING FEDERAL APPROVAL TO HAVE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS BE A
MEDIC REIMBURSABLE ITEM, AND
THEN WE'VE GONE THROUGH A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO DEVELOP A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM AND DID A
BIT OF A RESTART ON THAT, TO
REALLY MAKE SURE WE WERE HEARING
FROM THE COMMUNITY AND SO WHERE
THAT IS IN PROGRESS CURRENTLY,
SO YOUR ROLE IS JUST THE, UM THE
AND ENSURING THAT THOSE DOLLARS
WILL. SO SO I UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
SO THE DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE ARE
ARE TO SUPPORT THE TRAINING OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS FOR A
TORRES AND ALSO EMPLOYER GRANTS,
WHICH WE ARE DOING IN
COLLABORATION WITH WITH
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE CARE SERVICES
WERE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO THAT
TEAM BASED CARE AND IT TAKES
SOME DELIVERY SYSTEM CHANGE TO,
UH HAVE DOCTORS AND NURSES KNOW
HOW TO EFFECTIVELY PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS, SO WE
WILL BE PROVIDING STIPENDS,
TRAINING GRANTS AND EMPLOYER
GRANTS, UM FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER PER TORE AND REPRESENT
YES, THANK YOU. JASON, I YOU
HAVE SOMETHING YOU'RE GOOD. YOU
KNOW, AS LONG AS I WAS CLEAR OF
THE YEAH, I GOT IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OK, NEXT ONE COMMENT. JOSH
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS IN THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT DELAYING
INVESTMENTS IN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WORKFORCE. PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS ARE
STRUGGLING TO RETAIN WORKERS AND
FILL POSITIONS ACROSS THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. STATE LEVEL
INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE WORKFORCE CRISIS. IN
PARTICULAR, THOSE PROPOSED
DELAYS WOULD IMPACT NURSING
SOCIAL WORK AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE PROGRAMS, THE
PROFESSIONS WHERE PUBLIC
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS IN URBAN
COUNTIES EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE
GREATEST STAFFING SHORTAGE.
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR AND THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT. WE
HOPE THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN THE
HEALTH WORKFORCE. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M SANDRA POOL
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND I STAND TO LINE UM,
AND SUPPORT THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT èC P RELATED TO
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS, AND I'LL KEEP IT
SHORT TO SEE UM COVERED IT
PRETTY WELL. THANK YOU. OH,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. CHAIR SENATOR
TONY TREGEAR, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
ALWAYS HAPPY TO BE IN THIS
COMMITTEE WHERE EDUCATION AND
HEALTH MEET AT THE SCHOOL SITE.
WE'RE SPEAKING TO THE HÌ Kò
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ON PAGES 4041
TARGETED AT FOR REVISION OR
DELAY. THEY INCLUDE THE
COMPREHENSIVE NURSING INITIATIVE
, SOCIAL WORKER INITIATIVE AND
THE EXPANDED MASTERS IN SOCIAL
WORK WE'D LIKE TO LEGISLATURE TO
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER EXTENDING THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THESE PROGRAMS,
THE CANDIDATES WHO ARE SEEKING
CREDENTIALS AS SCHOOL NURSES.
COUNCILORS PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS. THEY ARE
CURRENTLY NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
WORKFORCE FUNDING AND, UH WE
BELIEVE THIS WAS A SERIOUS
OVERSIGHT. THIS IS A CRITICAL.
GIVEN THE WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN
SCHOOLS IN OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
STUDENTS' ABILITY. TO ENGAGE IN
LEARNING IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
WHETHER THEIR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS
ARE BEING MET STUDENTS WHO NEED
INDIVIDUALIZED AND ONGOING
COUNSELING RECEIVED THOSE
SERVICES. AND THE SCHOOL CAMPUS
IN A WAY THAT MINIMIZES LOST
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME AND MAXIMIZE
THE BENEFITS IN WHICH A
CREDENTIAL PROFESSIONAL CAN
EVALUATE AND ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. UM WE JUST HOPE THAT IN
THE OUT YEARS OF THE FUNDING
SURVIVES IN THIS CATEGORY AND
THAT WE CAN EXPAND THE
ELIGIBILITY TO INCLUDE THAT
CATEGORY OF EMPLOYEES. THEIR
LICENSED ALL THEY NEED IS A YEAR
TO GET THEIR CREDENTIAL AND THEY
COULD BE EMPLOYED FOR AT SCHOOL
SITES, SO WE THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ACTIVITY TO LOOK INTO
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. OH, HELLO,
EVERYBODY. RICHARDSON DAVIS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES ALSO REPRESENTING, UM
THE èC A èC. THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS COALITION. UM èC B HÌ, A
REPRESENTING MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER, CLINICS
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
CLINICS ACROSS THE STATE. SO I
THOUGHT YOU SAID WHAT,
EVERYBODY, EVERYBODY. YEAH,
YEAH. UM BUT ALSO JUST WANTED TO
SPEAK. UM UM IN SUPPORT AND IN
FAVOR OF, UM, A COUPLE OF ISSUES
THAT WE ARE AN ISSUE TWO AND
THREE. I WANNA APPLAUD THE WORK
BEING DONE BY, UH HÌ Kò ON
CULTURAL ON THE CULTURAL
DIVERSITY INSIDE OF THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. I KNOW
THAT BUILDING A WORKFORCE IS
IMPORTANT. A LOT OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP HAS STRUGGLED WITH
WORKFORCE AS OF THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS WITH COVID AND
EVERYTHING. UM AND SO AS WE
BUILD IT, WE, UH, HEARING ABOUT
THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE COMING UP
TO BUILD A STRONGER, MORE
DIVERSE WORKFORCE. UH, WE
SUPPORT THAT AND WE'RE EXCITED
TO HEAR ABOUT IT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE SEE, UM
ELIMINATING BARRIERS FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICATION RELATED TO THE, UM TO
THE, UM CAL RX ADJUSTMENT. I
JUST WANTED TO THROW OUR SUPPORT
OUT THERE AND SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BY
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HAVE A GOOD ONE. YOU TOO.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS.
BETH MALKI OF S¼ èC. IU
CALIFORNIA I WANNA START BY
SECONDING THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT HEALTH ACCESS
REGARDING THE STANDING UP OF THE
OFFICE. HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY, TREMENDOUS WORK
BY THE DEPARTMENT AND CONTINUE
THE SUPPORT FROM THIS COMMITTEE
HAS HAD IN THAT AREA, UM, IN THE
AREA OF HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
JUST WANNA ACTUALLY APPRECIATE
REALLY ROBUST DIALOG AND DEBATE
YOU'VE HAD HERE TODAY. WE KNOW
IT'S A DIFFICULT YEAR. DIFFICULT
DECISIONS HAVE TO BE MADE, BUT
REALLY HOPE WE CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
ACHIEVE THESE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ACCESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBER SARA FOX,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. I
JUST WANTED TO COMMEND THE WORK
OF HÌ Kò AND STANDING UP THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY THEIR WORK ON
FINDING OUT OUR TOTAL HEALTH
CARE, SPENDING AND TRANSPARENCY
AND WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR A 3% TARGET
ON SPENDING TO REDUCE HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE MOVING ON TO OUR
LAST PORTION OF OUR HEARING.
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE, ALSO KNOWN AS COVERED
CALIFORNIA LIKE TO WELCOME THE
ADMINISTRATION TO KICK US OFF
WITH AN OVERVIEW AND OPEN
ENROLLMENT UPDATE. AND THEN
WE'LL GO INTO ISSUES TWO THROUGH
THREE. COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN WE CAN KICK OFF
WITH THE ISSUE ONE GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR ROTH, KATIE RAVEL. I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
ELIGIBILITY AND RESEARCH AT
COVER CALIFORNIA AND I'M HAPPY
TO BE WITH YOU TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW. AND THEN ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT ENROLLMENT
TRENDS IN OUR HEALTH CARE FOR
STRIKING WORKERS PROGRAM. UM SO
COVER CALIFORNIA. IS A PRODUCT
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. IT
WAS PASSED IN 2020, IT
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED THE
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKET, AND THAT'S WELL
SUMMARIZED IN YOUR AGENDA FOR
TODAY. A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WAS THE
CREATION OF HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGES THAT OFFER
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH PLANS, WITH
INCOME BASED FINANCIAL HELP TO
LOWER PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET
COSTS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T
HAVE AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
THROUGH THEIR EMPLOYER, MEDICAID
OR MEDICARE. OUR MISSION AT
COVER CALIFORNIA IS TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF INSURED
CALIFORNIANS IMPROVE HEALTH CARE
QUALITY, LOWER COSTS AND REDUCE
HEALTH DISPARITIES THROUGH AN
INNOVATIVE COMPETITIVE
MARKETPLACE THAT EMPOWERS
CONSUMERS TO CHOOSE THE HEALTH
PLANS AND PROVIDERS THAT GIVE
THEM THE BEST. COVERED
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTS WITH 12
INSURANCE CARRIERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND OUR MEMBERS CHOOSE
FROM SEVERAL COVERAGE OPTIONS
THAT VARY IN THE AMOUNT OF
PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET
COSTS. THEY HAVE OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS, STATE AND FEDERAL
ACTION HAS BUILT ON THE
FOUNDATION OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT TO PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT
FOR OUR ENROLLEES TO AFFORD
THEIR COVERAGE. FEDERAL ACTION
INCLUDES ENHANCED PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES, WHICH WERE AUTHORIZED
THROUGH THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
AND THEN EXTENDED THROUGH 2025
BY THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT
OF 2022. CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN
SEVERAL EXCITING ACTIONS ON
AFFORDABILITY, WHICH INCLUDE
IMPLEMENTING IN 2020, THE NATION
LEADING CALIFORNIA PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH
MIDDLE INCOME CALIFORNIANS WERE
ABLE TO ACCESS PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OUR MARKETPLACE. IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA PREMIUM CREDIT
PROGRAM, WHICH ENABLED COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO OFFER PLANS WITH
$0 MONTHLY PREMIUM AND MORE
RECENTLY IMPLEMENTATION OF
SUBSIDIES TO REDUCE OUT OF
POCKET COSTS AND HEALTH CARE FOR
STRIKING WORKERS. THE BUDGET ACT
OF 2023 AUTHORIZED COVER
CALIFORNIA TO SPEND $82.5
MILLION TO LOWER OUT OF POCKET
COSTS FOR COVER CALIFORNIA
ENROLLEES. WE CALL THIS THE
CALIFORNIA COST SHARING
REDUCTION PROGRAM. UH, FOR 2024
BENEFIT YEAR. WE USE THE FUNDING
TO ELIMINATE DEDUCTIBLES AND
LOWER COSTS FOR KEY SERVICES
LIKE PRIMARY CARE AND OUTPATIENT
MENTAL HEALTH VISITS AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS FOR OUR
LOWEST INCOME ENROLLEES. WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROGRAM COVER, CALIFORNIA WAS
ABLE TO OFFER THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE IN
OUR 10. YOUR HISTORY. SO LET ME
TURN TO A QUESTION TWO AND WE'LL
SEE HOW THIS TRANSLATED INTO
ENROLLMENT IN OUR LATEST OPEN
ENROLLMENT PERIOD. UM AS OF
JANUARY, 31ST WHEN OUR OPEN
ENROLLMENT CLOSED OVER 1.78
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAD
SELECTED COVERED CALIFORNIA
PLANS FOR 2024 NEW SIGN UPS
INCREASED BY 16% RELATIVE TO
2023 EXCEEDING 306,000 NEW PLANT
SELECTIONS. THIS IS OUR HIGHEST
LEVEL OF ENROLLMENT DURING OPEN
ENROLLMENT SINCE 2020. THEN THIS
WE DID OFFER THROUGH A SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT A COUPLE OF EXTRA
DAYS FOR PEOPLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR OPEN ENROLLMENT ACTIVITY.
AND ONCE WE TALLIED ALL OF THAT
WE'RE CLOSE TO 1.8 MILLION
ENROLLEES SIGNED UP FOR 2024.
THANKS IN LARGE PART TO THE NEW
STATE FUNDING TO LOWER OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR OUR LOWEST
INCOME ENROLLEES. UH, IN OUR
SILVER HEALTH PLANS, WE DID SEE
A GREATER SHARE OF OUR ENROLLEES
. CHOOSING THOSE PLANS SO AMONG
CONSUMERS WITH INCOME UNDER 250%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE NEW STATE
PROGRAM, AS OF 2024, THE
ENROLLMENT IN OUR ENHANCED
SILVER PLANS JUMPED FROM 70% IN
2020 THREE TO 82% IN 2024. IT'S
A BIG JUMP FOR US, UM
PARTICULARLY ENROLLMENT IN OUR
GOLD PLANS DROPPED FOR THIS
POPULATION BY MORE THAN HALF.
UM, THIS IS ENCOURAGING TO SEE,
UM IT'S A LITTLE
COUNTERINTUITIVE TO SAY WELL,
SILVER ENROLLMENT IS BETTER THAN
GOLD. BUT IN THIS CASE, UM THOSE
PLANS THOSE SILVER PLANS OFFER
LOWER PREMIUMS AND MORE COST
SHARING SUPPORT. SO YOU'RE GONNA
PAY THE LOWEST PRICE FOR THE
HIGHEST VALUE, SO WE'RE VERY
ENCOURAGED TO SEE THAT UM,
TURNING TO QUESTION THREE AND
ITEM ONE COVER. CALIFORNIA IS
NOW WORKING ON THE DESIGN OF THE
2025 COST SHARING REDUCTION
PROGRAM. THE GOVERNOR'S FISCAL
YEAR 2425 BUDGET INCLUDES AN
APPROPRIATION OF 165 MILLION SO
ROUGHLY DOUBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
WITH THAT HIGHER FUNDING LEVEL,
THE 2025 PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE
SUPPORT FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE, AND WE
EXPECT TO EXPAND ELIGIBILITY
ABOVE THE CURRENT INCOME CAP OF
250% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. UM, WE'RE MODELING COSTS
AND POTENTIAL ENROLLMENT, AND
WE'LL HAVE A DRAFT DESIGN OF
THAT 2025 PROGRAM IN APRIL. I'M
HAPPY TO PAUSE HERE FOR
QUESTIONS OR MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TWO. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS NOTHING
FURTHER, DAD. BRIAN MILLER Ó
NOTHING TO ADD AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. SO JUST
FOR RIGHT NOW ON THAT THIRD, UH,
PORTION, UM MORE INFORMATION
WILL COME IN APRIL. BUT FOR
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE LOOKING TO
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY ABOVE 250. WE
ARE YES. RIGHT? YOU KNOW? JUST
ONE QUESTION, I. I THINK I NOTED
THAT OUR PUBLIC UM MEDICAL
PROVIDER IE HÌ P. IE HÌ P DOWN
IN INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS
, UH, PARTICIPATING IN THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. IT'S
PROBABLY TOO EARLY TO HAVE ANY
DATA ON THAT AND I ASSUME THE
PURPOSE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
TRY TO CAPTURE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DROPPING OUT OF THE MEDICAL
POPULATION DUE TO INCOME. AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY TRANSITION
INTO COMMERCIAL HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. WE WERE VERY EXCITED
TO ADD INLAND EMPIRE HEALTH PLAN
, AND THEY ARE THE UM LOWEST
COST PLAN IN THAT REGION, SO
THEY ARE THE RECIPIENT OF AUTO
ENROLLMENT. AS PEOPLE LOSE ME IN
THE REGION, THEY ARE
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLLED INTO IE
HÌ P, WHICH, AS YOU MENTIONED
INCREASES THEIR CONTINUITY OF
CARE AS THEY MAKE THAT
TRANSITION FROM THE MEDIC
PROGRAM TO COVER CALIFORNIA. SO
WE WERE VERY EXCITED TO GET THAT
STARTED THIS YEAR, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING A REPORT ON
THE DATA AND SUCCESSFUL IT IS SO
THANK YOU FOR FACILITATING THAT
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
TWO QUESTIONS, AND I APOLOGIZE
IF I MISS THIS, UM WITH MEDICARE
, RED DETERMINATION AND KIND OF
TALKING ABOUT THAT AND HOW
PEOPLE FELL OFF AND BECAUSE THEY
WERE ELIGIBLE, HAVE WE? WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE RIGHT OF LIVES
UNDERCOVER CALIFORNIA AND DO WE
ATTRIBUTE THAT SOLELY TO THE
MEDICARE RED DETERMINATION
COMING BACK OR OTHER FACTORS?
UM, IT IS A PORTION OF IT ABOUT
30,000 OF OUR ENROLLEES DURING
OPEN ENROLLMENT WERE ACTUALLY
THOSE TRANSITIONERS FROM ME. UM,
AT THIS POINT POINT IN THE
TRANSITION WE'RE SEEING MAYBE
15,000 TRANSITIONERS PER MONTH
EFFECTUATING COVERAGE WITH
COVERED CALIFORNIA. UM THE S¼ B
260 PROGRAM THAT WAS AUTHORIZED
AND A BILL TO, UH 260 FROM 2019
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL.
IT GIVES US THAT AUTHORITY TO
PROVIDE TO AUTOMATICALLY SELECT
A PLAN FOR INDIVIDUALS. UM,
WHICH WE'RE FINDING REALLY EARLY
SUCCESS WITH, UM, WE TURNED ON
THE PROGRAM WHEN, UH, WHEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ENDED IN
ME, RED DETERMINATIONS STARTED.
OVER THE SUMMER. UM AND WE ARE
SEEING GOOD TAKE UP IN THE
PROGRAM. UM AND PEOPLE KEEPING
THAT PLAN AND REALLY FINDING
THAT PLAN ASSIGNMENT VERY
HELPFUL TO THEM IN MAKING THE
COVERAGE TRANSITION AND FOR THE
PLAN GOING MOVING FORWARD WITH
DOUBLING THE SUBSIDIES DO WE
KNOW HOW OF THE POTENTIAL OF HOW
MANY THE PERCENTAGE OF LIVES WE
CAN IMPACT? THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON NOW. WITH THE PROGRAM
THAT'S LIMITED TO 250% FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR ABOUT 650,000 OF
OUR EXISTING MEMBERS WERE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
150,000. SO TH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE ALREADY ENROLLED WITH US
AUTOMATICALLY GET THE NEW
SUBSIDIES. UM AND THEN ABOUT
HALF OF OUR NEW ENROLLEES, UM,
QUALIFY FOR THE NEW SUBSIDIES AS
WELL. AMAZING AND WE DO HOPE FOR
A SIGNIFICANT ELIGIBILITY
EXPANSION, JUST DEPENDING ON THE
FINAL NUMBERS, OK, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WHAT IS YOUR CURRENT?
IS OUR FUND LOOK LIKE THAT POT.
IN TERMS OF THE COST SHARING
ASSISTANCE. WHAT IS THE PHONE
CALLED OR TALKING ABOUT? HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND?
UM I APOLOGIZE. I DON'T HAVE IT
RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME. I BELIEVE,
UM, FOR BUDGET YEAR THERE IS A
RESERVE OF AN I APOLOGIZE. I
THIS IS KIND OF OFF THE CUFF WE
CAN GET BACK TO. I BELIEVE IT'S
IN THE REALM OF ABOUT 100
MILLION TO THE RESCUE. YES. ONE
SECOND. SORRY. YEAH, SO FOR AT
THE END OF OUR CURRENT YEAR,
THERE'LL BE, UH, A FUND BALANCE
OF ABOUT 19 MILLION AND THEN AT
THE END OF BUDGET YEAR, IT WOULD
BE ABOUT 100 AND 24 MILLION. OK
AND DO WE SEE A DECREASE IN
INCREASE? UH, GOING EACH YEAR
INTO THIS FUND? IN PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. UM KIND OF
UPDATE YOU. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE OBVIOUSLY, WITH
THIS FUNDERS BASED ON THE
AGREEMENT AND THE BUDGET ACT
2020 SORRY. 2023 THE REVENUES
FROM THE PENALTY. WE'RE NOW
SHIFT FROM GENERAL FUND TO THE
PENALTY. WE DID SEE THIS YEAR
THAT WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
DECREASES IN WHAT THOSE REVENUES
ARE, UM, TO KIND OF
CONTEXTUALIZE. WHAT THAT
DECREASE REPRESENTS AS WELL.
IT'S CON THAT THERE IS LESS
MONEY COMING INTO THE FUND. IT
ALSO REPRESENTS THAT MORE PEOPLE
ARE GETTING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
. SO DEPENDING ON HOW YOU WANNA
LOOK AT IT, IT'S BOTH GOOD AND
BAD NEWS. UM SO JUST TO KIND OF
CONTEXTUALIZE WHERE WE THOUGHT
REVENUES WERE COMING FROM THE
PENALTY ARE ACTUALLY DECREASING.
UM AND ALSO NOTING THAT WITH
THIS FUND, THERE'S OBVIOUSLY,
UM, THERE IN AS PART OF THE
BUDGET ACT LAST YEAR THAT THERE
WAS PROPOSED LOAN TO THE GENERAL
FUND OF 600 MILLION THAT WOULD
BE REPAID IN 25. 26 SO THERE'S
KIND OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT
MOVING PIECES WITH THIS FUN
WHETHER IT'S THE REVENUE FROM
THE PENALTY. WE HAVE THE ONGOING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE COST
SHARING PROGRAM AND THEN THE
FUTURE REPAYMENT OF THE GENERAL
FUND LOAN. SO UM, HOPEFULLY THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. LEÓN
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THAT. UH,
NÓ NÓ. I DON'T THINK SO. NÓ NOT
AT THIS TIME. OK GREAT. GENERAL
R. OK UM, THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
GREAT. I'LL ADDRESS QUESTION ONE
IN YOUR AGENDA AND THEN TURN TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
QUESTION. TWO THE HEALTH CARE
FOR STRIKING WORKERS PROGRAM
AUTHORIZED UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL
2530 PROVIDES SPECIAL STATE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO LOSE EMPLOYER
COVERAGE AS A RESULT OF A LABOR
DISPUTE, SUCH AS A STRIKE.
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
FEDERAL PREMIUM ASSISTANCE BASED
ON THEIR ESTIMATED INCOME FOR
THE YEAR DUE TO THE STRUCTURE OF
OUR FEDERAL PREMIUM ASSISTANCE,
IT MAY PAY MOST OF THE COST OF
THE MONTHLY PREMIUM FOR THESE
ENROLLEES. BUT THE STATE PROGRAM
THEN FURTHER REDUCES PREMIUMS
AND OUT OF POCKET COSTS TO
ENABLE ENROLLEES TO RECEIVE THE
MOST GENEROUS LEVEL OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE OFFER. THE
2023 BUDGET ACT PROVIDED FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM AND WE SIGNED UP
OUR FIRST ENROLLEES IN JULY OF
2020 THREE. THE STRIKE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM PROVIDED ABOUT 166
MONTHS OF HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
ON BEHALF OF 75 INDIVIDUALS
BETWEEN JULY AND DECEMBER OF
2023. THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE
ENROLLED FOR AN AVERAGE OF A
LITTLE MORE THAN TWO MONTHS AND
THE STRIKE SUBSIDY PAYMENTS
DURING THAT TIME. NET OF THE
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES WERE ABOUT
$39,000. THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM
THAT IS SUBJECT TO AN
APPROPRIATION AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA WAS APPROPRIATED. $2
MILLION AND OF THAT, AS SHE
NOTED, HAS SPENT APPROXIMATELY
40,000 AND SO THE NOTING THAT
STATE FUNDS ARE TYPICALLY
APPROPRIATED THROUGH THE BUDGET
ACT TO ENABLE ANNUAL PROGRAM
REVIEW AND IT MAY BE PREMATURE
TO CONSIDER INCREASING THIS
PROGRAM AT THIS TIME. II. I
THINK WE WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT, UM BOTH THE PROGRAM
DISCUSSED IN THIS ITEM AND IN
THE PRIOR ITEM ARE BOTH FUNDED
FROM THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AFFORDABILITY
RESERVE FUND AND SO TO SOME
DEGREE, THEY WOULD BE COMPETING
FOR THE SAME REVENUES FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU KNOW, THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO PRIORITIZE
THIS, IT WOULD BE COMING FROM,
YOU KNOW THE PRIOR ITEM. ALL
THAT SAID, YOU KNOW, THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY IN QUESTION MAY BE
PRETTY SMALL, SO THEY YOU KNOW,
INTERACTIONS MAY BE MINOR, BUT
JUST SOMETHING TO CONSIDER AS
YOU, YOU KNOW. FORWARD WITH THIS
ITEM. UM DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
OR IF YOU MAY YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE WHAT DO YOU PROPOSING? IN
TERMS OF HOW MUCH TO FUND. CAN
YOU CLEAR? WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
PROPOSING TO FUND RIGHT NOW?
BOTH WHAT WAS AGREED UPON IN THE
BUDGET OF 23. NOW AS PART OF THE
GOVERNORS BUDGET, WE STILL
MAINTAINING THE ONGOING 2
MILLION THROUGH THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND. THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET DOESN'T
REFLECT ANY SORT OF CHANGE FROM
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION. WHAT IS THE
SOURCE OF THE MONEY IN THE
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY FUND?
YES. SO THERE IS A COUPLE OF THE
FIRST SOURCE WAS BACK IN, UM
2019. THERE WAS A ONE TIME UM,
TRANSFER FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO THE HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
RESERVE FUND WHEN IT WAS
CONCEIVED FOR ABOUT FOR WAS
THREE 133.4 MILLION, AND THEN AS
PART OF, UM THE MOST RECENT
BUDGET ACT REVENUE FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY,
WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY DEPOSITED
IN THE GENERAL FUND. NOW UM IS
DEPOSITED INTO THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND. SO
GOING FORWARD, THE ONLY REVENUES
UM, YOU KNOW, FUNDING THAT WOULD
BE GOING INTO THIS SPECIFIC
SPECIAL FUND COMES FROM THE
PENALTY FUND OR COMES FROM THE
PENALTY. SORRY. SO IDEALLY, IT'S
A DIMINISHING BUCKET OF MONEY.
IF THE WAY THE PENALTY WAS
DEVELOPED. YOU KNOW, IT'S MORE
PEOPLE LIKE YOU IN HEALTH CARE.
THE LESS REVENUE WOULD BE SO
BASED ON WHAT WE SAW AS REVENUES
LAST YEAR, WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING
DECREASES IN KIND OF LIKE WHAT I
SAID BEFORE IT. IT DEPENDS ON
HOW YOU WANNA LIKE A IT'S A GOOD
OR A BAD WE HAVE LESS REVENUE
COMING IN, BUT IT ALSO
REPRESENTS THAT MORE PEOPLE ARE
HAVING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. AND
THEN SPECIFICALLY, SO LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATED 2
MILLION. WE HAVE A $39,000
CHARGE AGAINST THE 2 MILLION
DOES. THAT MEANS WE HAVE THE
BALANCE AVAILABLE TO COVER THIS?
I WOULD SAY. AS OF NOW, IT
APPEARS THAT WHAT THE, UM WHAT
COVER CALIFORNIA SCENE IN TERMS
OF ENROLLMENT THAT THE 2 MILLION
IS SUFFICIENT TO COVER WHAT
EXPENSES ARE COMING FROM THIS
POLICY? UM BECAUSE LAST YEAR WAS
A BIG STRIKE HERE. AND OUR COST
WAS 39,000 TOTAL. THAT'S RIGHT,
OK? THERE SHOULD BE THERE IS
STILL SUFFICIENT FUNDING IN THE
FUND AT THIS TIME. I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE I GOT THE PICTURE
HERE. THANK YOU. SORRY MADAM
CHAIR NÓ NÓ NÓ NEVER APOLOGIZE.
ALL ENGAGED IN THIS. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE RIGHT. WE HAD THIS. UM,
WHAT IS IT CALLED THE HOT SUMMER
STRIKE AT IT. HOT LABOR. YEAH,
SUMMER. UM YOU KNOW, BUT THERE
WERE, YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE, UM
UH, UNION WORKERS HAD A LOT OF
BENEFITS AVAILABLE AT HAND TO
COVER THEIR THEY HAD FUN, UH,
ENOUGH VACATION AND SO FORTH
THAT WE WEREN'T THAT THEY DIDN'T
NEED TO DIP INTO THIS FUND. BUT
WE NEVER KNOW RIGHT AND WE ALSO
AVOIDED A STRIKE LAST YEAR WITH
UP S¼ WORKERS. I WOULD HAVE
POTENTIALLY REALLY SHOT THIS
PRICE UP RIGHT CLOSER TO
WHATEVER IT WOULD HAVE BEEN, SO
WE NEVER KNOW WHAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN AND ENSURING
THAT WE DO HAVE ENOUGH
ALLOCATION FOR THAT IS GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT FOR US SEEING THAT
NÓ. OTHER QUESTIONS ARE NEEDED.
THAT CLOSES OUT ISSUE NUMBER
TWO, WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT ITEM
OPEN. MAY I DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BECAUSE YOU. BUT NEVER
MIND. I'M NOT GONNA DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE. THIS IS A
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT. YEP.
UH, SHOULD I BE AT THE TABLE OR
OR HERE IF YOU WANT TO SQUEEZE
IN, THAT'S TOTALLY FINE. YEAH.
THREE MINUTES. TO SHARE YOUR
PROPOSAL WITH US. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DIANNA DOUGLAS
WITH HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE
, CONSUMER ADVOCACY, COALITION
AND CO CHAIRS OF THE HEALTH FOR
ALL COALITION. SINCE 2016.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN REMOVING IMMIGRATION
STATUS IS A BARRIER TO MEDICAL
ENROLLMENT. AS OF THIS YEAR, ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS CAN
ENROLL IN ME NÓ LONGER UNINSURED
NÓ LONGER GETTING SICKER AND
DYING, YOUNGER OR ONE EMERGENCY
AWAY FROM RUIN. IT ALSO MEANS
MORE INSURED AND PAYING PATIENTS
AT THE HOSPITAL'S CLINICS AND
HEALTH SYSTEM ON WHICH WE ALL
RELY, HOWEVER, DUE TO FEDERAL
RESTRICTIONS, UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL UNJUSTLY
EXCLUDED FROM PURCHASING
COVERAGE IN COVERED CALIFORNIA
OUR STATE'S MARKETPLACE, EVEN
USING THEIR OWN MONEY.
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WHO
EARN OVER 138% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LIMIT OR JUST OVER
$20,000 FOR AN INDIVIDUAL DO NOT
QUALIFY FOR ME AND RIGHT NOW
CANNOT SIGN UP FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA PLANS RIGHT NOW OVER
A HALF MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE UNINSURED
BECAUSE THEY EARN TOO MUCH FOR
OUR MEDICAL SAFETY NET AND OTHER
THAN THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS,
THEY WOULD QUALIFY FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA. ANOTHER 100,000
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE EXCLUDED FROM COVERED
CALIFORNIA BY COVERAGE, BUT IT'S
ON THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET. THIS
YEAR. THE HEALTH FOR ALL
COALITION SEEKS TO MOVE MOVE
CALIFORNIA CLOSER TO UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE BY REMOVING THESE
BARRIERS BY CREATING A STATE
BASED MIRRORED MARKETPLACE THAT
REPLICATES COVERED CALIFORNIANS
PLANS, ENROLLMENT AND OTHER
FEATURES. WE CAN REMOVE THIS
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO ACCESS
THIS MIRRORED EXCHANGE WOULD BE
FUNDED SEPARATELY FROM COVERED
CALIFORNIA, BUT WOULD ALLOW FOR
A NEARLY IDENTICAL EXPERIENCE
AND PLAN OFFERINGS. OUR PROPOSAL
SEEKS 15 MILLION IN GENERAL
FUNDS FOR THE INITIAL UPSTART OF
A STATE BASED MIRRORED EXCHANGE.
THIS PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
COVERED CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PLANNING, STAFFING AND
ADMINISTRATIVE AND TECHNICAL
UPSTART OF THIS PROGRAM. TO BE
CLEAR. WE'RE NOT PROPOSING THIS
YEAR TO PROVIDE STATE SUBSIDIES
TO THIS POPULATION, AND MANY
WILL STILL FACE BARRIERS. UM BUT
BEYOND JUST REFLECTING
CALIFORNIA'S VALUE OF INCLUSION,
THE SMEARED MARKETPLACE WOULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THESE
CALIFORNIANS TO SIGN UP FOR
COVERAGE EVEN IF THEY'RE PAYING
FULL PRICE. EVEN IF THIS
ENCOURAGES A SMALL FRACTION TO
ENROLL, IT WILL MEAN THOUSANDS
OF NEW ENROLLEES. CALIFORNIA
SHOULD MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS TO
SECURE OUR ROLE AS A NATIONWIDE
LEADER IN HEALTH COVERAGE, AND
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE IN YOUR BUDGET. THESE
FUNDS NEEDED TO START A MIRROR
MARKETPLACE AND REMOVE SOME OF
THESE FINAL BARRIERS TO
ENROLLMENT FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I KNOW THIS ARE
PROBABLY, UH, NEW PROPOSALS, BUT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS, SO THIS
PROPOSAL IS STILL UNDER REVIEW.
PRELIMINARILY WE WOULD FLAG A
CONCERN THAT THE COST FOR THE
BENEFITS UNDER THIS PROPOSAL ARE
UNKNOWN BUT COULD BE
SUBSTANTIAL. AND THE FUND HAS
COMPETING PRIORITIES FOR, UH,
FOR AFFORDABILITY PROGRAMS TO
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE FUNDS.
HELLO. UH, NOTHING TO ADD HIM,
OK? GO AHEAD, JENNER. YOU KNOW,
I, UM. I SUPPORT THIS CONCEPT. I
REMEMBER HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITH SENATOR RICARDO LARA WHEN
HE WAS HERE IN THE HOUSE ABOUT
WHY WE COULDN'T PROVIDE A SET UP
A SYSTEM WHERE THOSE WHO HAVE
THE MONEY AT LEAST AT SOME LEVEL
COULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO, UM
SECURE HEALTH INSURANCE. OUTSIDE
OF THE OTHER WAYS THAT WE
PROVIDED. I. I MEAN, I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS, AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE ANSWERED YET ABOUT
WHETHER WE CAN DO THIS WITHIN
THE, UM THE STRUCTURE OF COVERED
CALIFORNIA THE WAY IT'S SET UP
HERE, FORGETTING FOR THE MOMENT,
WHICH YOU KNOW WHICH WHICH
PROGRAM IT IS OR WHETHER WE HAVE
TO SET UP A NEW STRUCTURE. THAT
MIRRORS COVERED CALIFORNIA BUT
DUPLICATES STAFF AND ALL OF THE
REST AND WHAT THE COST OF THAT
WOULD BE. UM SEPARATE APART FROM
THE COST OF SUBSIDIES. DO YOU
HAVE ANY? DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
AS TO WHETHER ONE WE WOULD NEED
TO DO THAT? UM AND TWO HAVE
THERE BEEN ANY PROJECTIONS AS TO
THE COST OF THIS UM, THE INITIAL
COST OF DOING SO. SO THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SO OUR OUR PROPOSAL
HERE FOR THE 15 MILLION IS FOR
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
NECESSARY TO SET UP THE
STRUCTURES FOR THIS. THIS IS NOT
FOR THE SUBSIDIES. WE HAVE BEEN
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THE STRUCTURE
WOULD NEED TO LOOK LIKE, UM, TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IT WOULD
NOT NEED TO FULLY AND SEPARATELY
REPLICATE COVERED CALIFORNIA
STAND ALONE, BUT IT DOES NEED TO
BE FUNDED SEPARATELY. SO WE HOPE
THAT THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE ABLE
TO, UM USE SOME OF THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE THAT EXISTS IN COVERED
CALIFORNIA BUT THE STAFFING AND,
UM. STRUCTURE OF IT WOULD NEED
TO ALSO STAND ALONE. UM I DO.
STAFF WOULD NEED TO BE SEPARATE.
I THINK THAT THE FUNDING WOULD
NEED TO BE SEPARATE. SO WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOT
NECESSARILY SEPARATE PEOPLE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SEPARATE
FUNDING, SO THE FUNDING WOULD
NEED TO BE SEPARATE AND COME
FROM THIS OTHER BUCKET THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING. THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION MAKES HERE.
UM I, I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT AS COVERED CALIFORNIA IS,
UM, DOES NOT RECEIVE GENERAL
FUNDS FOR ITS GENERAL
OPERATIONS. WE DO. THAT ONCE THE
STRUCTURE WAS UP AND RUNNING,
AND PEOPLE ARE ENROLLED, THEN IT
WOULD ALSO BE SELF SUSTAINING IN
THE SAME WAY THAT COVERED
CALIFORNIA IS NOT NEEDING TO
CONTINUALLY DRAW IN GENERAL
FUNDS TO PERPETUATE ITSELF, UM,
GOING INTO THE FUTURE. WELL I. I
MEAN, I CERTAINLY THINK WE NEED
TO DO TO THE EXTENT THE BUDGET
ALLOWS IT. WE NEED TO DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO COMPLETE
AN ANALYSIS OF THIS AND MAKE IT
THEN MAKE A DETERMINATION AS
WHETHER AS TO WHETHER THIS IS
PRACTICALLY THE YEAR. TO TAKE
ACTION ON IT OR NOT, BUT I DO
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION. WHETHER $15
MILLION IS THE NUMBER I DON'T
KNOW. BUT THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE. THANK YOU. NÓ FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON MY END. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU. THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK TO ANYTHING
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT EXCHANGE, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBER SARAH FOX,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. I
FIRST WANTED TO START BY
THANKING AND COMPLEMENTING
COVERED CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR
RAPID AND VERY EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HEALTH CARE
FOR STRIKING WORKERS IN JULY,
WHEN BUS DRIVERS WENT ON STRIKE
AND WERE LOSING THEIR HEALTH
COVERAGE THEY SPRING INTO ACTION
HAD BILINGUAL STAFF AVAILABLE
AND IT WAS SEAMLESS. UM AND IT
WAS VERY EFFECTIVE, ALTHOUGH
LOOMING STRIKES THAT WE MANAGED
TO AVOID WOULD HAVE EATEN UP THE
2 MILLION WE ARE GOING INTO A
YEAR WHEN WE HAVE ANOTHER
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY STRIKE
AYAT AND TEAMSTERS WE HAVE HOTEL
WORKERS WE HAVE, UM GROCERY
WORKERS, DRUG STORE WORKERS ALL
GOING IN WITH A NEW MILITANCY
WHERE WE MAY HAVE STRIKES AS
PEOPLE WERE LOSING THEIR HOUSING
DURING THE ENTERTAINMENT UNION
STRIKES. THEY KNEW THEY HAD
HEALTH CARE AND NOT HAVING A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION CREATES
A LEVEL OF ANXIETY AND
INSTABILITY THAT KNOW IF THAT
BENEFIT WILL BE THERE. AND SO
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE DAYS
WHERE WE'RE ASKING PEOPLE TO
STOCK UP ON MEDICATIONS AND
THEIR EPIPENS BEFORE THEY GO ON
STRIKE. WE WOULD URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE AN CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION, UM TO THE HEALTH
CARE FOR STRIKING WORKERS
PROGRAM SO WE DON'T HAVE THAT
UNCERTAINTY. BUT IF THE MONEY IS
NOT USED, IT'S THERE IN THE FUND
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS MATTER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. SHANE
GUSSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS. S¼ A G, A FA UNITE
HERE. THE MACHINIST, THE UTILITY
WORKERS UNION OF AMERICA AND THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION ALL IN
. UM UH, STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
COMMENTS JUST MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE SARAH FLOCK. UM A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
FULFILLS THE PROMISE OF A 2530
OF CONTINUING HEALTH BENEFITS
FOR OUR MEMBERS WHO
UNFORTUNATELY, MAY FIND
THEMSELVES ON STRIKE. I THINK AN
INTERESTING A COMPONENT OF THIS
ALSO IS THAT THE VIABILITY OF
THIS AND RELIABILITY OF THE FUND
ACTUALLY, AND MAYBE
COUNTERINTUITIVELY WORKS TO
PREVENT STRIKES BECAUSE
EMPLOYERS DO NOT ENGAGE IN SOME
OF THE HARD BARGAINING AND
FORCING PEOPLE OUT ON STRIKE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THIS
TOOL TO THREATEN MEMBERS SO WE
WOULD URGE A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OK, YAMAMOTO
WITH èC P. UH, THANK YOU, FIRST
TO THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE FANTASTIC WORK. YOU GUYS
DO THE IMPORTANT WORK YOU DO?
UH, èC P APPRECIATES THE
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR REDUCING
COST SHARING TO SUPPORT
AFFORDABILITY OF HEALTH
COVERAGE. WE ALSO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE A
BUDGET INVESTMENT TO COVER THE
START UP COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH A
MIRRORED, UH, HEALTH BENEFITS
EXCHANGE, WHICH WOULD BE
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SANDRA PAUL WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY, ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE HEALTH FOR ALL COALITION.
UM I, UM SPEAK ON ISSUE NUMBER
THREE AND ALSO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE, UM,
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY IN THE
2024 25 BUDGET TO FACILITATE
CREATION OF A MIRRORED, UH,
MARKETPLACE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS, HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN. BETH BRONOWSKI, THE S¼ E
Ó. CALIFORNIA WON A SECOND. THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY LABOUR
COLLEAGUES AGAIN DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR EFFORTS IN
2023. WE LEARNED A LOT FROM THIS
PAST SUMMER THROUGH THIS, UM
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION. WE KNOW
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION IS THE
WAY TO GO. THERE ARE JUST SO
MANY UNKNOWNS WHEN WORKERS MAKE
DECISIONS. HARD DECISION TO GO
OUT ON STRIKE, ESPECIALLY IF
THAT STRIKE LASTS LONG AND
KNOWING THAT WE HAVE THIS
BENEFIT AVAILABLE TO THEM, UH,
MEANS EVERYTHING TO THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES, AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL ALSO SEND A STRONG MESSAGE
TO THEIR EMPLOYERS. NOT TO TAKE
AWAY THEIR COVERAGE,
ADDITIONALLY, AS A PARTNER IN
THE HEALTH FOR ALL COALITION
ONE, ALSO SECOND, THE COMMENTS
MADE BY DANNA DOUGLAS AND OTHERS
WHO IS IMPORTANCE OF TAKING
INITIAL STEPS FORWARD THIS YEAR
TO STAND UP ON THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS CHLOE
STOCK. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER èC IP èC IS PROUD TO
HAVE TO BE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
HEALTH ACCESS. UM WE'VE WORKED
ON THE HEALTH FOR ALL CAMPAIGN
FOR THE LAST DECADE, AND WE WANT
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
SUCCESSFULLY ACHIEVING MEAL FOR
ALL WITH OVER 500,000 IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS STILL WITHOUT
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE DUE TO
EXCLUSIONS IN THE COVERED
CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE, WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING IN THE 2024 2025 STATE
BUDGET TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS, REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS CAN ACCESS
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
WHEN EVERYONE IS ABLE TO ACCESS
THE CARE THEY NEED. WE MOVE
CLOSER TO OUR VISION OF AN
EFFECTIVE AND EQUITABLE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM BY COVERING AS
MANY LIVES AS POSSIBLE AND
PROMOTING THE WELL BEING OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HØI DIANA DOUGLAS AGAIN
COMMENTING ON OTHER ISSUES,
THANK YOU FIRST JUST WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU TO COVER
CALIFORNIA AND TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE WORK IN
BRINGING US TO THIS DAY OF
HAVING THESE COST SHARING
REDUCTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION TODAY ON HOW MUCH
FURTHER EVEN THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
GO IN 2025. WE APPRECIATE THAT
PARTNERSHIP. UM AND WE ALSO I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT OUR LABOR COLLEAGUES IN
THE WORK ON HEALTH CARE FOR
STRIKING WORKERS TO FURTHER
FIGURE OUT HOW TO ENSURE THIS
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE. UM, AND
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER WAY. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE CALIFORNIANS
ARE ARE GETTING COVERAGE AND
STAYING ON COVERAGE. UM AND THE
ISSUE OF THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE THAT CAME
UP I. I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
HOPE THAT NUMBER WILL GO DOWN
BECAUSE WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE
INSURED AND NOT UNINSURED AND
PAYING THAT PENALTY. BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT, UM, WE'VE DRAWN, YOU
KNOW 400 MILLION, UM, A YEAR IN
REVENUE FROM THAT PENALTY
REVENUE. IT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
AND WHILE WHILE IT DOES STILL
EXIST, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO MAKE SURE IT'S
HELPING TO MAKE HEALTH CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
SEE NÓ ONE ELSE COMING FORWARD
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
CONCLUDES HER PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THAT CONCLUDES BUDGET OF THREE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
. I THINK THIS ACTUALLY WOULD BE
ONE OF OUR SHORTER HEARINGS SO
STRAP IN Y. ALL RIGHT. BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE, NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES HAS
ADJOURNED.